the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club complications arose ensued and were
overcome at the US Women's and US Open
championships in St Louis if you're
waiting for the opportune moment to see
the nation's best chess this is it Bano
caruana is without a doubt one of the
best Grand Masters you've ever heard of
and he's making noise clenching his
third us title Carissa Yip took no
prisoners forcing her opponent to walk
the plank piling clear first in the
process it's down to two who will sail
off into the sunset as US Women's
Champion the final round of can't miss
chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome chess fans to the final day the
championship day here at the US Women's
Chess Championship and Us open Chess
Championship it's been a fantastic event
so far and the stage is set who are
going to be our Champions let's go to
the studio and find
out welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships we have an
open Champion but the women are still
battling as the final round starts right
now hello everyone and welcome thank you
for joining us I'm kaarina am TOA and
I'm here with yaser Sahan and Christian
Killa Kate this has been wonderful the
whole tournaments you Christian I've
enjoyed every minute but all good things
have to come to the end it's the last
round yeah lot of on is on stake in the
women's section oh no question about it
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for our Championship round we have a
repeat champion in the open as Fabiano
just played dominant chess and a
deserved winner the fight for silver in
the open is going to be intense but the
fight for the championship in the ladies
is going to be nerve-wracking Kate do
the honors tell our audience the
standings let's start with the ladies
absolutely let's take a look at the
women's section so here we have Karis
saip leading the competition with half a
point after a very smooth win yesterday
while beging to here janova did not
claim a three4 repetition and lost her
game and then there is a three-way
two-way time for the third place arena
crash and Alis Lee with 6 and a half
points and the standings in the open
section here we have already the
champion Fabiano Karana who clinched his
title with seven and a half points out
of 10 but there is significant prize
difference so we still fight for the
second place with two-way tie Wes liso
and lener Dominguez with six points with
MRA on the outside looking in and here's
our graphic here he is our 2023 repeat
Champion big congratulation to Grand
Master Fabiano Carana absolutely our
congratulations just outstanding and
tell us about the format for these two
national championships we play two 12
player run Robins which means each
player plays everybody else in their
respective section we play classical
chess 90 minutes for first 40 moves
followed by 30 minutes for rest of the
game and there is a 30second increment
from move one no draw offers allowed
here and traditional scoring system one
point for win half a point for draw and
zero points for loss real chances of a
playoff just remind me how a playoff tie
works so if two players tie for first
there is a two game rapid match with 10
minutes and 2 second increment if still
tight Armageddon and Armageddon means 5
minutes for white four minutes for black
and black gets the draw those are
nerve-wracking events those Armageddon
games and not much left to tell us the
schedule today we have the last round
11th Round And if necessary we will have
playoff tomorrow on October 18 starting
again at 1:20 p.m. Center time Christian
you have a number of what if
scenarios to uh tell us about the
potential playoff absolutely good to see
you guys it's finally here this is it
the championship day and all eyes are
definitely on the ladies section let's
take a look at the wtif scenario
as we see this historical race between
the two ladies finishing it out take a
look at this if Carissa wins today
Karissa wins outright because as we have
seen the standings she's half a point in
the lead if Karissa draws today and beg
him wins that's an interesting scenario
right there because then we have a
playoffs if Karissa loses and beg him
draws then we're going to have a playoff
once again so a lot of things at stake a
lot of things can happen Karissa draws
and begging draws then obviously Karissa
wins the championship outright and she
will be a two-time national champion
Karissa loses and begim wins begim lip
frogs her in the standings and wins the
championship outright a lot of things
can happen in this very important
matchups and let's start with this
head-to-head toir NOA versus Jennifer Yu
and I have to say this is a difficult
one for toir NOA we've seen how
difficult it was yesterday against the
eight time National Champion Arena Crush
she didn't win a single game against her
and unfortunately yesterday did not
change that and as you can see Zero wins
two losses and zero draws In classical
chess between these two ladies a
Monumental task for begim toan NOA to
win this Championship or force a playoff
and let's take a look at what's
happening in karissa's game well this
one I have to say she's the favorite
with the white pieces against the player
that she faced before ruy yangyang that
is but she never beat Ru yangyang zero
wins one loss one draw I have to say
though ruang yangang is struggling so
far especially in the second half of the
event right now tied for seventh
position a lot of things still can
happen we still have that fight for
second place in the open section A lot
of games explosive ones that is we're
just about to call absolutely but some
challenges uh for our leaders as we see
pby uh very relaxed he's already the
champion what's what does he have to be
nervous about and uh as we get ready for
our uh 11th and final show uh Kate uh do
the honors tell our audience who they
can expect pairings wise start with the
ladies yes we have a number of really
important matches today so we start with
Lee against eswaran that is a match for
the third place right toir janova the
leader against defending Champion
Jennifer Yu that's going to be decided
the gold and silver medal right
abrahamian playing Crush now that would
be a comp a match right there that I
would have said hey that might decide
first not even close not for this event
yep now she really wants to win or make
a draw to uh to clinge that title
against Yan and cantes playing zatonski
and P kashian playing PID and tell us
about the pairings in the open section
yes board one saw against Karana number
two versus number one in the competition
but number one has already been DET Cher
yeah and then Dominguez playing Neiman
that's going to be for that second place
very important game playing Robson
savian playing tank Shanklin playing
Jong and Mishra playing arunan that
final game also that suddenly became an
interesting game is leavon want to get
50% Mishra still in the fight for a
little bit of that second place third
place monies and talking about monies
let's start what's going on in the prize
fund for the ladies very generous one
$152,000 with first place winning 40,000
second place 30,000 third place 20,000
all the way to the 12th Place $4,000
exactly we'll go back to the World Chess
Hall of Fame and thank them most
profusely for a really wonderful
tournament I think the players all the
feedback we get from the players is that
they love the tournament Hall the pieces
uh they all feel incredibly com
comfortable playing and you see there's
a friendly atmosphere
right these girls know each other so
well from Junior Championships they're
friends absolutely but I have to say
ruang such a difficult task today
nevertheless you know you're not playing
for that much in terms of standings but
you're playing for something you're
playing to spoil somebody's tournament
you might as well find some motivation
in that
and I had to I had to smile or smirk
Kate when you said oh they're so
friendly and thinking about Hans nean no
they're
not they're tough tough tough no coach
uh what did
you say to beam uh about today's game
and what well it was mostly about
yesterday's game because that was a very
painful one so I just told her you know
to uh chin up because it's very easy to
beat yourself up after absolutely it's
not about losing it's about the way she
lost right she had that draw in her
pocket she knows that she knows that she
could have went into this round as uh
the co- leer of the event so definitely
that's painful but you have to move
forward and take it one game at a time
and very important not to focus on
karissa's game just focus on your game
forget about what Karissa does and let
the pieces of the puzzle fall in their
places yeah for me it was always uh very
easy if I ever was in a in a state of
where I'm playing for first place in the
last round I was incredibly excited it
was like forget everything that happened
never happened I'm here to win first
place give me a chance let me go let me
go and beum has a chance of winning
first place and it's that's exactly what
she has to do is focus solely on her
game on her game not worry about Chris's
and that matters in her preparation as
well because we've discussed how
important preparation is as you go into
this critical games and that's what she
has to do she cannot let herself think
about what happened yesterday just focus
on your preparation make sure you come
at the board with the best weapons that
you could possibly have and then just
play your game exact place we see beam
taking her seat and Carissa our
tournament leader wanded
through you're good to go
Carissa uh when I look at these games
and I'm looking at the names I'm seeing
Robson and I'm just thinking you know
how many points Ray has left on the
table what kind of energy he's going to
be bringing to this game because again
he's not fighting for a Podium finish so
many players are not Sam Shanklin as
well
uh you know it's strange he could have
had so many more points and you think
about you know and here we see Hans uh
with the black pieces today just
thinking what happened to me I was I was
in the lead I was doing really really
well uh that game with Fabiano that was
cruel and that was not the only one oh
no right I think he lost some very
painful games before that as well in
fact before he met Fabiano I think he
was half out of two so with that loss
against Fabiano half out of three and
then he slow the bleeding against wesle
so yesterday but still such a good start
for him and unfortunate second half for
Carissa yep and Yuen open Sicilian I
mean we've seen white duck these open
Sicilian discussions it's nice to just
finally see just a straightforward let's
go oh yeah no that that's actually a
very interesting choice um I'm curious
what Kissa is going to do I don't think
she played Knight C3 did she I think we
have Knight C3 Knight C6 on the board if
I'm not mistaken so yeah this is the
game that Carissa played against my
student at the world juniors that's the
line that we prepared with the black
pieces and Karissa got a losing position
because she forgot her Theory with the
white pieces with the white pieces
completely losing position like it was
minus four minus five no out after like
10 15 moves so maybe that's what ruang
is looking for now Karissa has a big
Choice okay Knight to B5 that's one and
Knight takes C6 which is a much more
aggressive approach that's too yeah
Knight to B5 allows ideas of Bishop to
B4 things of that nature which with very
precise and very good play have shown at
least uh the Practical results that
black is more or less fine yeah it it it
took me the longest time by the way I I
was disbelieving my own two eyes that uh
when I was a teen and I I saw this
position for the first time and I played
the move Knight D6 check and they said
yaser this was a mistake because after
King E7
uh black is better yeah and I was like y
but the King has been
compromised to Castle anymore like how
could black be better but that is indeed
the case and uh uh the the actual main
move against Bishop B4 is A3 uh but I
have always thought of this particular
move order by black as an invitation to
transpose into a SES that's right yes so
if you want to play the jikov you play
D6 if you want to play something uh that
has some independent value then you play
Bishop to B4 gotcha all right we'll keep
a a watchful thinking whether karisa is
going to go into open uh Sicilian main
variations or if she's going to play
more securely maybe some G3 fianchetto
saying you know I just need to draw for
a playoff and maybe I'll just push over
and win in long game I don't think so no
no I don't think so knowing Karissa and
knowing the typee of player that she is
she wants to win this one she wants to
win it outright because uh she knows
that begim still despite the fact that
she lost that game yesterday she's still
in tremendous shape and Jennifer U is
not we've seen that in this competition
so definitely I think aresa is coming
into this one thinking look I'm playing
a player that has only four points I've
been in tremendous shape I've been
winning game after game after game so I
might as well try to push this one and
finish the job right now and by the way
if I could ask Christian in the game
once again between
Carissa I see beging was a bit surprised
by the cameram snuck up on her there and
wait a minute J in the kitchen exactly
I'm just making my tea on cut cut me
some slack here um what do they call
this variation that goes Knight takes C6
that's the Four Knights takes but no no
this this very specific uh line of EA
Knight D5 Knight Knight E4 Queen C7
F4 yeah I only see it as a Four Knights
variation it's just called the four
nights because that's a whole invol hug
it's it's a huge line and white can play
in a lot of different ways black can
also deviate early on Queen C7 is one of
the moves you can also go Bishop to B7
with the idea of C5 this is something
that the world champion Magnus Carlson
has played recently especially in Rapid
time control
he doesn't play this in classical chess
as much because it's a very dangerous um
decision but look it seems like Ru Yang
is inviting a fight and again it's a
difficult decision for Karissa because
if she did not expect this she knows how
difficult and how theoretical and
concrete the lines are and she has the
experience of being completely lost out
of the opening in her last game in this
line so there's some fear perhaps some
doubt sipping in she also has the option
of going night DB5 which is I have to
say a much more practical decision in
the situation that she is in I would
myself go night DB5 exactly and in that
game of beum and Jennifer you we have a
nimzo Indian and Kate this is always an
awkward moment uh when you up against a
player uh in this case Jennifer you
who's always beat you yeah I mean you
have these moments of Doubt these these
uh thought fearful thoughts if you will
like what am I going to do uh against a
person um and on the other hand you do
feel confident because you do have an
incredible tournament while Jennifer is
struggling in this tournament so I think
this boost of confidence can help you uh
play this game exactly E2 E3 and uh
coach without trying to reveal too much
uh expect the expected position on the
board well let's see Castle again I'm
not wor working with begging for this
tournament um so I don't actually know
what she prepared I only gave her some
you know uh Tech ADV technical advice
yes yes you know we have to be here
early on at the studio there's not much
time oh man I can see you saying B I'm
sorry you're on your own for this one
you know to uh and Bishop to D2 okay yes
Bishop to D2 yes we uh it's become the
go-to anti nimzo is isn't this what she
faced
against who was it against it wasn't
against Arena or perhaps it was against
Arena Rook E8 D5 Rook E8 or D5 Knight F3
Rook E8 and then A6 that idea with A6
yes yes that was what she played
yesterday against uh there you go she
takes a page out of Arena's Playbook
wait a minute I felt I was on the back
fo C by way guys what if we turn our
attention to the open section and the
champion Fabiano Karana they have a very
complicated position oh this is they're
Bing it out this is all complic it looks
exciting and but it's all engine
generated Theory I was think I'm not
familiar with this line but I see the
clock Wesley so 1 hour 34 minutes
Fabiana 1 hour 31 minutes so they know
exactly what they are doing here yeah
and I think Wesley has probably
practiced this opening just about as
well as any of the top Grand Masters and
it always stunned me when I had to
comment at I saw this position on the
board and go wow the players are really
throwing the patties and my co-
commentators would say yes sir I'm sorry
to inform you but this is all welln
Theory uh we talk about the fight for
second as we see Knight takes E3 by the
way on the board Knight takes C3 okay
all right Bishop takes C3 and G takes F4
are the main moves Knight takes C3 is
also playable G takes F4 Bishop takes
C3 um how many times is Knight because
that one is actually a little bit uh off
the Beaten Track only 13 games with this
move Knight to C3 this seems to be one
of those typical situations in which
you've known this position you've
analyzed it but hey let's take a look
with the new engines and see what they
say and then they realized like a year
ago that you can also take with a knight
on C3 really yes yes like the previous
engines probably were giving white some
sort of an advantage and then they
started looking a bit deeper understood
that KNX C3 is also an option uh help
help me out here as far as like a
conventional Engine versus a cloud
engine so if I put this this position in
a conventional and my well I'll give you
the example there there there you go
this is a conventional engine that we
have right here not very powerful but
still very very good can be absolutely
anybody in the world very easily um but
this is saying
0.6 that's a decent Advantage decent
opening Advantage for white but again if
you put it on a cloud Engine with 128
cores or you know things of monstrous
like that then you know if you let it
thing for a while if you help uh the
engine with a few moves uh as you go
deeper and deeper you understand that in
fact it's z00 Z which brings up my next
question is okay so now you have got
this marvelous
monstrosity This Cloud engine and it
analyzes how many ply deep we're talking
about a Ply being a half a move so I
make a move and my opponent makes a move
that's two ply yes so using a cloud
engine will it analyze 20 moves
sometimes more more more than that more
than 40 they usually go up to 40 very
quickly like in a few seconds they go up
to 40 yes in a few seconds yes yes so
they could go as deep as an ending or
that's right even further that's right
and then if you let it think for a
little bit longer then uh it becomes a
bit more precise because sometimes in
those splies they miss certain things
and you have to help it um as you make
the moves on the board right and then it
becomes aware of other options along the
way but if you let it think yes you can
you can get quite a deep uh picture of
what's happening in the position simply
extraordinary and in the case of both
these
two well world class Grand Masters they
with the strongest engin they're they're
as deep as you possibly can guess but it
looks like Wesley is thinking he already
lost 3 minutes right well he had one you
know 134 right oh he's he's uh
remembering
his well if you got to remember it you
know 60 ply
deep I mean hello6 is this the is this
the conventional G takes F4 yes this has
been played now we're uh up to 23 games
in this position he takes D7 should
probably be the move so it's a little
bit trans transposing perhaps some
transpositions yeah like G takes F4
instead of Knight takes C3 D takes C6
and then Knight takes C3 stuff uh stuff
of that nature okay right now we have
Bishop takes D7 I'm sort of curious what
he's going to choose and I see you've
got a game of Fabby right in front of
you also F G3 yes yes so Fabby has
played this exact position not with f f
takes G3 but with Bishop to D7 and now
we see the change he takes on G3 first
so in the previous game the one that you
were mentioning that you see against
Anish giri Bishop takes D7 was the move
Bishop takes C3 and then the player
still made a draw the thing is about
this position you have draws in a lot of
variations in fact and that's why Knight
takes C3 Works Bishop takes C3 Works in
that particular position um at this
point you can also take take on F4 so
you have three moves take on C3 with
both pieces or take on F4 those are the
main lines um we got all the way to this
position we're expecting Rook A8 and
we're expecting it quickly so let's keep
an eyen Rook A8 on the
board by the way this shows us how
intensely players work before the
tournament right how much Theory they
analyze so they're well prepared
absolutely Bishop F5 also all stand
stuff yes oh yes Bishop takes C3 we're
expecting by the way isn't this the game
of West liso versus C CaRu from the
American
Cup could very well be Bishop takes
C3 I'm trying to remember and I'm
remembering a very similar uh ending
Queen to D1 we're going to see now Queen
takes D1 Bishop takes D7 in fact is what
uh Wesley's he played Bishop takes D7
okay okay Bishop takes D7 Bishop takes a
a one okay I think the players are
actually uh going through the motions
maybe blitzing out some some drawish
line Bishop takes
A1 and from Wesley's point of view a
draw Kate gives him six and a half but
it does open up a possibility for lanir
to take clear second lanir would have to
overcome Hans Neeman right and maybe if
Mishra wins then Mishra th with Wesley
for the third place exactly by the way
they are still BL
there's never been a different result
than draws in this position yes Bishop
takes B7 week back Queen takes
C5 by the way first real threat Queen
takes G3 check right right yeah with
Queen takes E5 Bishops of opposite color
well I mean I'm with you on this one uh
Christian you could almost call the game
Draw at this point because it's it's
such an equal uh position let's go to
the game of lanir and see what's
happening as a lanir cross of Swords
with Hans nean this is
a yes it it these days it's kind of hard
to tell if it came out of a Joko piano
with Bishop C4 or Ru Lopez because often
times the bishop ends up on B3 usually
The Telltale sign is the Pawn on B5 as
far as the Berlin or not and anti
Marshall and uh the players are still uh
well within uh theoretical B maybe we
can jump back just for a second to the
game of karisa and ruang Yen because she
did take her castling rights away and
she has this really cool line I played
it for White Once I actually lost this
game I have some bad feeling about it
but I analyze it deeply it's not that
easy really to play uh for white so with
this bishop F4 so first first of all it
was Knight B5 and it wasn't Bishop B4
right it was Bishop C5 now this is a a
wrinkle for me because I'm so used to
Bishop B4 or
D6 um Bishop wait a minute hold on I and
now I'm confusing myself no no Bishop C5
is a bit strange right yes it's a
sideline it is a sideline it's
considered to be better for white but
because I can actually play the moov
Bishop E3 here Force you more or less to
take E3 now after check King E7 it's not
that easy to
evict this Knight like I'm going to go
Queen D2 and Castle's long yeah but I
think the idea is that you go King f8 oh
and then Knight E8 like quickly the so
take okay so King F King f8 takes and
now Knight E8 wow okay so Bishop C5 a
wrinkle for me Knight check King E7 now
Bishop F4 simply defending that Knight
kind of forcing black to play E5 to give
me that D5 Square as well as in this
case first have to do intermediate the
F5 square right I sh King went back to
f8 Bishop G8 Bishop G5
D6 okay who's blitzing out their moves
now rang rangang like this is all part
of her and
what what do they call this
opening also the four night variation
again uh I'm sure I'm sure I can see
more but uh I don't want to press that
button you know what okay you know
what's going to happen with my board so
we're going to leave it at four night
variation apparently our director is
saying the Cobra variation I'm not sure
if I believe him but that's the Cobra
Tom this is Tom we're talking about
Cobra uh what's happening in this uh
line well now you have to address the
idea of Bishop takes F5 because I don't
think you want to allow that you can do
so with Knight to E3 that's one of the
ways and to my eyes at least is very
logical right because you want to go
towards D5 okay set up this pin already
so you might as well try to take
advantage of it and now the question is
okay
H6 my question is what about Bishop to
H4 and this the engine really doesn't
like after G5 Bishop to G3 and Bishop to
E6 saying that black has a very good
position very stable position wow
despite of the fact that all these H6 G5
ideas H4 doesn't seem to come with a lot
of uh Power in the position because I
just simply defend that Rook with King
to G7 so this is something that Ru Yang
definitely analyzed at home at the same
time if you have to go H6 Bishop takes
F6 Queen takes F6 now you're going to
play for the D5 square and yes it makes
a lot of sense that white still
preserves her opening Advantage due to
the fact that you have such a stable
control over D5 square and you can
reinforce that with the move Bishop to
C4 this is part of the mainline Theory
Bishop to E6 again this is something
more of a Gamble from ruang in this one
I'm saying okay I know that with best
play I'm probably going to get a worse
position out of the opening but at the
same time psychologically I understand
what I have to do I understand what's
what's at stake right right and what's
at stake for you specifically for
Karissa there's going to be a lot of
nerves so she's trying to play against
karissa's nerves in this one play
spoilers
role Carissa looks very calm at the
board she always does I must say she's
looking at her opponent like what are
you trying to trick me with it's a
gamble it's a slight gamble we've been
seeing the L uh section especially
thanks to the efforts of Karissa a
number of Kings in Indian defenses I've
just turned my attention to the game of
Alice Lee versus asria and uh I'm seeing
one of my uh pet lines against the Kings
Indian as well uh 92 and 92 93 I also
liked you know the sameish as well as H3
the idea uh was to uh get in the move G4
so for example if I could just put a
move on the board and you would play
conventionally Let's just say E5 A5 yeah
and the whole idea of the setup was I
know that you're aspiring as black to
play the move uh F5 and so I would like
meet you ahead of the race I meet you at
the finish line and I'd be setting up my
pieces in such a way as to make the move
F5 yeah I thought G3 looks very nice
because sometimes on G1 it's unclear
what the Knight is doing for example in
samish I'm always like okay how do I get
that guy out exactly uh in this
particular case uh Alice had a different
approach in mind and that approach I
think was based on the idea of H4
H5 uh shria kind of nipped it in the bud
with her own H5 and bling very quickly
both of the players as if all of this is
standard and maybe it is um very
different approach but in any case the
Knight on
G3 is making it very awkward for black
to play the move F5 let's say for
argument sake I just castle and the
desirable F5 is going to unfortunately
leave a Pawn on H5 hanging the again the
desirable recapture being G6 Stakes F5
but at the cost of the Pawn on H5 uh
intriguing uh you're immediate I feel
like like we have a slightly uh similar
position I mean the structure is almost
the same in the game uh that t abam
played with uh Karis so there was like
this bishop D7 C6 we were talking about
maybe some B5 ideas to kind of break in
on that Queen side exactly all right
we'll keep an eye on this one and
Christian uh what has caught your
attention is we're in the championship
rounds baby well let's uh yes yes we are
yes we already have one Champion let's
not forget about that it's all about the
ladies and I'm looking always at this
line at this ladies to NOA and Karissa
Karissa we've seen what happened she
hasn't played since but take a look at
this 95 we left it somewhere around here
and we remember Rook to E8 followed by
A6 that was be him's choice in
yesterday's game against
Arena Jennifer plays B6 which is the
main line C takes D5 take D and now
Knight to E5 5 Bishop to D3 by far the
main line Rook to C1 as well but Knight
to E5 okay it's already asking a very
serious question and you have to address
it immediately if you do go Bishop to B7
which by the way it's the most obvious
move in the position looks very convin
then I go Bishop to D3 and in fact it's
not that good what I was saying and I
was saying this yesterday as well you
have to put as much pressure on the
Knight on E5 as fast as possible
otherwise white is going to have enough
resources to stabilize in the center for
example Bishop to D3 now you go Knight
bd7 I can go F4 in this position yes F4
you go Bishop to D6 it doesn't really
matter anymore uh you don't get the type
of play that you want and in fact the
best way to do so to get the play that
you want Bishop to C3 was the move that
was played in the game is Bishop to D6
followed by Rook to E8 you can start
with Rook to E8 as well because after
Bishop to D3 Bishop to D6 F4 this is not
that good C5 ideas are going to come in
the position and the problem is you're
not as fast as you should be C fast C5
for example let's go castle if I
remember correctly was it h maybe I'm uh
mishandling the position because from
what I remember I had to put the Knight
on C6 and Target The Pawn on D4 so let's
try to do that again Bishop B7 and
Knight C6 perhaps yes yes Bishop to B7
is one way Bishop to A6 is another way
but again it's all about the fight
against the Knight on E5 and to be
honest with the move that she played
Bishop takes C3 you're kind of helping
me already Bishop takes C3 I didn't even
have to play A3 I'm going to say okay
thank you very much give me two Bishops
Bishop takes C3 and Knight to E4 I
understand you will probably take that
Bishop back I'm not going to go Bishop
to B4 and allow C5 I don't want that but
Bishop to D3 this is a very good
position if you take on C3 I take back
and now you're starting to feel the heat
in the position position because I'm
going to go Castle F4 I always have in
the back pocket C4 to change the
structure and get to your C7 Pawn is a
very stable long-term Advantage for
white so Bishop takes C3 I have to say
it's not looking good for Jennifer again
we're still early Jennifer still hasn't
made any big blunders in the position I
have say some imprecisions up to this
point yeah Rook C1 came quickly
as beum I think this indicates she she
has a preference for recapturing on C3
with the Rook MH yeah putting pressure
maybe on the I also think that maybe
after Bishop D3 black can play
immediately Bishop A6 trying to like
trade the Bishops or maybe bishop adding
that uh exchange on C3 so with Rook C1
beggy may be waiting for that Bishop A6
and then recapturing on A6 immediately
with uh kind of saving that one tempo
that's one way yes yes that's one way to
look at it for sure now again it's all
about the Knight on E5 we need to kick
that Knight out and we need to do it
fast of course F4 and this is the case
right now F4 doesn't work right because
of Queen to H4 yeah don't do this you
can take on E5 and then Queen to H4 the
idea being that once you go G3 I take on
G3 the game is over right so don't do
this is a very typical um puz Rush
puzzle Rush tactic yes tactic that we
learned in the first uh six months by
the way I I I get credit for that when
when the puzzle Rush gives me this
tactic and I go Queen H4 gives me a
green check yeah oh yeah it's another
one baby you you feel like you got the
bonus that I know this but you have to
be fast also I know they count the time
as well so you know gets freaky but your
immediate Knight D7 I boy I mean doesn't
it pres present that lovely Knight C6
you want to go to C6 the problem is
Queen to F6 you resign on the spot gosh
darn it that's a problem good morning
morning St Louis boom yes yes of course
the Dusk and I don't again no F4 no
Knight to C6 so what are you going to do
probably you have to come back but again
I don't like what uh beim did with this
move Rook to C1 because if he go Bishop
to D3 first and then Knight to D7 this
is a completely different uh situation I
can take on D7 and now I can go Queen to
H5 attack and this is different because
you cannot take the bishop anymore at
least not before you weaken your Pawn
structure first of all you still have to
defend the pawn on D5 no time for D6
because Queen takes D5 so in this way
white would have gotten a nice Advantage
stable nice Advantage maybe I can even
go castle at some point in save my
Bishop if I manage to do that save that
dark Square Bishop then I'm going to uh
really enjoy my Bishop air for the
remainder of the game that's not going
to happen after Rook to C1 what
F6
she just played the move F6 Jennifer oh
this is a mistake this is a strategical
mistake
D Knight Knight D3 Knight F4 yes that's
exactly right oh my goodness no no no
this is not looking good for Jennifer
perhaps begim in her
preparation well Jennifer for sure
missed
IDE but perhaps beg him spotted a
weakness in Jennifer's understanding of
certain type of structures and positions
and perhaps that's one of them F7 F6
well Knight D3 is begging to be
played um this has really suddenly
became a very big Advantage for beam as
uh I'm looking at Knight D3 followed by
Knight F4 and I just like wow wow there
are so many pieces still to develop so
what is
master3 immedi Ben fighting gold say
never play F6 never play F3 uh you're
weakening your king side too much KN D3
and already a huge Advantage just in
huge again it's a strategical Advantage
it can develop nicely and you're not
risking as much like it's going to
increase slowly but surely you're going
to have problems with that pawn on D5 if
you do take on C3 then I have options I
can take with a B Pawn I can take with
the Rook as well and put more pressure
on C7 probably with the Rook especially
after Rook to C1 well indeed because uh
if I have if you have to play C7 C6 that
pawn on C6 is on an open F half openen
file and it's backwards for forever
essentially yes and in the meanwhile I
can see that this Knight wants to go to
F4 so you have ideas like Knight takes
D5 and Bishop C4 for me I I see this as
well I feel like black is gonna be
struggling now for the rest the game
yeah I don't Pleasant position no I I
don't even want to make a suggestion
here I just say take it back uh this is
not good how is Carissa doing hasn't
played yet so let's take look around on
all the games in the wom absolutely the
last move was D7 D6 well let's jump to
tatev and Arena and uh I really uh think
that this is an incredibly different and
important approach when I
remember the game that Talia had played
where she played D6 and Bishop D7 and
Knight F6 and walked into a situation
where she was literally losing out of
the opening unlike that game ARA Arena
has played it much more Cally she's kept
her night on G8 so the whole G4 G5 isn't
coming with a big Tempo and the Knight
doesn't have a square in this case but
thei move is very interesting I feel
like gra you don't usually grab that
space like too early right you start
with F4 you develop that bishop or King
B1 exact but TF is playing very fast on
that King side yeah King B1 you're
usually toss in in uh that move so it's
awkward as long as the queen remains on
D4 it's awkward to develop the kingside
pieces so it's uh incumbent upon black
to get rid of the queen right and one uh
way of doing that is by playing Knight
to E7 follow let's just put King B1 on
the board for a moment and now with the
move Knight to C6 we can drive the queen
away which means that we can develop the
bishop and Castle uh I'm sure we're
still in theory you know yest I'm
wondering after Knight E7 please can I
just try to punish you Bishop takes B5
yeah I was about to say you're going to
sacrifice uh against my uh Queen side
because I want to jump with my NE on the
D6 and then F7 and yes yes so uh have I
blundered upon I probably have and the
question is something like this I got
the two
Bishops probably it's not it's not
enough yeah because rookie one we know
about a kind of strategic sacrifice
night5 that Karissa already played in
this tournament yeah and again that was
against um
Talia the Knight C6 to B5 if I play
B4 and uh force your knight to uh A4 yes
I hate to interrupt I do think that
we're going to see a handshake in the
Fab ver Wesley versus Fabby game so
let's move to that one is almost empty
boy did we see a vacuum inces take that
didn't take long no yeah well I remember
the um St Louis chess club before it
became a no draw offer said no draw
offers before move 30 think they just
reach 30 uh of the players and I think
it's just a repetition
right and I SM on the face yeah Wesley
congratulates uh Fabby for
well-deserved um Victory undefeated but
at the same time was saying to Fabby
congrat conratulations on drawing
against
me you managed you managed well done
well done also doesn't it mean that
Wesley goes
undefeated yes yeah I mean he didn't
lose that game Ray Robson typical plus
he loves the plus two he loves the plus
twoes the plus two it's brought him
Victory and our congratulations once
again to Fabiano who came in today
already Champion but it just feels that
much nicer to go undefeated that's
that's very and if I'm thinking about
all the positions that he said I cannot
remember him being
worse in every in any game he missed a
couple of chances but those from being
better from being winning sometimes even
against Sam Shanklin against Sam seavan
he was slightly better but not by much
only one moment in that one hasn't been
worse well I felt it one moment that
Hans Neiman was
better that's right but but it was
coming out of the opening you know and
Hans was white so it was a yes no no no
he got he got slightly outplayed in that
early middle game with that Knight to H5
missed that move Knight to H5 and then
um but he was mentioning it if I managed
to go C5 as black then he felt he felt
good about his position that's why I
think Rook to C1 was necessary from Hans
and once he didn't spot that one he got
a lot of counter chances exactly uh very
very very impressive uh champion and to
repeat we we we said to oursel we were
saying to ourselves um when was the last
repeat champion because we do have
players like Sam Shanklin who has a a
fantastic result and CaRu with gotsky
we've had these Champion also getting
really strong
stronger we had four players who broke
the 2800 I know it could easily have
been a leavon aronian well in fact it
was Wesley that repeated just recently
2020 and
2021 but 2020 was online online and it
was rapid time control it wasn't uh the
classical time control Wesley so in
second place yeah Wesley saw six and a
half points uh hoping to stay there and
not having lanard um playing or passing
him and Fabiano Karana eight out of 11
fantastic performance absolutely uh I'm
just going to jump to the game of lanir
and now that we know uh that the silver
medal is up uh for grabs here uh in his
game with Hans nean uh anti Marshal with
A2 A4 Bishop B7 played earlier in the
tournament uh Knight A5 Bishop A2 all
very standard stuff thus far a takes a
takes Bishop G5 Bishop takes F6 Knight E
Knight to C2 as the Knight makes a
beline towards the F5 and uh uh D5
squares Knight C2 Knight C6 I don't know
okay I mean to my eyes I think I I I I I
like white a smidge but it's sort of
like black has succeeded he's got his
fair share of the center a effective
development yeah I'm expecting something
like Knight E7 maybe now right target
that bishop and what you want to well
the whole point of the move Bishop D5
was to kind of deny black uh the two
Bishops right and then maybe you've got
something some kinds of ideas I don't
know of so if I go G6 now right in order
to to hide my Bishop on G7 yeah I'd
probably be inclined to move like H4
maybe again if I can play H5 and
establish some Outpost I start trading
the Rooks Rook a rook takes A1 another
Rook on A8 yeah Hack and Sack feel it
should be very solid for black I know
don't you feel like at the end of the
day you know the opening has been just
ever so slightly ever so slightly uh
favors white but you know one thing I
see is that let Dominguez he lost no
time right he made all his move very
quickly he has 1 hour 31 minutes while
Hans is a little bit of theory already
because he is 1 hour 8 minutes so lenar
knows exactly what he is doing so he may
know how to be push for an advantage
there okay well keep an Bop was uh the
novelty was a all of this has been
played up to this moment yes Knight to
E3 was uh the previously seen and only
one game so Knight E3 and I like Kate's
move Knight E7 just you know controlling
these two guys so long as you you can't
play Knight G4 and I don't have an
awkward way of meeting Knight G4 but the
move Bishop D5 how did the computer
assess and that's the idea um if you do
go Knight to E7 which is again very
natural conventional Bishop takes B7
Queen takes B7 and it does seem like
after Knight to E3 I have a slight pull
okay not much
definitely not much but this is
something that you know linear has
looked at with the help of the engine he
knows the plans he knows how to create
some imbalances and probably feels
comfortable because again look this is
the real office it's going to be very
difficult to get an objective Advantage
out of the opening so um this one a very
intriguing complex battle about to shape
up but for the final time in uh this
event we're going to say hi to Wesley
Wesley welcome back to the show a quiet
day at the office for you the strategy
seems to have been uh clear uh tell us a
bit about today's game tell us a bit
about your estim estimation about your
performance at this
Championship well thank you guys it's
nice to be back but first I'd like to
say a big congratulation to Fabian
karwana for winning his third us Chess
Championship it was a very well-deserved
Victory I he could have won an extra
more game actually but uh yeah he's he's
been playing really really well recently
he also almost won Norway he won
Romania um and he's also playing very
well on speed on faster time controls
which I'm not sure how you do that you
do you play well but uh yeah uh well the
third Victory and uh I hope he I hope he
keeps it up uh especially for next
year's Olympiad maybe we can finally win
another goal
absolutely yeah big Olympiad is coming
up but tell us about your play that's
the plan that's the
plan well my play has been subpar that's
why I didn't feel like playing today
considering the way that he's been
playing and the way that I've been
playing the way uh the way that I've
been playing in the last few months was
not entirely what I was hoping for and
it didn't exactly go my way so the World
Cup I had like a mental breakdown so I'm
still reeling from that uh I'm still
recovering
um after the World Cup I played in the
world team championship and my teammates
pretty much carried me I scored
50% uh so it's clear that uh you know I
need to work harder on my chest I need
to set things right uh the the plus two
performance in this tournament is very
good considering all things but I wasn't
especially pleased with my play I I
thought I was making bad decisions here
and there like small positional
decisions uh yesterday against Hans nean
I guess if I played Knight D7 SE Queen
D6 maybe I had some chances you know
maybe it was the last chance to try to
fight for the tournament
Victory but uh it is uh it is what it is
and uh right now at least I get three
weeks of
relaxation and
uh I'll still try to you know work on my
chest and try to try to recover but
coming before tournament I knew that the
US Championship was going to be tough
this is my ninth year and uh as I said
from the beginning I believe the US
Championship is the toughest Tournament
of the Year considering that uh
everyone's very well prepared and you're
playing against uh young people so so
and then I can't really complain but uh
I have to I have to play play better
chess many players um not many at your
level but many players throughout the
world experience this type of slumps in
their form in their shape how do you
address that as an elite competitor how
do you do
it well I guess you just live your life
uh a day at a time uh you keep uh you
keep working you know take it easy if
it's not meant to be it's not meant to
be uh just uh I just try to be happy and
relaxed
try to put in my work every day try to
put in a few hours a couple hours at
least of Chess work every day and then
uh and then see what happens after all
that's all you can do no one knows the
future what the future holds but I do
hope Fabian becomes a world champion one
day but no one knows so I mean you just
got to uh keep working taking it uh
taking it easy you know enjoy
life um yeah I I guess uh that's uh
pretty much but also my mom kept telling
me that chess has
changed these days compared to a decade
ago there's a lot more faster time
controls there's a lot more online chest
there's a bullet uh and I can't really
blame people for it happening because
due to advancement of Technology not
everyone wants to to watch a classical
game like I'm not going to sit in front
of computer and watch a 4our game it's
like watching paint dry I look at the
critical moment I look at the critical
moments and uh we try to make it a bit
more exciting
wle yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah
you yeah you you you know you you three
you three keep it going but you know you
have a lot of experience and you're
gaining a lot but uh okay no no no
offense intended but I love it but Bish
told Bish an told me in Amsterdam that
people don't even watch entire games
nowadays they just watch clips of the
games so uh it is what it is but I think
uh I think if there's only one time
control in chess it'll be easier for me
to focus on that but nowadays you like
the last years I've been earning as much
money from fast time controls as
classical M so you have to be very good
at both and I find that a bit a bit uh
uneasy but uh we're we're trying our
best so your training in Rapid sometimes
takes away from your training in
classical that's definitely a balancing
that Wesley thank you very much for your
good performance in this event and for
your entertaining interviews as well
guys any questions for very very quick
very very quick question for you Wesley
um not talking about your performance uh
but I always like these US championships
in terms of the new talents uh that come
and the debut of Mishra for me has been
a real Revelation he's played here in my
estimation extremely successfully and
yeah uh maturely uh you're you're your
take sitting across the board from
Mishra what uh how does it feel for from
from your
perspective well yeah for sure I mean
during the last few years the United
States is a big country and uh we have a
lot of great amazing talents that come
up the scene Amisha is clearly
exceptional he's very talented but he's
also you know I guess hardworking and
very intense yeah you know his father
sure has big plans for him uh yeah I
think he's you know he's doing very very
well he's a bright future ahead of him
uh there are a lot of questions that
needs to be answered mostly you know is
he willing to keep this up or is he does
he want to be a professional chess
player right uh because when you're a
teenager like you're very focused on
chess you know you're you're very
motivated you're doing well but we don't
know yet what happens uh in the future
but uh uh right now the future looks you
know really bright for him I predict
he'll reach 2700 soon one day mhm uh if
things keep up um but uh it's it's nice
to see that we have all this amazing
talents come up here and there he's not
an easy opponent to to play with uh he's
got a lot of
strength and uh he's you know there's
still room for improvement but I'm sure
that uh I'm sure that he can do it I I
think St Louis is doing a good job in
cultivating
younger players also us chess and also
we have the Sam for Fellowship for
people under the age of
26 so I guess my message to M sure just
keep doing what he's doing you know
he'll keep improving he'll he'll get
there at at least we have a we have a
very young teenager to to challenge the
the the the Indian Prodigy from other
side Wesley congratulations on your
performance thank you for the Fighting
Chess it looks like you're really
respectful of all the other players and
appreciative thank you for that as well
yeah for sure I mean after I realized
that I couldn't beat and Tang there's no
easy opponent in the US Championship all
right thank you Wesley thanks and indeed
Christian tell us uh what's going on in
beam's position as Jennifer rided the
ship or how was the situation oh I
wasn't really looking I was trans fixed
by Wesley's interview as well his uh
explaining of my great experience a
commentator making I I love it
look he was nice to me the first time
now he paid you guys some homage as well
I like it nice very nice A5 so this is
after Knight to D3 right F6 we said that
that was a very suspicious move I had
very suspicious weakening the light
squares around the king don't do that A5
Knight to F4 C6 and now this is the
position that we currently have right uh
with black to move and it's looking good
for white because the problem is once
you play the move C6 if you do take on
C3 and I take back with a rook the
Knight is stuck on B8 at least for the
moment right until you manage to go
Bishop to B7 but with this structure do
you actually play Bishop to B7 um do you
leave the light squares around the king
side weaken like that no so nothing is
really working in a good cooperation
right now for black I'm struggling to
find and remember when I told you hey if
you at some point allow me to go Bishop
to E1 drop the bishop back hide it from
your knight and then go F3 and then go
Bishop to F2 and have the two Bishops
and the potential break in the center
with E4 then that's going to give me a
very nice Advantage again long-term nice
advantage and the problem is that black
doesn't seem to have counter chances
generally you get something on the king
side somewhere yeah it's it it doesn't
really look like there's anything right
now in the position and guess what
you're not going to break with C5
anytime soon either because of the
weakness of D5 so it looks problematic
it looks good for begim right now as we
can see from the line scores and we
mentioned this at the beginning of the
show for the moment Jennifer U has a
tremendous score in their head-to-head
against beim toir janova but in this
tournament begim uh her shape is so much
more Superior to to Jennifers but we
also discussed this before the show
those last rounds they have different
rules they do and anything and
absolutely everything can happen yeah
well
they're you got to keep your nerves uh
and stay calm I just want to turn our
attention to Karissa uh's position for
just a moment uh she got surprised in
the opening certainly the whole Bishop
C5 um approach uh surprised me as well
against D7 D6 after some consideration
uh what about 20 minutes or so knight uh
F5 E3 the engine's recommended move was
played as she sidesteps ideas of Bishop
takes F5 and after Bishop E6 Queen D2 H6
Bishop takes F6 Queen takes F6 Knight
D5 uh this is the current position and
your take on it uh Kate I mean you one
thing I like for black the development
is very easy right so uh Ruan gen lost
no time whatsoever in the beginning
because you just want this H6 you force
the bishop away you recapture with Queen
you put the bishop on E6 so it's you
don't have to think much how to set up
your pieces but now you have a decision
so Knight E5 I'm assuming the queen
drops back I have no desire really to to
open up yeah to trade yeah put another
Knight on that D5 square but now having
said that one thing I might
consider Bishop takes E3 the idea is if
you take with the queen then I kind of
eliminate your hold if you will over D4
and C file is opening or Knight D4 yes
but exactly I have to take back with a
knight right do we Okay so Bishop takes
I really don't like to take with a pawn
I don't know why fair and the question
is okay I haven't moved my
queen can I play G6 and King G7 okay I'm
sure you can but how will that position
be in fact let's say Bishop C4 Bishop to
C4 exchange the light score Bishops um
on Whose terms that's a good question
right F6 uh pardon me G6 let's go Castle
short Castle but what if I mean G6 I get
but we always have this queen G6 move to
kind of Target E4 and
G2 I but I I will defend with F3 and I
will defend both of those pawns with
have3 I've got I'm not 100% sure the
queen belongs there if I was going to
but to your point if I was going to move
the queen I kind of want I don't know
it's a you want to exchange yeah I do
want to trade uh anyway just to finish
the the thought uh Carissa's
position balanced what but now Rook D1
and you start putting pressure on that
D6 Pawn right right after this bishop to
E3 I just feel like black should be
worse yeah I'm not I'm not uh anxious to
give up the two Bishops I I I didn't
know whether I want to play Queen G5 oh
you do have Knight C7 I do apologize uh
if I wanted to encourage you to play H4
or just re Retreat the uh quick uh quick
quick take uh you prefer white little
prefer prefer white I like that position
a little bit more because that D5 square
is is occupied and white species look
nicer we we are with our
2023 US champion Christian uh Fabiano
you had a full night to sit on this
result how impactful is this national
championship for
you yeah it's it's always very special
for me uh to to win the US championship
and it's been very difficult in the past
for me uh I I went many years without
being able to break through and last
year things went smoothly this year as
well so it's uh it's very important
for me both from the point of view of
how strong of a tournament it is and
also from a personal point of view
because it is the US championship did
you take any lessons from last year's
championship uh Victory into this year's
championship I thought that it felt
similar to last year in the sense that
nobody is really trying making like huge
strides towards um like there are some
years where people start to run away
with it for example I can recall in 2018
uh I had had a good event but Sam
shankland went plus six and there was no
way for me to catch up at the end uh
despite my best efforts and but I think
also chess in general these days it's
harder to uh to get a
win uh it just seems like the level of
play in general the level of preparation
is so high for people that you you see
everyone struggling to create chances or
um sometimes they do but it's because
you unexpectedly get chances during the
game like those those kind of clinical
plays that used to be very common where
you get an advantage from the opening
you increase the pressure and you win
are exceedingly rare these days so uh of
course it's uh it's really uh really
huge for me that I I was able to do it
this time because I I know that these
tournament victories don't come easily
and I know from experience and and these
days it gets more and more difficult
especially with the young guys getting
stronger and and they're super motivated
so uh you you have to put a huge amount
of effort into these types of events
guys any questions for our champion
absolutely kid I have one question
Fabiano first of all congratulations
great performance what would you say is
your favorite game of this
tournament
um it's kind of hard to say I would say
the the game which I recall most fondly
is the game against Hans because that
was pretty much the game that um I
really needed to win to to keep up when
when lenier and Wesley they were they
were picking up wins near the end I need
did to to keep that Gap so that was
super
important in terms of wins like I don't
feel I played a super beautiful game in
any any of the games um like generally
speaking I played some decent games with
nothing that I can recall as like um
going to be super memorable but yeah
that maybe that game against Hans
and uh like the most important game I
feel is the game against daro I think
that was that was really important for
my tournament because if I had drawn
that game
and and it seemed for a long time that I
had no chances to win the entire game
pretty much I I don't think that it
would have gone as smoothly in the
remainder of the event so that that game
I look back as maybe the like most the
most essential moment in the tournament
because sometimes it's about just like
playing really long game and waiting for
that opponent to make a mistake yeah
Bobby I also would add my uh admiration
and congratulations for your Victory uh
your key rival Wesley so he came on the
show and he said you know if there was
only one time control in chess I could
focus on it and I'd feel like I could be
a perform better uh and he mentioned
specifically you uh that you have
improved you you you've had a very good
2023 uh you've you you uh and the
candidates again you've won the uh
back-to-back US championships in Norway
you were simply excellent but you've
also improved your Blitz and your online
Speed play and he almost openly asked
how how does he do it how do you get
better at at Blitz as well as uh
classical normally you focus on one or
the
other well I think that chess is chess
so any sort of Chess work will will uh
improve your results in any area of the
game mhm uh I do I do understand his
point that it's difficult to constantly
be readjusting to the different time
controls uh if I could give Wesley any
one piece of advice I would say that it
helps to take up podcasting that's
that's the one thing I would say I'm
looking forward to the to the Wesley
podcast someday all right very good
Bobby uh what can we say just tip of the
Hat well done and uh keep up the great
work I know the sville cup is coming up
for you so uh you still have a lot more
challenges this year ahead of you good
luck thank you absolutely go the 2020
the US champion Grand Master Fabiano
Carana absolutely uh very very well done
indeed and uh undefeated again it always
feels so much better when you do manage
to make it an an ed I don't know man
about that advice podcasting is
difficult podcasting is for those
retired guys for those retired that
cannot handle the pressures of uh
tournaments competition and stuff like
that so I don't know Wesley maybe you
shouldn't take that don't take it to
there there we have it uh give us some
chess chess is chess chess give us some
chess what's nothing has happened since
this one uh 9 C5 at least it seems like
Ru Yang is finally out of her
preparation and she's thinking has a lot
of options at her disposal one of them
was Bishop takes C3 again I don't feel
like we should give up the two Bishops
especially not Bishop takes E3 maybe I
will give this bishop on A6 but at the
same time if I give the light square a
bishop then who's going to guard all
these weaknesses right the Bish B C5
sure is going to be a good defensive and
maybe offensive piece at times as well
but it can be kicked around A3 B4 stuff
of that nature I don't feel secure with
my outpost on C5 so I think what I want
to do is go Queen to H4 maybe even Queen
to d8 things of that nature poke around
uh this side of the board and by the way
Queen to H4 what are you going to do how
are you going to react to me attacking
that pawn on D4 you don't have F3 at
your disposal and that's the key about
this move Queen to H4 you have to defend
it with the bishop at the same time once
you committed the bishop to D3 no longer
Bishop to uh C4 no longer G3 followed by
Bishop to G2 you've committed to a
square right and you're going to lose
some tempies to get it uh to a different
place and I'm not 100% sure if Bishop to
D3 in this setup in this Pawn structure
is the right Square for the light Square
Bishop so again it's a very complex
battle I would still say that white has
the edge but black given the two Bishops
given if she manages to go G6 and you
mentioned this correctly G6 King G7 get
the king uh to G7 make the connection
between the Rooks and then that's going
to be a very very decent I would say
even favorable shikov uh style position
for black exactly want to turn our
attention to the game between Talia and
Anna for a moment just as to contrast
and compare if you will Kate if you look
at the game of tella and think of the
game of Jennifer U and um beg him for a
moment very similar except in this
particular case Anna has done a lot of
things much better than Jennifer to
begin with she hasn't played Bishop
Bishop B4 takes C3 and giv up the bishop
the bishop actually sits kind of nicely
on the D6 Square doesn't really allow at
Knight E5 jump uh to begin with stopping
the Knight E5 but also protecting this
Pawn on C7 maybe you get to play C5 Anna
is also um put her Bishop on A6 so uh
essentially to deny uh this light Square
Bishop from being a good piece from
Black's perspective
trading playing with C6 putting the
Knight on e4 we see the Rook on c c I
would say the big difference is that we
do have that Knight on F6 ready to jump
as you showed on e4 instead of the Pawn
on F6 that is creating weaknesses and
precisely forces the Knight to be
somewhere else yeah and Jennifer's game
the pawn is actually on F6 which just
looks like an ugly Square imagining Anna
completely misplaying her pieces so that
she could play the move F7 F6 gives us
an indication that Jennifer's got things
wrong again I'm just going to go around
the horn uh for a moment and uh pick up
with ausa and Nasi okay this was another
I was about to say uh there's a whole
line of people wanting to wanting to
take on Nasi in the saying third time is
the charm exactly she sees Bishop E2
complete change of strategy for Nazi I'm
not going to give you any Queen side
expansions no A4 A5
toov and K both went A4 C4 and kind of
won that game and N says well in this
particular game what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make an outpost for night
my knight in the middle of the board the
the square D5 is home for my knight very
different approach and frankly I I
wouldn't want to see Nasi lose the same
game three three times in a row uh good
to see that I'm going to jump to the
game of of uh Alice Lee uh versus ashria
was trying to kind of break in on that
Queen side with A4 Knight C5 and but no
C6 no C7 C6 well the problem with the C6
is it does uh open up the default now uh
the question that uh Alice has for
herself she's got this night kind of
okay it does do this and this but
where's her play she doesn't want to
play F4 she does not that will open up
the dark Square Bishop exactly she
doesn't want to play
B4 so um long term Alice has to be
asking herself where does she want to
play well she's come up with the move
Knight B5 inviting what she imagines
will be something that's favorable for
her any trade and the the the bishop and
the queen uh are are hitting the C5
Square overall I would say that black is
actually kind of okay with all of this
queen d8 pretty much okay um still a lot
of Chess to be played back over to you
uh Christian what do you have let's just
see what happened in this game between
begim and Jennifer u a critical one for
the standings C6 Knight F4 this is where
we left it off and she played the move
Knight to D7 we did discuss this ideas
with Bishop to E1 and F3 Bishop to E1
right now would have been close to uh
decisive Bishop to E1 what do you do
next I guess you can go Bishop to B7 the
problem is after F3 let's say Knight to
D6 Bishop to F2 where is your next move
how do you continue I know how I am
going to continue I'm going to go Rook
to E1 Bishop to D3 Queen to C2 put some
pressure create some more weaknesses
because you will have to do either G6 or
H6 and those will create um weak squares
around your king and then if I don't
have a way to deal with that I'm just
simply going to go E4 so Rook E1 Bishop
D3 Queen C2 in the meantime you have
nothing to do and I have full control
over the dark squares that's very
important it's very important to hold on
to the bishop she played the move F3
which is also a good move also uh
keeping a pretty significant Advantage
but it doesn't have the same impact as
Bishop two Bishops is so nice right
you're you're simply going to enjoy and
we've seen that with Arena versus beim
yesterday Arena was enjoying her two
Bishop's Advantage Knight takes C3 Rook
takes C3 almost forced I don't expect
Jennifer to go Knight D6 she might but I
don't expect that and then Bishop to B7
and there's a a very nice line in this
position I can go E4 and in fact you
cannot touch that pawn if you do take on
e4 this is game over Rook H3 Knight G6
I'm giving you the KN like this and now
I just simply take there's no way to
stop Rook to H3 absolutely no way to
stop Rook two uh H3 you cannot cover
this a toga diagonal with any of your
pieces game over right beautiful line
obviously she's not going to take if
they go to this position after E4 you
can just sit like this play the move
Knight to f8 defend the pawn on D5 again
white has a very comfortable Edge but
with the two Bishops I like it even more
without the two Bishops I like it a bit
less but again it's uh it's a very
significant Advantage we are starting
also to see times ad time Advantage
because because beum has already 20
minutes Advantage right now over
Jennifer yeah that that's actually quite
significant and uh that I I love it when
my opponent is in time trouble but I'm
kind
of flx that uh you don't play Knight
take C3 immediately it'd be like I'd be
grabbing that Bishop with both hands and
you know before you move it type of
thing and uh you've got the game of no
it's not uh that interesting a again
just going through it uh let's uh go and
somebody told us Sam shankland was
winning but that was fake news fake
newsland is definitely not winning just
want to say that uh in the game of atat
and Arena we've seen remember when we
left it more or less here and I was
proposing uh Knight E7 and then you
clobber me with the move Bishop takes B5
yeah that was very good uh and the whole
point was the Knight D6 I was thinking
that if I'm in Arena shoes and I can't
play the move Knight E7 this confounding
Pawn on on G5 really bothers me imagine
I play H6 what you're going to do
because now that the Rook is up on D2
you're not playing H4 I don't think you
want to play Rook G1 H6 I want to take
on a G5 is my intention mhm what do you
think of that usually the response is G6
right to just give up the pawn but since
black pawn has uh not moved from D7 the
E square is not going to be weak exactly
so I will
play I may capture you may capture
because the the other move that really
caught my eye was if I play H6 and I
didn't know if this was a threat or
not Bishop F4 you're very direct yeah
just it just happens that you're set up
for this mate in one you know you take
can't take the bishop and I don't know
if you're happy with the move Queen C6
so just capture okay again I'm sitting
here saying I can't play a game three
pieces down there everybody's in their
dormatory room nobody uh got out of into
the battle Knight takes H6 um a very
different approach by Arena but uh we'll
keep an eye on this one as I'm going to
send it over to you uh Christian in the
open so we had the wrong Sam it's Sam
Sean that actually has a winning
position take a look at this so this is
very typical standard stuff you play C3
you allow D5 that's Mar right and then
Sam Sean plays the move D3 and right now
Andrew spends 30 minutes natur off his
clock and doesn't play the D6 which is
considered to be the main line by far
but he plays D5 he's wondering why can't
I play D5 well guess why there is
there's a reason behind of that uh take
take take I'm going to take your pawn
and after Knight to D4 Knight to C3 yeah
this is this has actually been seen
crazily this should be known right this
has been seen this should be known but
it doesn't seem like Andrew was aware of
these technicalities Knight to B4 and
now A3 A3 has not been played he's
thinking Sam seon right now but after A3
this looks very good for white you
wanted to say winning but you stopped
yourself if not winning yes Knight takes
B3 C takes B3 you go back no no you
cannot go Knight C6 knight6 is coming
for KN C6 is coming for white exactly
seven this is over right so you have to
go F6 after uh taking on B3 but I have
to say I'm looking at the position I'm
seeing Queen to F3 ideas maybe just the
simple Knight to F3 preserve my extra
pawn and where's your compensation not
me I have two Bishops is it that clear
so I go back Knight C6 that's the thing
you have to go to Knight C6
you would love to go Knight D5 and then
Bishop D7 and stabilize like that but
Knight to C6 is not the best position
for the Knight because I can go B4 at
some point I will get something on the
C5 and again where's the Knight going
you cannot go to D4 you cannot go to E5
let's go Bishop G4 just for a second yes
I want to put some pressure on that
Knight yes so let's go and that's why I
played B4 as well to get out of this pin
whenever I want with the move Queen to
B3 so let's start
with Knight to a
D4 you want to sacrifice your queen
Knight takes D4 takes Knight C6 c yeah
that's serious that is really uh you
cannot allow um so that's three light
pieces for a queen you cannot allow
Knight you have to go Bishop B3 and go
into this end game but this is not
pleasant that's very difficult to see NE
Medina will uh be very proud of the the
queen sacrifice there so A3 objectively
at least the engine are white is
Andrew's back border line winning wow
all right well thank you for that
Christian it's that time of our
broadcast where we get ready for our
first break of the day and as we do that
we always go to our friends at Q
Boutique to see what's the specials are
well guess what it's t-shirt day grab
the newest appara for the 2023 us Chess
Championship these shirts proudly
featured the logos of the 2023 us Chess
Championship on the front the official
St Louis chess club logo on the sleeve
and the back displays the names of the
players in each field the red shirts are
in a men styles and display the players
of the open field and the blue are in a
women's style and represent the women's
field the red shirt is 50% cotton 50%
polyester the blue shirt is 60% cotton
and 40% polyester somebody's getting
ripped off in that deal I don't know
who's getting the better deal but both
are only available while limited
supplies last available at cutique
stl.com and we're going to see you all
on the other side of this
break
be thank you so much for joining me
today tell me a little bit about your
chess upbringing H thank you Saina for
having me and when it comes to my up
chess upbringing it's influenced by my
family by my siblings and my sisters
played chess when they were like 9 10
years old they started it and when I was
around like 6 seven years old I I
remember watching them play and that got
me interested H in chess but my brother
was the one who actually taught me how
to play chess when it was three and a
half years three-ish years uh as I was
told so I don't really remember how I
learned how to play chess but I have
been playing chess since I know myself
wow that's that's very nice how many
siblings do you have I have three two
sisters and then a one brother okay I
wasn't I didn't know about the brother
so I'm learning new things yeah he's the
one who never played chess but he knows
after to play chess and always follows
the games my tournaments and is he the
one who taught all of you to play uh no
actually my dad was the one who told my
sisters have to play and my brother is
the third so he his responsibility was
how to was to teach me how to play so
it's only me I see so you learned around
three and a half four and uh how did you
continue after that was it were you um
excited that your sisters were playing
and you kind of learned from them you
wanted to be stronger or just be able to
compete or I never had such a great like
motivation oh I want to do that I want
to win this tournament it was about
traveling actually I was a crazy kid I
would never sit down and work on
anything I was I loved uh like playing
games with my friends basically it was a
totally different Dynamic back then and
the opportunity that we got back in OB
bistan at the time was if you win the
you like a national championships by one
and a half points you were eligible to
go to a Asian and uh World Championship
you're only you so it was my huge
motivation traveling and going to both
of them so I would try to beat uh
everyone like I I want a lot of my games
like that for that reason and then chess
was something very fun for me I would
like you know just play back I see so
you basically were motivated by the
opportunities that chess gave you to
travel and um I'm assuming you did a lot
of work in order to be able to win all
those it's just like it was the way my
family uh motivated me because they knew
what I like and then they knew I like
chess but I couldn't like sit down and
work because at that time I was too
young to understand why I should do that
basically so did you have times that you
were spending together working on chess
playing or maybe studying end games
middle games uh absolutely my oldest
sister she's a wgm and my youngest
younger sister she's a f Master too
she's a quite strong player and they
helped me a lot even my brother he has
he he's a candidate master so it's just
like chess is all around my family and I
worked quite a lot with my sisters until
I reached a point when I you know when I
needed more coaching than working with
them was there a specific book that you
remember as a kid that influenced your
chess not really and when I was growing
up already we had internet we had a lot
of information uh like flowing around I
played it a lot and then we tried to of
course learn from books a lot and in
like end games middle game but still we
didn't have something specific we just
had a lot lot of material can already I
see and coming to the United States
you've been balancing a professional
chess career with uh going to school
tell me a little bit how you were able
to manage your time and also of course
get ready for this year's us
Championship well I think I didn't
manage my time well you can see from my
rating it just dropped like 80 points
100 points since I came here the things
that um college is a whole all like
different experience it gives you like
personal different like you know growth
and I love the process I still uh do it
and I love it and it's a little bit hard
to balance with chess but slowly I'm
come coming back where I can still do
school and I work for the club little
bit you know that and I still enjoy
chess so it's more about me sitting down
and doing something but still enjoying
um my time doing chess learning learning
something new so you enjoy working on
chess but also combining it to continue
promoting our beautiful game absolutely
and I love what you're doing with the
club um I love sharing with you this
position time but this time you're the
competitor so I wish you good luck in
this competition thank you so much for
sitting down with me and looking forward
to your games thank you
Saina
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping gr
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so uh the contributions have
been immense and of course it's all
thanks to uh Dr Jun singfield and RX
singfield I would say that s Lou CH Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it sense a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
Al flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the same Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess is intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit worldes h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both inch
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
qti stl.com for a wide variety of gifts
for everyone to
enjoy
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr jeie Karen sinkfield and
Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess club is
a nonprofit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
today hello everyone and welcome back uh
to our coverage of the 2023 US national
championships yes we have Fabby as our
new National Champion but the ladies
competition up for grabs there but we
have a very special uh guest in studio
Nick regon Nick you're with Ascension I
am welcome welcome welcome welcome here
here I do a lot of interviews all year
for the central Charity Classic and lots
of other stuff for work but this is the
one I enjoy the most every year year
really yeah fantastic that's true I'm
not lying it's good uh tell our viewers
uh about Ascension sure uh you know the
viewers uh know me I've been on this
many times but essentially we're the
largest hospital system in the country
we have 150 hospitals in 20 States we
serve tens of millions of people every
year particularly in the the most
vulnerable parts of the community where
we're the safety net provider and we're
really proud of that Legacy and uh and
I've been with the c for 10 years and
it's a calling to work in in healthc
care in a Catholic Healthcare System to
help the most vulnerable is really
something you're called to do and I'm
really proud of the work we've done
Nationwide now we don't have any
hospitals here in St Louis but we're
headquartered here and because we're
headquartered here I thought it was
really important that we have an impact
on the community and so we've done that
through our charitable giving including
with the chess club and the ascential
Charity Classic golf tournament and
other stuff so I'm really proud of that
Legacy and we're very grateful as well
and uh thank you for that and then I
know uh through your son you helped the
Ferguson School school district and
bringing chess into the schools as well
so again thank you for that tell us a
bit about the charity tourament SED
Charity Classic this is our third year
we're a PJ tour Champions event so we're
partnered with the PJ tour which is the
professional Golf Association and we
started this event three years ago
really to invest in North St Louis
County you know the rest of the country
still thinks that St Louis or North St
Louis county is Ferguson and what they
saw on TV a decade ago and it's much
more than that and so we created this
event all the proceeds stay in North St
Louis County to the Urban League Bo and
Girls Club Mary Grove and um and I'm
proud of saying year three now again
this is a professional golf event we're
both the most charitable event on PJ
tour Champions as well as the best
attended we've had record attendance our
first three years over 50,000 people and
so uh I'm really proud of that that's a
reflection of St Louis our ability to
give back uh the commitment of our
corporate sponsors to be engaged and and
I think you know it's it's covered live
on the Golf Channel for 3 Days the
Charity Classic and it's a love letter
to St Louis it reminds the rest of the
country that St Louis uh is not what you
remembered from Ferguson from 10 years
ago but rather it's a a great place to
work to live to play and the state of
Missouri has invested heavily in it our
Governor Mike Parson our Lieutenant
Governor Mike kho um our big cor
corporate Partners have and I think it's
become uh a part of the permanent Sports
landscape the way the blues and the
Cardinals and soccer and NASCAR and
chess and golf are part of that
landscape congratulations for that that
you me I think St Louis is very happy
for and very grateful for everything
that you are doing for the community and
I want to ask specifically about Chess
because you've been instrumental in
creating your uh move chess program
right which is for the undeserved
students it's an after school chess
program tell us more about it sure so uh
about eight or nine years ago now I
can't remember the exact timing but um
it was born of my son at the time was in
fifth grade and he was at community
school and he played a lot of Chess and
he said to me appropo nothing you know
do all the schools in this area have
after school chess and and I I don't
know I no idea uh but it it got me to
thinking and this is right after
Ferguson and uh so I made a call to the
chess club and Tony Rich picked up the
phone and I said hey you know do do all
the and he goes no in fact we just got a
new superintendent Dr Joe Davis uh at
Ferguson and he he likes chess and he'd
like to have a program and I said what
would it cost and we started talking
numbers and I went down stairs talked to
my CEO and he said let's do this and
then next thing you know your move chess
was born and we've done a bunch of
fundraisers and I think we raised over a
half a million dollars for the program
and I think it you know and it's been
six seven years now and you could see
how it's impacted the lives of these
kids and it gives them more confidence
the ability to to think on their feet uh
to know that decisions have consequences
and so I'm just so proud of that you
know I believe that chess has its kind
of Curative power um to make people more
whole to heal them it's a game we could
play for life as is evidenced by you
yes and uh and so for long be great at a
Long Level uh and so I'm really proud of
that and I'm proud that that of what the
chess club and particularly Rex his
vision for chess in St Louis Scholastic
chess and you know I'm proud of the fact
that when I travel and I tell people I'm
from St Louis they usually ask about the
blues and the cards but a lot of people
say wow isn't that the chess capital I
say absolutely I like to joke that with
a with a little vision and a lot a lot
of investment you could create something
very special and Rex has done that I'm
really proud of it yeah you're so right
um you're also the captain of your chess
team the Ascension chess team in the
corporate league and I know you guys
haven't won
anything you
that that enthusiasm derion new captain
see coming is there any chances that we
could get a get a better captain in the
years ahead I I think we have better
captains um in the waiting um we we have
a very enthusiastic team I will tell you
the corporate chess league and uh um and
what Alex is doing it's amazing at at
how much that is created uh with the
companies that are part of it how
competitive is and Lauren's been a big
part of that and um they have a great
team of Edward Jones does and dhy
solutions and others and and we love
Enterprise is the champ an Enterprise
yeah that's true we have a new champ I
got to I got to bring you into the into
the mix here look this is a very
important game Carissa Yip she has a
half a point lead coming into the
competition she's playing white beum uh
half a point behind her now you got this
nice Knight on the Square
D5 uh two Bishops for black but look at
this the king is going to need the
castle by hand G6 King G7 now you're
white in this position you just played
the move Bishop B3 are you
confident that your position is good
enough for at least a draw oh yeah for
white yeah so what I what I'm not that
anybody would ask me but I like that
Bishop back there I'm worried about that
Knight on C6 so I would open up yeah I
would open up that I would open up that
pawn the a pawn just so that it has a
retreat Square okay you like that you
like that maybe although I see the other
Pawn is I mean the other Bishop the
black Bishop is looking at it anyway so
yeah that might not be the best move no
no I the position I'm worried about that
night jumping in though the big question
that I really meant to ask you about
this position in is uh basically Karissa
has a choice she has a choice that she
could Castle short put the king away
tuck it away there very safe option or
go long and make it a game yeah right
that I would to go long all the way I
mean come on but come on you got point
lead yeah that's true the safe play is
to Castle Shore just and make black come
after you wait back and do a lot of
nothing make black make a mistake you to
play the tour that's why I'm an 1800 and
not a grandm I would Castle long and
they're just making an all out slugfest
Nick you came in very very enthusiastic
talking about Magnus Carlson and what
was going on qar with the watch what's
your take on that whole controversy I
think um I have two points of view one
is it it it's good that people are
paying attention you know Gotham talked
about it when he did his recap when it's
Magnus and cheating it it gets double
the views right and that's good for the
game I wish I wish that we would just um
there'd be less emphasis on the acud mon
go with it more on the game itself it
was a brilliant game I think U Magnus
himself said he didn't think it was
cheating but having a analog watch threw
him off somehow he's the greatest player
of all time I don't think Bobby fish
well actually Bobby probably would have
gotten thrown off too I don't know if
you would have or Gary would have or
others Bobby would have stormed out
actually um it's interesting there's so
many good young players and Magnus not
being the world champion it's a little
weird it's a weird feeling for all of us
like not Magnus the world champion and I
think he's adjusting to life after being
world champion and being more of a
streamer doing a lot of other stuff and
his streams are interesting but um I
don't think he loves classical chess the
way he used to and I'm not sure he's
quite as sharp as he used to be uh we're
seeing that actually too Kate we're
seeing that the um online chess has
changed dramatically we had Wesley on
earlier he's saying on the scales he's
earning as much playing fast chess as he
does playing classical chess sureo earns
10 times people want to see that action
they don't to wait 2 hours for a player
to make a move so I understand that it's
kind of speeding up the game when you
think about the broadcast here from
these US championships you're watching
the highlights you're not watching the
four hours right hard to watch the full
I mean I I watch the highlights I um you
know I go to Gotham and get some updates
and then I go and play like we want to
go play I like play online I love
classical chess but it's it's boring to
watch four hours and I'd rather see you
know especially uh even with a 15-minute
time control with the increment watching
a car Magnus there's usually a decisive
outcome there's sometimes you get draws
but there's way more decisive outcomes
that at the end of the day the Casual
fan like myself we don't want to see
draws we want to see decisive outcomes
and the shorter the time control the
more likely you're going to see a
decisive outcome the longer the time
control the more time they think you
know they're making stockfish level
moves exactly less likely there's going
to be decisive outcome and so I think
you know as more and more people get
engaged on the sport through twitch and
YouTube through Gotham through hararo
through Daniel and others um they want
to see those shorter time controls
because we want to see decisive outcomes
ABS Nick thank you for joining us thank
you for everything you do thank you for
supporting the St Louis chess club the
world Fame cheers to Ascension and your
CEO thank you good Lu thank you I was
going to say yes when we going to play a
little Blitz oh yeah baby bring it you
been afraid of me oh yeah you know I'm
black I'm tricky I play the Scandinavia
I've been ducking you for quite some
time absolutely thank you Nick and uh
let's just take a quick look at our
standings we're going to jump to the
ladies as everything to play for for the
gold right so standings after round 10
just one more round to go that they are
playing right now Karis sa is leading
the tournament so far with half a point
advantage over beim to janova who is
however having a really good position
right now and then a two-way tie for a
third place arena crash and Alis Le with
six and a half points big fight for the
the the bronze medal there EST have a
little bit in the mix as well and in the
open section we already crowned the
champion here the boss Grand Master
Fabiano Karana winning with eight points
and then we have westlea with six and a
half points so far clear second but
waiting for what Lenard Dominguez is
going to do in his game and again Mishra
on the outside looking in trying to get
to the podium uh and Christian tell us
uh who's getting to the podium and
perhaps it's a good idea to start
looking at those matchups the one of
lener the one of Mishra as well let's
update our viewers this one by the way I
believe after Knight to E3 or somewhere
around here Bishop to D5 we were
discussing linear was very well prepared
in this one Bishop to D5 was a novelty
but I have to say hans's response was uh
very very good as well take on A1 Rook
to A8 Queen to D1 Knight to E7 and we
got this position G6 H4 H5 and Que Queen
to B3 King to G7 get out of this
potential pin it makes a lot of sense
also the King on G7 protects the bishop
on F6 it's the ideal Square for the king
and now we have Rook to B1 and I'm
wondering what is this Rook to B1 yeah
yeah yeah the mysterious move the move I
sort of understand it I think he was
getting ready for for Queen to A2 Queen
to D1 perhaps or queen to C2 and have
the B2 Pawn on their WPS protected right
so this is what I think Rook to B1 was
meant to be Queen to C6 was the response
so I'm not venturing he's having some
nightmares about venturing with a queen
on the a file we remember what happened
against Ray Robson got his Queen trapped
on A3 so definitely not looking to
repeat that scenario he uh keeps
controlling the center with Queen to C6
I like this move I'm looking at the
position the material is so limited
right I mean it's it's dry exactly
that's the word and if you do go Knight
to D5 I think I'm just simply going to
take that you're going to take that and
then I'm going to drop by to B7 or D7
and I understand maybe at the right
moment you will have some uh ideas about
getting that Knight to E4 but even once
you land the Knight on e4 I just simply
go Bishop E7 play the move F5 it just
doesn't seem like you have enough
resources in the position and remember
laner was at some point 30 minutes up on
the clock right now he's 15 minutes down
yeah so a lot of things have changed it
does seem like Hans knows what he's
doing he can keep control of this
position and even if lenier maybe had a
slight Advantage out of the opening
that's starting to dissipate right now
feels to me like you're seeking to make
no something out of nothing if you go
back to the current position yes after
the move Queen C6 if I'm
aspiring for the good knight versus bad
Bishop I might be thinking about the
move C 3 C4 here with the idea that in
case you play B4 play along for with me
for just a moment Knight to D5 again
play along with me you you're doing me a
a favor C4 takes D5 and a little bit
different than the other position now
you get your night even here I'm not
convinced like I'm
overwhelming something you know this is
my weakness right and I can only hit it
once you can only hit it once and then
you can put more pressure with F4 but
guess what I will play F6 like we're
going to get something along these lines
and I have control over D it's dry how
are you taking control over the a how
are you fighting for the aile the only
way I see you to uh fighting for the
aile is by playing getting the king to
C2 playing B3 King B2 and Rook to A1 but
once you play B3 that closes the
trajectory of the king to try to invade
via the queen side so I don't I just
simply don't see it I think the material
is limited it's very symmetrical
um I think Hans has equalized and he's
uh fairly safe in this one but guys
please excuse me I didn't want to do
that but take a look at this game Mish
this one is completely wild okay and it
in fact it started off wild from the
beginning from the get-go no Namo no
quiet stuff from leevon leevon is
looking for a fight in this one and MRA
is saying okay let's go you want the
fight let's go let's do it good G3
Castle Knight C3 and Knight C6 that's an
interesting uh approach yeah you
normally where we're used to seeing D6
or C5 as a maybe C5 especially against
G3 right we know the benoni with G3 is
not as good for white Bon is a very
suspicious opening but with G3 it's in
fact playable um feel but he goes Knight
C6 and now we have this position it
feels like a reiteration of the game of
leevon versus Hans also these two uh
pawns right
here uh it was much more open on the
king side that one so some differences
but still we have this
position and after Knight to B6 which
seems to be a very good move in this
instance you have to defend the E3
Square somehow right how are you going
to do it you don't have that many
options trade that knight from D5 yeah
no that yeah I didn't see the move
Knight B6 you take take take my guess is
you're going to go H3 Knight back and
then you take on C6 for example right no
no I don't want to do this as black H3
C5 you have to go C5 yes yes you have to
go C5 take take Rook takes uh D4 and we
get this position but I have to say I'm
looking at the pawn structure I'm
looking at the weaknesses potential
weaknesses maybe even take on F5 if you
have to take with the G Pawn I was going
to take with the G Pawn I have ideas on
the G file but but I also have ideas
against the pawn on D5 I see a slight
Advantage for white not much again but a
slight Advantage something that uh Mish
can play with in the position and Knight
to B6 is on the board right very
important move by the way because if you
if if if leavon could convince M to play
a rook e w that that that passive move
yeah then maybe he could get an
advantage uh Knight B6 nicely timed it's
rather remarkable to me that black
doesn't have well I take on C5 Knight
takes A8 Queen B7 oh you want to take C
no no no no no Knight this is over Queen
B7 Queen C5 I just love well the thing
is I can also defend that pawn with
Knight I know it's a great exchange big
Advantage uh there no no blunders uh By
Me we're expecting Knight Tak be6 right
uh a game that two players um have not
uh played very well but darush versus
Ray Robson uh if you don't mind just
tell me tell me what has happened in
that sure game you know surprisingly
versus RS very good time right
now okay yes Ray has uh playing really
fast we know him to have some time
troubles but right now he has one hour
all right so we have the Cleon and well
I was about to say I don't remember Ray
playing the Dutch Stonewall M it's
coming uping up coming up coming up not
because of this move C5 right right
because of this move C5 um and now the
Dutch ston wall with
F5 and there's yeah there's a St you're
attacking me on the queen side you're
trying to break through and create
weaknesses on the the queen side I have
this beautiful Knight on e4 supported by
this D5 and F5 pawns yeah that's typical
Dodge Stonewall idea uh but I have to
say I mean this is looking like a very
good version for Bishop on is happy to
kind of have space to breathe absolutely
very good version for black H5 H4 uh
shades of Miguel naidorf one of his
Immortal victories uh for Miguel
involved H5 H4 okay keep an eye on that
one and finally Sam Shanklin Jeffrey
Jang as we just go around the board I've
got the wrong tournament I just wanted
to catch up with the players it was
great uh have having Nick on board and I
know he he actually wanted to hey can I
play some chess you that was why I
brought up uh the Carissa game I just
wanted to
see okay minority attack uh I do like
Sam's position I won many of these uh
style positions as white just pressing
against C6 create a weakness there and
then just put all the pressure on that
yeah just bring everybody I can to
attack the pawn on C6 so I like White's
position there lanir we've been we just
discussed and then finally um well uh
Andrew Tang did capture on B3 wait a
minute we were expecting to capture the
other Knight but Sam decided to capture
the Knight on B4
instead because we were looking at C
takes B3 exactly and then we
were hold on then we were looking at
F6 it was really weird so let let's just
see so we take so he's basically saying
look I want to play Knight C6 if you
take my Rook first of all the knight's
not coming
out but secondly this Fork I'm going to
win material so you have to come back to
D4 right so Knight to
D4 is there a way that I can win
material Bishop year Bishop stopping the
intended Bishop
takes I guess we this is all forcing to
my eyes uh tell me if I'm missing
something here takes Knight C6 Bishop
take Rook takes but at the end of the
day did
I because I'm a pawn up right I'm going
through all of this uh to try to try to
win a pawn and here and at the end of
the day Andrew is happy so um we're a
little bit surprised by the decision of
uh Sam Sean to capture the Knight on B4
and not the Knight on
B3 oh but there's a tactical trick I'm
getting the echo from the production
Knight takes B5 here oo wow that's a
visual Knight takes B5 taking advantage
of the uh pin on the a file Knight takes
now I'm so happy the C six square is no
longer defending that simply wins but
wait a minute I'm already a pawn up
Knight takes
B5 Bishop takes Knight takes Bish Knight
C6 Knight C6 yeah important intermediate
move yeah this is and I can take this
but I'm happy camper Knight takes B5 I
think we missed something no I sort of
like uh the this a takes B4 right okay
you have to take the exchange you have
to take on A1 right you do yes yes
Knight D4 just loses Knight B5 beautiful
move and I'm sure Andrew is going to see
it so he has to take on A1 we we we
stopped ourselves right here and said
isn't this winning yeah it's very good
yes it's very good knight C6 it's not
completely winning but it's very good
because I'm going to have ideas of
trapping that Knight as well so let's
keep going Queen D7 Queen so you're
obviously playing against trapping my
knight on A1 yeah I'm I'm ready to go
Bishop here
and something similar to the Knight on
E7 so what do you do next I don't want
to have my knight track so you start
with that okay now I take on CA maybe
with the which Rook it doesn't matter
you you you can decide in a moment and
I'll play Bishop E3 so I'll guard oh you
have A5 that's right yeah so I would
take with the F it's very important in
yes okay so that means I don't just uh
easily it's not that easy uh snap the
Knight off the board and win the game
okay so a different approach if I play
Bishop D2 A5 going to do the same thing
well then you still play B3 so what I
was thinking was I was going to play
Knight here happily move my queen
happily move my knight but you do still
have B3 I do have ideas yes and in fact
maybe it's an even better version not
not as clean as I had hoped Okay so KN
takes A1 Knight takes E7 king h8 um
Bishop out Kate I will be AC if he has
Bishop E3 wanting to park that Bishop on
C5 keep well no I can I but I have
discovered
attack very lucky I have to ad very like
covered
attack uh nicely uh conceived well
conceived so Bishop c a okay Bishop C5
and A5 again just trying to rescue but
even if you open that a file you're not
really rescuing that night no but it's
it it exists okay uh otherwise we were
just winning okay and Rook takes yeah
well then there's Knight
G6 good
nice wow we think Sam Sean is really
having a nice Advantage oh yes from a
practical perspective I have to say okay
forget about what the engine is saying
saying that maybe black uh keep it close
from a practical perspective is not easy
at all no and in fact look at Andrew
right now he looks in disbelief hey did
I just miss Knight B5 now he realizes
that kn5 KN takes B5 and he's like yeah
I'm sort of busted I think that's the
thing I'm forced to capture on A1 it's
the mentality that he has right now he's
looking at the position he feels busted
and I don't think that he's going to put
the best resilience because of that
because he uh doesn't know and it's very
difficult I mean queen D7 is not an easy
move it's the best Square for the queen
but it's not that clear right yeah for
Andrew I mean in the interview by the
way very personable uh Charming
interview I felt by Andrew there you
know he could freely confessed that his
openings are not the stuff of his
colleagues here and rivals in this
tournament
that uh he's been suffering well guess
what you know Fabiano's openings are you
know world class it it's tough but in
particular I think Andrew has had a
difficult time in this tournament from
the openings but when he gets into
positions what he did against
Hans truly extraordinary uh well I'm
thinking of his resiliency against Hans
nean in particular he kept that Fortress
for 5050 moves oh it's not easy
bive yeah and again he comes in as a
lowest seed but his fighting spirit and
he told us in the interview that his
goal is to win one game and he got it
and he got it yesterday right he sure
did he's on minus to but he's winning a
bunch of rating yes he is yes he is
what's going on between a beum and
Jennifer as a fight for gold medals as
intense as ever after F3 she actually
did not take the bishop on C3 really I
would have grabbed it with both hands
exactly give me that
Bishop Knight D6 was the move played E4
Bishop B7 Bishop D3 Knight
f8 you can sense the walls closing in
right for Black's position right now
what's your next move right I know mine
I will go Queen to D2 maybe I will go
Bishop to B1 maybe Queen to F2 Queen H4
improve so many E5 you have to worry
about that as well guess what your clock
is ticking 25 minutes for Jennifer you
right now with a bunch of moves to make
22 um to be more precise so I have to
say this one is really not looking good
because you don't have any counter
chances if you try to change the nature
of the position you get yourself in
trouble if you try to go Knight G6 you
get yourself in trouble because that
opens up the H file with tremendous
consequences uh very dire consequences
those are so
once again let's remind our viewers
right what if what ifs if both of well
if in case uh the results are as follows
Karissa wins that means Karissa wins the
championship clear outright she's
already half a point in the lead Karissa
draws and begim wins and she looks Prime
to win her game then we have a playoff
tomorrow we're going straight into a
playoff Karissa loses and Begg him draws
once again we have a
playoffs if Karissa draws and begging
brw that's obvious Karissa will win the
2023 us wom sh championship and if
Karissa loses and beg him wins beg him
wins allright so a lot of possible
scenarios of course and a lot at stake a
lot to play and I have to say still very
balanced position in that Karissa versus
RU yangang game well it was that leap
frogging that we saw yesterday where uh
Bean came into the round half a point
lead over Carissa
beum refusing to uh claim the draw
against Arena and that was that would
cost her the national championship or a
tie breaks ticket yes that's going to be
painful okay to my eyes seriously bam
has a huge Advantage maybe a decisive
Advantage yes which means that Carissa
draws we're going to have a playoff
playoffs how is that game going uh
currently still very balanced um but I
cannot say that I really enjoy uh for
black what plan she chose okay which was
King to G8 and then King to H7 castling
by hand but not playing G6 I was
thinking about G6 King to G7 would have
been a bit better for the most part
because you don't have the dark Square
Bishop white doesn't have the dark
Square Bishop right but she does have
the light Square Bishop so now with the
King on H7 as we can see Kissa dropped
the bishop to C2 there's no more taking
on D5 you cannot touch this Knight on D5
because that's a discovery check and
that's game over so um that's why I
don't like this King on H7 as much as I
would have liked it on G7 at the same
time you still have to prove um that you
have a way to make progress in this
position as white and I still don't see
that perhaps it's time to start
exchanging some pieces Bishop takes C3
why not why do you take
with the
Rook if that was an option
whoops yes
sir I just somebody somebody think yes
you sometimes you've got to throw a
little monkey I mean you know of course
you're going to take with the Knight not
with the queen oh yes of course I mean
you don't want to the queen is uh the
best move according to the engine but
Bishop takes D5 you just told me it's a
discovered check oh gosh you're not
listening I I I I wanted to I wanted to
make sure that I had D5 Al I was afraid
back in the days when I was in a
different room you had an excuse but
right now there's no more ex to takes D5
check that's it game over sorry I was
going to play Knight E7 obviously in
this position um but yes then as you
mentioned Knight to E7 the problem with
Knight D7 is that I am in fact going to
take that pawn on A7 so don't allow me
to do that because this would be
problematic and again if you take on
check that's a che is ruining everything
I really don't like this night
right so let's look at Bishop takes
takes and
now look at this move okay that's D
that's a nice one okay Bishop to D3
Bishop to D3 yes give me your knight
okay yeah she's not going to play like
this Knight
F5 no that's not going to happen if my
take take and supposedly this is fine
for uh is my queen getting trapped if I
take the A7 Pawn Knight F5 yes Queen
takes A7 as you prescribed Rook to
A8 not getting my queen trapped am I
queen takes B7 no I don't think you are
I'm just simply going to take on B2
Queen C6 mhm not realistic again I
really don't see this as a way to go for
ruang I don't think she's going to touch
that Knight put it on D4 and two
sacrificing two pawns you have to be so
sure
no uh in that circumstance and to my
estimation she's not going to take on E3
either either so I'm curious I I don't
feel like it's positionally sound but
what if as black I try B5 now the idea
just to push for B4 because Karissa is
like not castling yet maybe thinking
about long Castle yeah why not why not
no and I want to get the D4 Square I'm
with Nick on this one I'm castling short
yes yesing short all the time yes are
you going A5
I mean the before seriously okay so it
really does have that spe nikov type of
feel to what if I try to stop you
right how do you continue again at some
point things will stop on this side and
my question is how am I pushing and I
the answer is4 yes maybe after King H1
first and thenly
G6 G6 yeah yeah now King H1 and again I
I I think it's all about that F4 yeah
but now there is no discovered attack
after I capture your knight so if I
capture on E3 you capture with que take
back with our Knight yeah because this
is what I wanted to avoid was Queen
takes E3 Bishop takes D5 I'll recapture
with the Knight and now I go B4 cuz
that's what what I wanted and I want to
jump with that Knight to D4 H okay even
at the cost of a pawn huh maybe I
shouldn't take it though but I take the
pawn feel feel the
force who's who's talking who's
talking take the
pawn I don't know I don't know Rook A6
by the way I'm also Queen B6 or Rook to
B8 I'm not so sure about this I think
set pawns on B5 will be captured later
this uh concerns me a little bit okay
you're kind of making a point there
that's
interesting if you take I go Rook d8 I
take and I think this is more than fine
for black comp full compens um none of
this will happen because she played the
move Knight to E7 which I sort of like
yeah well challenging the supremacy of
the D5 square and also she's going
towards G6 which will cover I think so
G6 maybe F4 later on okay Castle short
let's go
yes time to Castle King
G8 that's right
did were you told this as a young girl
uh this was called castling by hand you
would put your king to H7 you move the
rook and call it in Czech artificial
castling
artificial castling okay I like that
castling by hand artificial castling
Rook f8 uh King
G8 okay it looks like a normal position
yeah absolutely absolutely uh it's all
look I want to go back to the that
surprises me for a second is that Kissa
is not up on time and we know that she
usually is up on time but ruang is
keeping Pace with her and that's
encouraging if you are begging right now
and you're seeing this position you see
that nothing has happened nothing
drastic has happen in the position uh
still balanced and the times are similar
so definitely right now you know beging
can go back to her board and be like oh
yes I have my chances let's keep going
let's keep going I have my chances
speaking of chances she's she's got a
terrific Advantage which I think just
has increased over these last few moves
right but one more I wanted to go to can
we just take a look at Alis Lee because
she still has also an important game for
the third place okay
you I'm playing for a gold medal and
you're doing what uh take on you had
mentioned uh Christian that any any
trades in the center were actually going
to be helpful for Bon beum agrees
wholeheartedly look at this uh the
change now E4 E5 opening up these
Bishops that's certainly on uh beam's
mind well everything what white wants
right pair of Bishops opening up the
position and just staring at that black
king C5 and to be honest why didn't she
take on C5 right now and then play e and
then E5 which is exactly the point I
want break everything open uh isn't this
what you as strive for with the two
Bishops yeah but I understand E5 you are
blocking the bishop on B7 yes yes but
things at some point need to be concrete
right and right now I think this one
with dark Square Bishop on the long
diagonal getting open like this is going
to be deadly exactly my feeling as well
Bon wanted her cake and to eat it as
well she played the move D5 which uh
fits with your what you just said Kate
hey the Bishop on B7 is blocked and E5
if com as well well like if if if it was
beam's turn and she could play E5 I
thought it would be immediately a
catastroph uh Knight F7 on the board and
we've caught up with the I think we've
caught up with the players uh last move
but you know to my eyes I just think
that uh this is
overwhelming uh in fact and that beum in
this exact moment huge favorite uh to
win this game and Jennifer is starting
to get low on time she has 23 minutes
while begim has 55 minutes if uh if you
had this position how how would you
approach uh this position Kate yourself
I mean are you are you going to go all
in over here do you like Rook lifts I
mean there's too many tempt tempting
moves a lot of plants I know I would
definitely start thinking here a lot
because now is the decision time kind of
are you going to allow the Knight to
jump on E5 and block it or are you going
to give up the
pawn give up the pawn E5
sa how do I give up the pawn don't give
up the pawn I'm not
sure don't don't do that to me uh okay
so once again uh
D5 knight5 looks very nice Queen H5
allowing that Knight E5 move tickles the
Knight so okay let's say I try to block
Bishop B5 Bishop B5 ooh not allowing you
I'm coming Rook E3 Rook H Rook E3 Rook
lift yes going the yeah just so you
start to swing uh over I'm sitting here
going look I hate everything that's
going on in my position seriously I
don't like it one bit but I don't want
to see The Rook landing on H3 so my
Bishop is not doing anything there I'm
going to stop you with the move Rook uh
I'm stopping you for Rook
H3 I mean I kind of closing my eyes to
the king side because it looks so tragic
my intention for what it's worth is to
play Bishop to D7 I think all right I
going to start having some tactics if I
play D6 just a question if you take it
Rook D1 yes sigh okay you can go to C7
because I have a fork mhm you have to go
to B8 then you go d d8 That's I'm crying
that's game over I mean it's still very
risky to give up that D6 Pawn you you
have to calculate but you have these
ideas no you you this looks uh
overwhelming in fact to my eyes all you
know this Rook never moved this bishop
is actually sleeping at home this looks
awful just uh flat out awful I like what
you did you went you improved your
pieces with Bishop B5 Queen H5 Rook E3
and I was going backwards uh most of the
time as well this looks uh like and how
bad is it the engines usually uh
Surprises with with things like plus
pretty bad pretty bad not plus three
plus
2.3 again if you let the engine think
maybe it's going to uh go higher but yes
the idea is Queen to H5 seems to be the
best move Bishop to B5 the the exact
line that we actually uh covered Rook to
E3 is just one of those position that
it's so difficult okay objectively maybe
you're not completely obliterated but
you're playing this position and you
have 20 minutes on the clock and you
need to make a move right as well and
you play Bishop C8 and then you're done
right right then you're busted because
of these ideas of D6 by the way jumps to
plus five right wow doesn't not a
surprise and Bishop to C8 is a very
natural move yeah I'm trying to stop
Rook H3 after all it's just simply not
in an easy position to play no no
exactly um well this should obviously
beum win this puts uh the onus on
Carissa uh absolutely if beging wins she
is at nine points out of 11 and Karissa
let's to make sure that you know she
wins to Win It by herself or there may
be playoff it doesn't look like she's
going to uh lose this game because her
position looks very solid when you look
at the standings and you see Jennifer
our defending Champion tip for eight to
three and a half points you go oh my
gosh the wheels fell off truth be told
uh I had Jennifer as one of the players
I really thought was going to be
fighting uh for the gold medal with uh
Alice and uh this has just not been good
now let's turn our attention speak Alice
yes let's take a look at her shall we uh
I've been
desperate together tell us what's going
on I not sure what's going on but Alice
is a very open position I like her
Bishop on C2 okay see some traits at a
certain moment Alice said look I'm not
going to leave my knight here forever I
know you want to play F5 but I want to
put my uh Knight to work Knight E2
allowing uh shria to uh finally make a
break takes takes now KN came back haha
just fooling targeting that H5 Pawn just
a moment so she does walk in ah I've got
okay snatched okay there we go I don't
I'm not losing a I'm not sacrificing a
piece takes takes
Queen G3 uh pardon me uh prepping Queen
takes G3 takes takes
A3
and
well things just kind of exploded here
yeah because I'm thinking about for
example Queen takes G3 all right I will
probably play A3 takes B2 why else did I
I push the pawn to
A3 and black has some ideas with
sacrificing a rook Rook takes A2 let's
say I play Rook F1 for example as white
right oh actually and I was thinking
that maybe you want then I start with E4
and then you got your Rook A2 business
right this kind of thing what you wanted
yeah exactly although I do have King B3
King B3 yeah or so on it it but uh in
this position I thought that you wanted
to play
B4 oh wow so you want to be trapping
that room indeed I did uh if you take
the pawn on B5 something of this nature
right where uh
hello that's that's bad news uh maybe
some counter that Queen
F5 Queen F5 check good
point strangely uh strangely enough even
though this bishop is so passive it's
still lurking there isn't it yeah I
didn't like oh okay sorry I thought uh I
thought I would I thought my move B4 was
driving you back and then I wanted to
play Queen takes G3 sorry Kate I think I
got the the wrong the wrong memo on this
one shall we shall we try it again Queen
takes G3 a takes
B2 uh Rook
over and I I'm guessing Alice wants to
play Queen G6 here right so E4
yeah maybe I take on
e4 you know I I'm I am fearful of this
Rook A4 I I don't know do I have time
for A4 probably not oh I know what I
should do pardon me oh that's a good
move Bishop B4 stopping all the jokes on
their diagonal and attacking G7 instead
exactly and then that suddenly now I'm
feeling very good the pawn on B2 can
actually be a defender of the white king
Right double agent yeah double
agent uh treasonous traitorous upon on
V2 and as we go on break uh we would
like to uh remind everybody of a very
special message from the board of
directors that we've been through
playing throughout our broadcasts here
it
[Music]
is
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping Ground
Schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
uh Dr junor singfield and rock
singfield I would say that St lucious
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
send a hope that the game of chess will
always stay flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waste across the
[Music]
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
one of you know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kidss and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St lisis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
PRS at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
past sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis City in County
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting St Louis chess
club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States it also plays host to
an award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Cub Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy hello everyone welcome back to our
coverage of the 2023 National
championships in the open section we
have a winner let's just take a look at
the standings uh in the open Kate hon
the newly crowned Champion Fabiano
Karana Drew Drew his game today and he
is eight out of 11 the champion and wesa
so far second with six and a half points
he's waiting to see what is going to
happen in the game of lenier
Dominguez and Amisha also on the outside
trying to fight his way into second
he'll over have to overcome a very stiff
challenge in leavon aronian and tell us
about the women's standings for here
right now Kar s is leading the
tournament with eight and a half points
but I have to tell you beim is
completely winning in her game so she's
going to be leading the competition very
soon with N9 out of 11 and then we have
a two-way tie for the third place arena
crash and Alice Lee with 6 and a half
points remind me what happens uh in case
of a playoffs what are the two scenarios
that could uh do that chis well take a
look at this if Karissa wins Karissa
wins the championship if Karissa draws
and beging wins that's a playoff right
there IFA loses and beging draws that's
another playoff right there so those are
the Playoff scenarios that we're looking
at after this round all right uh just uh
looking at this round in that Alice Lee
game it just looks to me like suddenly
Alice Lee is dominant as she's a pawn to
the good her King is really really safe
and she did make that move B4 and and
ashria decided that well she was going
to drop the Rook back and that's why I
like the move B4 Rook takes B5 still
that Queen sight exactly and that's
exactly what happened well Queen takes
G3 came with a very very nasty potent
threat but after Rook F6 Bishop E4 this
is all Alice I mean it is just fantastic
I mean Alice is about ready to you know
post up with The Rook Rook to C6 Rook uh
to C1 threats of uh Rook takes B6 then
you can always draw back the queen to E1
D1 and kind of force the black Rook to
go away and you have three against one
on the king side truly it looks uh
absolutely absolutely awful for shria in
that fight for third place arena Crush
definitely has uh something to something
to say about it uh interestingly enough
when we saw the move Rook D2 um I was
May I think I was pining for uh H6
another uh challenge that uh Arena said
is I'll play F6 inviting you to capture
I'll recapture with the Knight the the
benefit of F6 over H6 is it does allow
me to release my Bishop right away we
were also worried for white playing
Bishop F4 right kind of forcing the
queen to go away so F6 is prepared
caring a E5 response for that move yeah
it indeed Bishop F4 E5 stops that and
maybe the move tatf played Bishop H3 is
again angling for the same idea Bishop
F4 uh because E5 Bishop D7 okay Bishop
H3 Bishop C5 and a tickle and there's
the bishop F4 guys isn't this over holy
SM smokes I whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa uh the queen
just a second hold on how exactly do you
defend that point um something happened
here because I was thinking that somehow
the bishop was going to get to C6 Arena
got wrong-footed and she was forced to
put her
Queen on C6 this is the square that the
bishop needs to go okay triples on the
dile I mean I've got to defend D7 if I
go Queen G3 now looking at got Bishop C7
and G takes
F6 I mean this looks horrendous for
black it truly
does whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that
would be third consecutive win really
what a finish at the US wom's
championships wow and to beat Arena as
well not only that she has six points
Arena has six and a half so you beat her
you Le frog her whoa and you take her
spot on the podium or if Alice Lee in
the fourth position also talk about
price money here right that's a big
difference uh which place you take for
sure EST tatf with six points facing off
against arena with 6 and A2 but Alice
Lee with 6 and a half points looks like
she's winning so she's going to get the
bronze over tatv even if tatv does seal
the deal of on this and why are we
saying it's a big difference well just
look at the the difference between third
and fourth place K exactly so that's a
$4,000 win for T between the fourth and
the fifth place yeah that's a that's a
big gap that's big and I'm looking at
this position that we just uh got uh
after Bishop F4 Queen C6 Rook D1 and if
I play Rook d8 I'm looking at this
position with after Queen G3 and I
despise what I've done with the black
pieces here I mean look F6 E6 the kn
blog there exactly The Rook not
developed hello everything is collapsing
there and the King's still stuck in the
center that's like you know a totally
misplayed opening here and I'm I'm
seeing shockingly
enough is on the board by the way yeah a
lot of misplayed openings uh by the
players are really surprising especially
Arena Arena has a lot of openings and
defenses in her repertoire guys qu3 is
deadly well T did didn't have I mean
that's a a double threat that this is
over this is actually over uh G5 takes
F6 as well as your move Bishop C7
hitting the Rook which is can't move you
just simply cannot allow I guess you
have to take on C3 is the only thing
that you can do okay and be and then
Queen takes C4 and pray close your eyes
close your eyes exactly but how do you
close your eyes after G takes F6 and
queen G7
uh you might start crying that's fine
Queen G7 Queen G7 Rook G8 Queen F6 Rook
f8 do I have to resign I wouldn't be
surprised if I have to resign starting
to look at some yes s hor takes D7 or
maybe que Queen takes d8 what do you do
after that yes uh
cry I have to go to E8 and then I go
Bishop G5 and very fortunately I don't
have the face of music of Bishop H5 not
the immediate mate but the mate is
coming on E7 and d8 but do we even have
to kind of play on the king side I was
thinking after Queen
G3 and you capture on B3 I
recapture and then I'm threatening just
Bishop C7 so after Queen takes E4 can I
just play Bishop C7 CU I want to grab
that rook and grab on
D7 yes and I don't see how you have any
counterplay well again it's so it's
impossible to to defend when your pieces
are dormant they're completely asleep on
the uh on the king side there I mean
night7 night E7 sorry
what
97 I
mean first of all 97 I immediately see
ideas of okay Rook D6 doesn't work yet
but you start what if I take on F6 and
then go Queen G7 let's try to activate
ab and then we want to transfer the
bishop to that a H5 Square why
not why not well what can I do Rook f8
you probably Rook f8 Bishop G4 this
looks like the transfer you just
mentioned because let's say you capture
yeah you cannot capture only for it's
defended with them oh this is so painful
this is just game over true true and by
the way let's let's continue with that
because I have a funny idea
please uh should I would you like me to
play Rook G or Rook f8 Rook f8 Rook f8
is fine Bishop G4 okay let's take on C3
okay now I'm not even going to take that
I'm going to give you a check okay and I
have a lot of ways to wh Queen takes H7
is one of them but this is the one no I
wanted Bishop d right yeah that's a
beautiful Bishop D I want to give you a
mate on E7 Oh I thought you want to grab
the Rook Queen takes f8 also that yes
yes oh man I thought you want oh no I'm
crying this is H this is just terrible a
thousand ways from Sunday takes on F6
takes on F6 Queen G7 I don't want to see
your transfer Kate I'm going to go Rook
G8 okay I'll take the pawn on F6 yay and
and I'm going to go for that okay I take
on C3 with the pawn yep well wait maybe
Rook takes D well okay Bishop takes E6
Bishop D6
also I think Bishop D6 might Bishop D6
let's start with that move well you
might you might start with the move but
you might finish the
game you know that once happened to me
with Victor kchoi we were playing Blitz
day after day after day after day and
crazily enough strange thing things
happen and I won two games in a row MH
and Victor said to me if you win a third
game you know what's going to happen I
go no he says you're going to lose a
partner like I started singing I'm going
to lose a
partner won the third game in a row he
took a walk Bishop D6 g a stop uh oo
wow uh just just an overwhelming uh game
there H for tatv who as you say is on on
a roll and just jumping to the game of
Alice because she had a dominant
position and Kate I think she's still
dominating actually and we left we we
just saw shria play Rook A4 Bishop D2
just keeping PA that pawn uh ashria
throwing CAU to the win Rook F4 I've got
a lost position might as well try to
make it we may want to take the Rook I
like Alice's Rook C4 there is no rush
with capturing that absolutely Queen to
D7 she's looking to take the pawn as a
shria okay now it's time to take the
Rook time to take the Knight and time to
take on F4 probably I think so and she's
done precisely that Queen takes F4
because now we have check on F5 the
other Rook is getting to the E file and
that should be enough to check made that
black king
absolutely uh very convincing game uh
here or the Finish is going to be very
convincing I think asria was doing well
somehow when she played the F5 move
maybe that was absolutely mtime because
this is a disaster
Christian where is our action well the
action is in the leaders uh games and in
both of the leaders games in the ladies
section take a look at this we we left
it off somewhere around here I think
after Bishop to B5 Rook to e Rook to E7
we were mentioning Queen to H5 that was
an option as well she decided to go
Knight to H5 so potentially looking at
Queen to G4 uh Queen takes G7 or Knight
takes F6 of course that's an idea as
well that's why she defend it this F6 uh
Pawn with the queen Knight G3 looking at
F5 Square no no no don't touch that but
now she had this move E5 she oh she
didn't play it she did not play it no
interesting she played the move Bishop
to C6 she still has the move E5 but this
is the pattern that she needs to go for
it's the pawn sacrifice and we've
actually looked at this type of idea
before as well to get D6 exactly because
look at the position of Black's pieces
they're so passive right you're not
playing with a lot of your pieces Rook
on eight Bishop on C8 Knight on f8 not
doing much and all I have to do is start
pushing my Pawn that's going to put a
lot of tension uh in the position
E5 would have been winning Knight takes
E5 Knight to E4 where do you go with the
queen you cannot go to C7 B8 d8 let's
say d8 right that's a reasonable Square
the best is to go to A7 I mean this
looks so ugly and by the way take a look
at this take a look at this finish right
here Rook takes C5 yes I'm not even
going to take that I'm just going to go
Queen to G uh D5 that's pretty oh guess
what I have another Rook take on E5 with
I'm going to take on E5 Rook takes E5
next Queen takes C5 create that battery
Bishop to C4 after the King goes to G8
All She Wrote absolutely devastating
consequences in this one so Bishop to C6
missed opportunity right there and now
she's probably thinking about doing the
same thing which is E5 which is the best
move in the position in this case maybe
I go Rook Tak C5 I I mean just to try to
uh and the funny part is I don't even
want to take that Rook yet oh boy and I
don't even want to take uh The Rook
after Queen to C7 I just simply want to
go Bishop to B5 followed by D6 so well
that need to get my D6 yes is an
indication that Bishop C6 Bishop C6 was
not good Bishop to C6 was not good and
it makes sense yeah it's a misstep
because D6 you're always going to have
these two pieces connected to each other
right so whenever you go D6 if I keep my
queen on C7 I can take the Bish Pawn C
so you have to L another Tempo it's just
not a good insertion of these moves
Bishop to C6 Rook to B the plan is to go
E5 sacrifice the pawn blast open the
position right that's the idea not with
a bishop Pawn
C6 but Jennifer looks like she's not
interested in anything that's going on
in this game like she's only it's like
one of those you know you look with a
half an eye like this this game is not
going my my way and and what have I done
wrong yeah and she may be regretting not
capturing actually that Bishop on C3
right you guys were saying you would
capture that Bishop on C3 with both
hands because now that's going to be a
very big player in the game and why
would I have captured that Bishop with
both hands because of that variation
with Rook takes
E5 I mean are you kidding me how many
games have I lost to a magnificent
Bishop on the long diagonal uh sacrifice
that uh even for an exchange at this
moment but again I mean Bishop to C6 the
trend is not favoring beging in the last
couple of moves Bishop to C6 was not the
right solution she had to find this move
E5 maybe she will find the move E5 but
right now is not as impactful as it was
before Bishop to C6 still a great
position for begging but take a look at
what's happening is about ready to win
the game by the way Alice is definitely
just about to to to finish the game but
we knew that for a while C's wow look at
Carissa Castle's long this one is
getting interesting take a look at mean
uh Nick said Castle short
and tournament victory in sight I was I
was there with Nick yes all the way with
Nick for sure B5 because because of this
reason I'm going to attack you vious
plan to try to get control of the D4
Square by the and open the position and
check you that's right have we seen
Karissa like Carissa's been the one on
the offense like she did with Anna
zansky she was she was she wasn't now
she's on the defense what if I take on
C3 right what do you take back with well
I hate taking back with the Knight you
want to take on E5 I have some Knight F6
yes and how is this position by the way
a lot of pieces pair of Bishops for
black I don't think he can take
compensation if you take back Bishop to
B4 traps the queen just on the spot on
the spot if you take don't take with the
pawn you're going to get checkmated
somehow Rook to B8 Bishop A3 you don't
want to see that on the board like this
right Bishop A3 no bueno no maybe you
have to go Knight to D1 but I mean it's
not fun when Rook takes D yeah okay it's
not no no no no no no no but Queen to E1
definitely signals that she wants take
on
E5 at the same time if ruang with
minutes calculates this takes it one
move at a time and calculates this
Knight takes F6 this is starting to look
dangerous for Carissa in fact most
likely after take take uh on E5 like
this can you take on C3 with sorry
you're taking my Pawn on E5 and it's a
good
idea if I take on
B2 what just just help me out here what
am I missing oh you want to take like
this what if I cuz I was wondering if
the problem is actually sort of helps me
I keep looking and I'm forgetting the
king is on H7 yeah that's I'm sorry I
mean I'm so that King on H7 is not a
common uh pattern that I us to G6 and
King G7 exactly still exactly look
Karissa is making her moves fast so
that's good for her because she's
putting a lot of pressure on ruy Yang's
clock at the same time the position is
getting more and more difficult more and
more double-edged the way I see it and I
have say ruang has been playing very
powerful chess she did spot the moment
she played B5 A5 not lost a single Tempo
and that's very important because if you
lose one tempo in this type of races
who's going to Checkmate who first if
you lose a Tempo then you're too slow
that's decisive yeah and she's not
losing any tempies so far by the way
once again Alice Lee just played move
Rook E1 which is a key indication she is
ready to play Queen E8 and I think that
will just simply win the game
and keeping in mind that arena is dead
busted uh against tat by the way tat
said you know what Bishop D6
immediately is also very very powerful
takes Queen GC Queen G7 is on our agenda
as well as Bishop takes uh B4 uh Arena
busted simply busted out of the opening
here um Christian completely busted yeah
I mean by the way if you take on D6 I
think I can take on D6 and then take on
E6 as well right that's even even more
convincing Bishop takes D6 Rook takes D6
let's say the queen goes away and then
what you're saying is thanks to the
double way but I would still wait with
that maybe capture on F6 I mean t has
all the time in the world with her
pieces that's the vultures speaking yes
I mean we're Pi menu of good options uh
picking the bones but Bishop D6 I gets
my vote as well well if we take a look
at game Lenard Dominguez against Hans
Neiman because I'm wondering if Hans is
starting to get advantage in that end
game oh kidding really first of all
lener Dominguez is starting to get very
low on time he has only seven minutes
but only one move to make okay so that's
okay okay so funnily enough back from
our starting position we were looking at
night D5 and uh after a trade to try to
REM maneuver our Knight to E4 I said
said I asked Christian what about C4
with the idea of dropping a knight on D5
and lanir thought that's a good idea let
me do it that way strangely enough he
didn't trade
Queens huh I thought he was going to
head for that better Knight versus block
position and you have pair of knights
and he traded oh pardon me he challenged
for the a file did lanir but now black
is the one who's keeping full control of
the a file by the way I like what Hans
is doing uh bringing his Bishop to an
open diagonal on um F6 it wasn't
bothering anybody and doing anybody
any fears no fears there and then this
Knight A5 move so I'm targeting B3 Pawn
clear you have to go back to defend
maybe you need to play Knight E3 because
if you just go back Queen B1 okay I may
start to go Queen E2 and pay attention
and I mean F5 F4 I'm going to start push
on the king side you know I'm fearful of
your queen Coming to E2 let me get rid
of the queen just go away I completely
miss that move right and white is
totally okay and then you know like now
that I've driven you back let me defend
the pawn and okay I think it's a draw I
think it's a balance completely blocking
that position right you did scare me
when you suggested that uh things were
going very very badly but also you had
mentioned Knight E3 driving the queen
back but then I'm happy to probably get
the Knight for that Bishop right I'm
sure you are again move back kind of
force and then and if I go Knight C6 if
put the Knight on B yeah it's probably
still very equal very I just like that
the Black Knight is targeting the B3
pawn and kind of tying Queen to that
pawn whereas while white is not really
targeting black pawns agreed agreed but
the F3 I think that's a very strong move
all right uh well that no definitely and
when we had left it there was a Sam seon
game which was
absolutely fascinating uh right in this
moment this uh a takes B4 forcing the
move Knight takes A1 I mean again if you
were playing a Blitz game you would play
Knight D4 like Al aemp and you think
well maybe I'm okay give me a chance to
play Bishop B7 maybe and Knight takes B5
would really rock your world and you go
oh to oh yes I was like oh no uh but
therefore because of the Knight takes B5
tactic Knight takes A1 and the
players went to this position remember
we were looking at stuff based on A5
let's see how Sam did it Rook E4 is he
about a rook lift Queen H five and Rook
H4 Rook
E4 wow
so Queen because remember you don't have
H6 after I double on the H file because
my Bishop on C1 can fly over and just
grab that pawn okay let me get on my
tracksuit and just ask you are you going
to commit your queen to H5 I commit okay
H5 oh but now you can take on C2 that
was my dream yes very tricky oh well
thank you very much I the old the old
pwn capture and the still has some
Wicked wickedness uh so let me start
with Rook H4 okay fair Rook
H4
yeah I'm not a f I'm not a
fan but
again7 now which is targeting The Rook
not allowing Queen H5 because of
background checkmat thank you thank you
for that
I was just about I have to be a little
bit cautious the bishop probably on C1
needs to get out the bishop E3 Bishop C5
we talked about that maneuver but why
didn't you like it Rook so what is the
idea behind Rook E4 the idea behind it
is like if I play A5 to Res because you
want to play this right like say Rook E4
let's say I play King G8 why don't you
bring out your pieces and you're
threatening Queen takes A1 right right
so then you can I I've got no choice
I've got to play some kind of
tricky uh
stuff to rescue my
knight so Bishop C5 yeah but then the
question is why did you need Rook E4 and
the answer is Christian help me out here
why did Sam play the move Rook E4 when
we were looking at I don't know Bishop
E3 Bishop D2 We had other Rook E4 is he
going to go Rook H4 because it's the
best move in the position no way yes and
what is the underlying motive the idea
is that you want to also start looking
this Knight on A1 will be trapped at one
point um I I don't need to hurry with
that what I can do in the meantime is
ideas of Rook to H4 Queen to H5 and then
sacrifices on H6 that's one way that
direct wow he wasn't working for us why
not why not absolutely by the
way win we expected this yeah that was
overwhelming that she is going to be uh
clear third clear third because not
winning her game unless a complete
Miracle happens for every no that would
be or a complete tragedy for T and what
a great finish for Alice because she
started a little bit slow but then she
just a little bit slow I mean half out
of three I mean two losses we didn't see
that coming but you're right she flew at
the end I mean once she got pass those
first three rounds then she had an
amazing score by the way take a look at
this concept is really cool Rook to E4
if A5 which makes a lot of sense right I
will take take and now I go B4 I go back
you go back let's say to A7 so that you
can double and defend right but Bishop
to B2 is a big big problem in the
position not only that I'm attacking
your knight but take a look at this
diagonal that's and now we understand
why the Rook is on e4 right Rook to G4
might be coming in the position
this one is looking really really bad
for example I don't even have to hurry
it's a long-term advantage and there's
no saving this Knight in fact and the
bishop coupled with the action of the
knight in
fact protect against all the entry
squares for blacku so that render your
pieces kind of useless in the position
I'm immobilized I can just simply go H3
and just uh keep improving my position
Queen to E2 Rook to H4 Rook to F4 and
you have nothing to play no I'm going to
go C6 F6 though just show me how you win
it I mean I I I do believe White's Mass
Oh I thought you were going to go Queen
E2 and I was going to play well I have a
lot of ideas Rook G4 Rook H4 Queen E2
all of those are in my back pocket yeah
F F6 let's
go okay let's start with Queen F5 so I
don't allow the queen H5 good move good
move okay F6 F6 no
now okay what is this queen C1 I'm not
sure I understand that Rook F4 Knight
takes
F6 I'm starting to have some sacrifices
ideas yes yes some sacrifices are there
definitely I really like this bishop on
B2 much it's Beau much more active than
that one on C5 we transl there there's
no uh there's nothing to worry about for
white that's the thing I mean I'm an
exchange down one I understand that I do
have a pawn for it but the doubled Rooks
are in immobile yeah that's it they they
they don't anything useful anything
active in the position so that's Sam's
devious plan I have to say very good
move this Rook to E4 uh we left it and
it was a rather exciting position I must
say Mishra versus leavon remember that
was the Knight B6 there was a knight on
G4 let's let's get to that moment I this
was
a a a perfectly Tim move uh this move
Knight B6 and it really clears as to who
has the Advantage because at first blush
you know you look at your Bishop on G2
and it's kind of a dead piece and you
said it's not obvious but uh once
these pawns were cleared off the board
then the resulting position it's Mishra
because you see the delay Pawn on D6 and
that's going to be a big Target for the
rest of the game exactly and you see two
against one on the queen side very nice
going be a runner easy uh majority easy
for white to play uh Rook C1 and now I
like this move Bishop F1 very
much uh leavon is not going quietly he
needs to do something right he cannot do
anything on the queen side nothing in
the center so he's trying to get a game
on the king side Rook G6 now that's a
big decision Knight he's coming to D4 to
the F5 F5 Pawn I C5 to just captur the
pawn on A6 right exactly I was I
seriously I was in the in the same
direction uh Knight takes B7 Rook C Rook
C5 just to capture the pawn Mishra said
no no no I want to put a knight on D4
we're catching up to the position and
the more I'm looking at I'm telling you
uh this is really looking good for
Mishra he's up against a
2800 here uh in this the uh Championship
round very very impressive play by
Mishra but we have Alice in studio with
you Christian Alice you started the
tournament slowly but you picked up the
pace just like a very experienced player
and you are a very experienced player at
such a young age first of all
congratulations from us uh tell us a bit
about today's game and assess your
overall performance in this
competition yeah thank you uh so for
this game I played like this 5 to
win the king Indian um it's something
that I prepared but I don't she
definitely like I haven't played I only
played like night KN of three um and I
played it twice in this tournament so I
think it was the opening I was able to
get uh a pretty comfortable position I
mean uh I didn't get like the exact move
order but I kind of knew like the ideas
of the position uh till like around move
20 um so I think I I'm happy with the
opening position I got and then after
that I mean there was some point later
in the game where um so you knew the
ideas all the way to here yeah yeah I
kind of knew like okay Bishop C2 um
Bishop D1 Bishop C2 Rook C1 I think I
probably should have done Queen D2
instead of Queen C2 earlier but um so
here like then I knew kind of the idea
that I'm supposed to go and try to
attack the A4 Pawn um and I was like
overall very happy with my position uh
here after this I thought that I would
probably be winning because okay but
Queen E1 I feel like ibly shouldn't have
done because um it I mean I'm sure I'm
still winning it's just that it uh it
it's like it's not unnecessary I could
do something like Queen E2 first then
Bishop D2 and then Queen E1 and uh it's
pretty safe um or Knight C3 and 94 okay
but uh I think after this I was still
able to win and it was uh very nice for
me to win um yeah so overall I started
really badly um in the first three
rounds but I think after that I was able
to come back um I think especially my
round four win was really important
because that game I was uh like it was
super crazy I was winning I was losing
then I was winning again um and for me
to like get that like super crazy win um
I think is in some ways even better than
uh getting a solid win um and yeah so
overall I finished uh 7 and 1 half out
of 11 and I think that's uh a good
performance for me um I broke 2400 for
okay I did it before but this is the
first time where my official rating
should be above 2400 uh and that's also
something that I'm happy about well
congratulations and that in fact will
give you the international Master title
so uh that's quite impressive Alice
congratulations from us guys any
questions absolutely absolutely Alex you
are having incredible year again
congratulations on this performance you
also won the 2023 us junior girls
championships uh you played extremely
well winning gold medal on the first
board for the US national team at the
world Team Championships I mean the the
successes are just piling up what's next
for you what are your plans
um I think I have a few more tournaments
before uh the end of the year uh so
actually right after this I'm playing in
the I of men Grand Swifts tournament um
so I'll get a few days break and then uh
I'll be going to uh iow man tournament
um and that tournament is of course
pretty important um yeah so overall this
year has been pretty successful I was
not expecting this tournament to be uh
to end this well especially since I
started out so badly I was just hoping
to get an equal score um but yeah I'm
really happy with this result and also
some of my previous results um and I
hope at least in the next few
tournaments that I'm playing in I'll be
able to keep it up I don't want to put
any pressure on you but I'm being asked
by a lot of people uh if you are
aspiring to become grandmas you know if
you want to break that record before you
turn 15 I know you talked about setting
your own goals is Grandmaster Norm your
kind of upcoming
goal yeah um I mean I I will be playing
in some tournament where I can't get the
norm after the next tournament if I
perform well enough but of course um
it's very hard I'll have to um keep
working on improving my uh chess and um
I will of course try to become a
Grandmaster uh I'm not thinking about uh
any sorry record in specific um yeah my
microphone is it's okay take your time
commentators cursed Alice this is what
we deal with all the time no worries no
worries okay
but I know that awkward
feel well we've had that yesterday with
fa trying to adjust his his earpiece
that was funny that was pretty good
stuff we're going to get that super glue
you know stick it stick them on uh but
we're we we we're going to get Alice uh
back because uh she's for me fantastic
let's go back Alice you're back welcome
back how
awkward
yeah Alice you were explaining uh
grandmas uh your goals and The
Grandmaster
title um yeah so I would like to become
a Grandmaster but I'm not I'm thinking
about like setting any records you know
it's uh it's a long process and I still
have to at least um improve my scope
because I don't think I'm at the skill
level quite yet but um we'll see I mean
of course it depends a bit on luck in
certain tournaments uh but uh hopefully
luck will continue to be on my side for
this year absolutely well you've had
again a fantastic year maybe not the
tournament that you hope for here but
very very good luck uh in the aisle of
man that will be well along with the
Qatar Masters which is going on now the
strongest Swiss tournament in the world
so uh definitely a challenge for
you yeah definitely thank you and there
are some uh candidate spots uh in I love
men as well so that definitely is a very
very important uh one do you have any
aspirations to qualify to the candidates
right
now um I mean okay I'll I'll try my best
um but I guess it's like it's extremely
hard the field there is extremely strong
so um I'll see I'll try to do my best
and I'll see where that Tak takes me
that's going to be an interesting
tournament to follow for sure thank you
Al thank you very much uh just you know
just fantasy go go along with this I
mean we've all seen the Netflix and Beth
Harmon and we all know that g uh pardon
me Gary kaspar that Bobby Fischer became
a
candidates uh um and became a
Grandmaster by becoming a candidates but
how crazy like ridiculously insanely
crazy would it be Alice Lee goes to the
aisle of man performs like a boss
qualifies for the candidates becomes a c
a grandmas I mean it's right out of the
Beth Harmon Series right that would be
great the the the media would be all
over you heard it here
first wow uh something to really dream
about uh Christian but uh tell us about
the ladies well let's take a look and
actually let's see Karissa right now
because she's been thinking for a very
long time she's down to her last 6
minutes this move Queen to E8 after
Queen to E1 just completely stopped her
in his tracks 14 minutes think right now
she was at 20 minutes right now she's
down to her last 6 minutes with 18 moves
to go that's not easy in such a
complicated battle with so many threats
circling around the board and so many
transition possible transitions right
you go F5 do you take on E5 why do you
take you take on B4 you have so many
options this is not going to be easy and
right now you know the nerves are
starting to kick in as well because you
know if you win this one you're the
champion right but if you don't then
you're opening up the gates for
potentially Begg him not taking
necessarily the crown if you manage to
save a drw but perhaps forcing the tie
breaks uh so take us through the current
position the move Queen E8 not an
intuitively obvious move I think uh many
people would have been reaching for the
Rook so that you could bring your king
back to G8 maybe reaching for the pawn
on F4 or she's really just trying to get
the queen away from the defile because
we saw that if Karissa captures on E5 we
need to recapture with the pawn and then
the queen can be targeted so one one of
those SEC and there we have it night
takes so this is why
ruing and evacuated the defile because
she was afraid but Christian pointed out
that maybe black is fine he just capture
the Knight and then get another Rook for
the queen and has a lot of pieces for
the queen yeah but I think he actually
started with that particular sequence
was B takes Pawn takes Pawn takes Knight
F6 so the pawn would already be there uh
we're just going to catch up with the
players cuz she did play Queen E8 Knight
takes E7 on the board Queen takes e F
and then you talk about the Transitions
and you know do you play with f takes E5
do you play with F5 the problem should I
be capturing on B4 please for Kissa is
that Black's moves are more or less
forced you're not going to go Bishop D7
Bishop D7 allowing Knight D5 that's not
well now now I've got tremendous control
over the center and in fact the queen
side now I even start to think about
picking up the Pawns
so correct there's no choice Bishop
takes you're pretty much forced and the
problem is that right now your Bishop on
C2 suddenly becomes sort of
useless because you take on E6 or you
take on E3 it doesn't really matter
let's take on E6 sure Bishop C5 and we
get that position but the thing is the
pawn from E4 no longer
moves there's no way in which you're
going to open up your Bishop
anymore squares
thank you uh Kate I mean we can we we we
we've got uh a diagonal if I can get
Queen on F5 Bishop on B3 why not okay
Bishop B3 by the way Bishop takes E3 on
the board as you prescribed Christian
it's just forced right yeah it's forced
you cannot allow the Knight to to D5 AG
agreed but hold on and this Bishops of
opposite color position who has the
attack yeah I mean precisely who has the
advantage let's say I
go here kind of
eyeballing
um let me take on f8 let me just do it
the worst possible way and take here
sure I'll take let's say with the pawn
with the pawn I really want to keep that
Bishop Pawn C5 I feel like that
construction right there blocks any sort
of ideas that you might have on the
queen side yes yeah and I can really get
my Bishop to F5 as exactly yeah and well
I was dreaming let's say just G3 I was
dreaming to get my queen to C4 right if
I could get my queen to C4 I'd always be
eyeing a G8 but Rook F2 it's not that
easy uh to get my queen around the board
so I can also try for Bishop D4 I have
to be careful because you may just grab
that Bishop with the rook and Rook F2 is
hanging but in some instances when the
queen moves I'm targeting B2 Square yes
here I might bail I seriously I might
just give you the pawn and say well I'm
not going to take on exactly oh there's
Bishop C2 Bishop C2 and I'm not taking
that but yeah but I might just bail
there with Rook to D2 and go into
Bishops of opposite
scenario okay there are some worst case
scenarios uh okay so if Karissa draws
and beIN beim wins which she is having a
very good position then we have a
playoff and if kisel loses and begim
draws playoff again but if kisel loses
and begim wins then it's beim who gets
the championship title that is a worst
case scenario no question uh no no no
doubts about it but let's just jump to
our Phenom uh our 14-year-old Mishra as
well as 14-year-old Alice Lee uh they
showing some skills in this seriously
but like no no no no this is not a joke
just this is a dominating performance
look at this these doubled Rooks on the
C file control all of the vital squares
including
C7 terrible Knight ter terrible Bishop I
mean I mean for me it's really Leon's
pieces are doing nothing yeah and how
just Mishra was like very patient with
that Knight on A5 not going for extra
Pawn but just transferring it to a
better Square so much much positional
understanding brilliant no seriously
this is a simply an outstanding game and
leavon knows that he has been
comprehensively outplayed this is not a
position he's happy about at all there's
nothing to do on the queen side in the
center on the king site leevon can just
be waiting exactly uh once played a game
where the the position was described as
uh you know worse in the center worse on
the greens but lost on The King side I
would I would go so far to say worse on
the king side worse in the center but
lost leavon is lost on The Queen side as
uh A4 A5 I don't know if um he play if
Rook B6 was a threat or not but this
move A5 basically what that does is it
nails down the pawn on A6 it means that
you're perpetually always going to have
to be uh defending that pawn and it's
threatening Rook C7 a direct attack
because once you capture The Rook the
other Rook gets there and then you know
the bishop can be trapped or Pawn on a
A6 will be hanging I got I feel like
I've got no choice but somehow the
problem is now I go B5 ah and then I've
just walked into the pin a nasty pin and
if you allow my Pawn to get to
P I'm crying do that I'm damned if I do
and damned if I don't this is just
terrible it's a very sad position it's a
very it Tru a very sad position don't
have any way outs and A5 uh fantastic
game by by Misha B and that was the 40th
move that's why we don't see Mishra
anymore because he made his 40th move he
had two minutes um when he made it so
for leavon this is stunning uh because
he finally got uh to 50% he had been
nursing loss uh he won and you know okay
you kind of start to feel like okay the
tournament you know you're playing
yourself into shape something good has
happened for you at long last and then
this that played against him because
let's be honest today he took a lot of
risks with his opening Choice we've seen
that Knight C6 against the G3 Kings
Indian we don't see leavon playing the
Kings indan by the way guys I see
something happen in the Karissa Yips
position that's I wonder if there is a
blunder on Karissa side or if she
calculated really deeply really nice I'm
not sure about that so B3 happened we
left it Knight takes E7 F5 Bishop takes
E3 Queen takes E3 Bishop C4 we were
first of all we were mainly focused on
on takes uh Bishop takes B takes C4 I
think this is a problem because look at
this after takes Queen B7 forcing Bishop
B3 but now Rook takes C4 Rook takes C4
followed by A4 and this is just game
over I have too many pawns not A4 first
a king oh my good or even Queen takes C3
A4 no Rook takes C4 is necessary to play
first not allow the queen to get closer
and then A4 and E4 is hanging just Rook
C4 was can I go A4 A4 any Oh I thought I
go E4 anyway now I was going to go King
C2 to get out of a C3 C2 then I capture
on e4 okay is this completely completely
you cannot touch the C3 Pawn cuz you're
going to go A4 next anyway a
yeah is com I was I was planning on
going for a
walk no there's no
walk very dangerous there's no
walking it's it's it's the plank
actually a blunder not Rook takes C4
she's played A4 and after King C2
Karissa has to play King C2 right now oh
but this is transposition Rook take no
Rook takes C4 doesn't work now because
Bishop takes C4 and the King run and the
this was the walk that I hoped for it's
not the walk of
shame but big Miss by ruang but she's
still in the lead in terms of objective
assessment of this position is it why
King C2 well I can take on uh B3 and my
attack continues like you're going to
Rook A8 you take on C3 not so fast I was
going to go Rook A1 but then Rook H B8 I
think that's uh over
Rook H B8 Queen takes E4 yeah you can
never capture with Queen on C3 oh that's
nasty you're absolutely right that means
I have to go for a walk with King takes
C3 but you're going to play Rook hb8
anyway immediately oh well I thought I'm
going to start Rook A3 Rook A3 Rook a
not sure if it's a difference Rook B1
Rook B8 okay now I'm I'm All
huddled Queen takes C3 take C3 well that
gives up the E4 and F5 pawns wow Carissa
no definitely Carissa is losing this now
no this has to be Los this just it's
terrible oh my gosh I mean they flipped
in round 10 beum comes into the into
round 10 half a point lead blunders
loses the game chiss is in the lead it's
a hot potato lead what is going on as
but wait ran Yan is not capturing that
pawn on e4 what B8 just a second what
are we missing here
folks
not3 this was check I think Queen takes
C4 Queen takes Queen to D3 she was
worried about
okay but ruang is playing these moves so
quickly and she has 15 minutes on the
clock whereas Kisa less than three
minutes so Karissa is forced to play
really fast whereas ruing Yang can take
some time to think putting a lot of
pressure on the clock I can play King B
but can I play also just Rook E1 to
defend that
pawn yes why not because if we trade
Queens I'm happy I survived I'm putting
pressure on you almost uh you almost has
a grateful uh grateful that you could
trade Queens I agree wholeheartedly
trading Queens is uh and you know if I
was in uh ruang shoes I would never
trade Queens and I would have played
Queen takes E4 check but Rook B8 maybe
Carissa's in the game still after1 look
let's not forget she's a pawn up right
now karisa is a pawn up but if the pawn
on e4 fails then if black captures it
then I mean King B2 King B B2 we're
expecting Queen take C4
finally for sure very surprised not to
see Rook H E1 I seriously I couldn't
agree with you more and inviting any
kinds of Queen trades would be
uh because look at The Rook on D1 it is
targeting another Pawn on
D6 absolutely no this is a very peculiar
time trouble scramble that Karissa finds
herself and she just played the move
King B2 inviting Queen takes E4 by the
way yeah you cannot capat on D6 right
that's an important Point yeah I mean
with G2 hanging I think Carissa's Queen
C2 yeah would would would be planning
Queen C2 in this case defending
F5 just want to make sure that Rook
takes I think it was a Jennifer Yu
versus Arena Rook takes me to like ah
everything exploding everything explode
and the thing is any sort of end games
right now after Queen Tak C2 are very
good for
Carissa because you have the B Pawn
which is going to run
and you don't have you also have a
weakness that you have to deal with that
D6 we okay but again time trouble is
such a shouldn't we be a bit more
forceful though please why don't we go
Queen
A8 what do you think of that que A8 yes
um my spidey sense is tingling why can't
I take the PA you're going to take on B3
that's right that's my
plan ah Rook takes that's a so the queen
is overloaded isn't that funny that we
play Rook takes D6 Rook takes B3 and we
can't take with the queen cuz that wins
Back The Rook if we take with the King
you win this Rook MH very maybe yeah
very very very funnily enough right we
pick up the rook and we're happy for
that trade of the weak D6 PA but we can
go Rook
A1 can we do that yes yes Force the
queen to go somewhere and then the other
Rook to D1 yeah but that was a question
did did our Rook get pulled away from a
good offensive I don't know I think the
open file is it's good open file yeah
open files should be good uh and wow
what a Twist of turns here the game I
mean A5 A4 well I'm just like very very
confused by by this decision of Karissa
not to go for the the yes exactly and
then
by not to play Rook takes C4 because
Rook takes C4 is such a visually
attractive move you want to play C2 you
want to play A4 you want to play E4 and
then this one also critical moment of of
the game I have to say this Rook takes
C4 if she stops and thinks and
understands my guess is that she didn't
realize that C2 is another threat in the
position as well uhhuh with a Pawn on A5
so she probably thought that maybe Kissa
can go something like King way oneor I'm
just going to refresh apologies yeah
this is the current position King B2 on
the board by the way if you move back to
move 25 before Carisa playing B3 cuz
that just such a gambling move to play
B3 after no yes takes bishop and now to
play B3 I wouldn't be
reaching but what else well okay I mean
I take take take on A2
sorry this is what she was worried about
and you can take on C2 in this case oh
so it was kind of defensive move it
might have been a forc decision for
Karissa you know I would again because
of the tournament result T tournament
situation the Bishops of opposite color
again this might have been one that I
would have grabbed with uh both hands
because you know the the drawing margin
is so high and I just want to secure
that the worst thing that could happen
is a playoff uh no Carissa didn't go for
that and she finds herself in well a
great fight going on here how is Bam
doing by the way sorry I just wanted to
say ask the times so Kissa has 2 minutes
whereas ruing y 11
minutes nerves but car has to be kind of
relieved now that she surviv that attack
on the queen side true that
and and of course if caressa wins no
playoff she she she's our new Champion
uh Jennifer the position has
become murky has uh yeah she improved
her position Jennifer for sure uh
enormously doubling on the C file and
that pawn on C4 maybe we will see the
pawn to C3 and C2 like game againsta
Crush by the way uh can I go B4 can I go
C wait so what was the last move guys
okay we just uh return Knight F5 and
then Knight to D4 that's a very strange
move I have to say yeah strange sequence
yeah I think you're transferring the
Knight to E6 uhhuh and some attacking
The Rook I mean trapping The
Rook okay so let's uh agree
uh that I want to open up the C file for
just a moment and how is the uh not
necessarily end game but how is the
position after Queen takes B3 Queen
takes B3 I want to defend that pawn on
A4 and attack your Pawn on B6 okay
Knight
C4 Knight C4 okay I was about to suggest
Rook C4 but okay Knight C4 right by the
way we need to keep in mind that
Jennifer has only one minute and change
is that correct it's not a lot of time
that is for
sure Jennifer has has two and a half
minutes whereas be 13 minutes be has 11
minutes Advantage wow I mean here it is
here's the championship on the line C4
takes B3 will they go down our
variation but again we were worried
about Jenifer you kind of being pack
made it on the king side right and she's
solid there right now the No No that
scene is now happening on the queen side
history yeah that's history oh she her
position dramatically yeah cuz Queen
yeah I said murky but I'm looking at
Queen takes
A4 basically this big Pawn on D5 it's
blockaded so that's not a factor
remember when we had our Bishop on B2
and we had pushing E5 Knight takes F6
and Rook takes F6 and all kinds of
business Queen captures Queen Tak B3
yeah we were just uh looking Queen B3
Knight C4 because you you you mooved
Knight E6 was trapping The Rook uh Kate
so in this case reminding white let me
just clear the sea file the sea file is
actually uh the potency for for for for
black as strong I want to play Knight E6
that's on my agenda okay then I will
start with Knight E5 Knight G E5 Knight
to g e now I'm assuming that Knight
E6 doesn't win an exchange for oh I'm
going to capture on D2 she has takes
B3 and Knight takes B3 and then you
capture on D7 correct KN and then you've
got two knights and you're happy sorry
let me no but Rook takes D2 after um of
course so Rook here Knight E
E5 Knight here Knight takes D2 Rook
takes D2 so I'm hitting B6 I'm hitting
the Knight my knight is hitting your
Rook sorry okay Rook C1 Rook C1 and the
immortal words of Nikolai manev gift me
the pawn now I would like to now the
king gets bit exposed though you can
take on F1 and take on A4 by the way
Knight C4 on the board the the players
can black now go Knight
C4 In This Moment In This Moment The
Rook is hanging the queen is hanging
everything is hanging it's a fork excuse
me and if you cannot capture on B6 then
I'm then I have to defend on the first R
rook and queen D6 I'm going to be
looking at mhm okay I capture on D1 yes
and Rook takes D1 and queen D6 not easy
anymore okay but
now can breathe the side of Rel I'm kind
of feeling like I really really like
White's position once again why because
uh your majority if you will is
constrained it's not uh a passer right I
do have a passer my knight is actually
hitting uh this guy and maybe I can play
moves like Rook
B1 okay yeah you know I'm not happy
about trading the Rooks but white is
getting the position that maybe you want
with that active Knight on E6 sure so we
do we're up to date by way guys just to
interrupt you for a second let's move on
to the uh T versus ARA game because
that's about to be over you know it's so
strange I thought that that position was
so bad it's checkm in one move for uh
Arena Queen to F6 I didn't even believe
it I mean we see all the white pieces
around black king and queen H7 K six or
queen of six that's
one wow wow wow what a finish for T
right like three out of three can't beat
that no absolutely she Leap Frogs Arena
takes her spot her fourth spot position
and allows Alice Lee to be uncontested
on uh on the podium and that was a draw
we see another Rook end game so we know
it's Sam shanklin's game uh versus
Jeffrey jeang both of these players just
wed this tournament to be over they they
haven't had the success uccessful event
minus two both of them Sam Jeffrey they
cannot be happy with this result they
wanted this tournament to be over
exactly uh Carissa yep uh jumping back
into that game we just we finally saw
after King B2 Queen takes E4 Queen C2
and we're expecting well the trappy move
I want to say queen A8 it's an important
moment because if you take on C2 she's
done this is bad for you right now now
this is a bad end game for and for black
Karissa is so happy right now oh it's a
dream she must be really at the moment
no question about it backwards Pawn on
D6 you're the one with pa pa on B3
you're the one with the passer so you
you you post up The Rook it's not that
you're you no the whole idea is that
this Rook is going to come to
B1 this king is going to go to C3 and
then you put your your your your
majority to work you've got your Queens
side majority this kingside majority is
not doing anything and again this
backward Pond Queen takes C2 uh
fundamental error there that Tri that
Queen trade oh it's so happy for for
Carissa and
now um beum is going to be in a
situation she has to win she absolutely
has to win because it's it probably
Karissa is now a favorite uh in this
we're talking about beame kind of
winning her game Karissa having troubles
now is the other way around karisa is
pretty safe and beim is the one who is
starting to get trouble in her position
that's right Rook D3 that's right that
position is no longer easy at all Rook
to D3 okay for me this move Rook D3 is
an indication that uh um we want want to
play Rook to A1 I always like The Rook
behind the pass Bond but it for for for
me this is like Carissa wants to play
Rook A1 and bring her Rook uh to the
seventh ring I think she's trying to
tempt black to play E4 you know kind of
get that pawn a little bit closer but
I'm going to be happy for that because
the pawn is going to be weak you see
Rook A8 Rook A8 played by yuang and
again you I think Carissa is going to be
forced to put her Rook on the right
Square Rook to B1 so she can meet Rook
A2 check with Rook B2 Rook B1 and again
from White's
perspective get the pawn to B4 as soon
as
possible uh so you can
advance and again two minutes for how
many moves for six more moves
okay but this one has really calmed down
a great deal the Jennifer uh beam um
versus Jennifer game that's
still uh a three result game right we so
Knight C4 on the board we we were
expecting maybe Rook to D1 she played
Bishop to E1 Knight B6 takes takes
Knight C6 Knight takes E4 Bishop takes
A5 uh really uh wholesale change of
position and now who's better now and
why
yeah I mean that question doesn't have
an easy answer anymore uh
crickets what do you think are we going
to see Knight E5 I don't
know I still feel white
should better but if you trade that
Knight then I have a pawn that can be
potentially running exactly this Knight
on C6 is I I didn't know Knight E5 or
knight7 I didn't know if the Knight if
if this Pawn was a weakness or a
strength
on uh E5 but if I can get rid of this
Knight let's just say Knight takes Queen
takes I do
have a pawn supported by The Rook
supported by the Knight on a very very
uh lucky day I get to go Queen A7 and uh
Jennifer made your move Knight
e77 on a very lucky day if I can sneak
in a move like Queen A7 Che check that's
just so unfair right and also it was her
40th move 40th move so they just reached
the time control okay uh I'm going to
jump back to the chissa game just
because time control has been met K be
she was not forced to play Rook B1 I
can't can't guess move I can't guess
Carissa's moves at all I would have
posted up with The Rook on D5 I would
have been eagerly bringing this Rook
Into The Fray so that I can support B4
King B2 F F6 pardon me G6 I love this
move by R improve your King right and
the games are about activating your king
to the center so we need to get the king
out ex exactly I hardly approve now
again um Carissa Rook
F1 is it and you know if you capture on
G6 just let's say car Capt we may
capture with the king so the F Pawn is
running oh no that would be
uh that would be something I really
would want to avoid as white I mean I'd
even be I'd go so far as to stop you
from playing F5 with the move G4 even
though I'm reducing the material uh
count by
the by the way Carissa is now Rook D1 a
minute all this straight that's very
interesting G6 and a chain I was about
to say once again inviting a a
change of the pawn structure takes Rook
takes D6 not interested but now F takes
G6 isn't that breaking
through say what F takes G6 after Rook
A6 F takes G6 I'm assuming King takes
well the problem with King takes I think
I can give you a
check ahuh then driving me back keep
giving you checks because that's another
one then R F3 Rook F3 or Rook H3 gotcha
and then if the Rook had been
on I a I think Kissa is taking over
right now she she would have been able
to defend with Rook f8 intriguing so she
did play just as you've prescribed it
Christian but okay if I go just back
King
87 okay but but I put this grip on with
a rook on F6 that's the problem exactly
now
uh with the Rook on F6 posting up this
looks really very unpleasant grip I mean
I will go Rook to3 I mean Rook B6 pardon
me which one Rook that one that one
probably this guy okay cuz now if you go
Rook H3 I go King G7 so what if I go
Rook
D3 with the threat of Rook takes B6 then
I have to go E4 right
yes and now haven't you created more
more weaknesses but King G7 Rook F4 and
that's the one I'm tar some point you
will lose a pawn that's the problem
exactly you cannot get to my pawns and I
can that's the difference in this
position basically uh there's Rook
D7 there's C5 C5 and I take on C5 that's
a coupon so that's a funny with funny
pattern with all the Rooks on Rooks on
Prix King H King H7 on the board now a
key moment for Karissa with the under a
minute she's played the move Rook
F1 as
expected well there's no way I'm
allowing Rook takes F7 check to reach
the time control exactly there's no way
I'm allowing Rook takes F7 check so
whether it be Rook A7 or Rook B7 I have
to defend the pawn and then Rook
F6 yeah this is very good news for
Karissa
true that um the only
thing you know I hate playing The Rook
endings passively mhm can I try Rook A7
so I go King
C3 that
is very clever just simply Sid stepping
any and I'm ready to play either Rook D3
or Rook H3 and get one of those pawns
you got it I couldn't agree with you
more uh oh dear uh as we have have we
reached the time control finally after
Rook F1 not yet one more move one more
move one more but we think any move Rook
B7 Rook A7 Rook B6 Rook F6 Carissa will
have made the time control and oh that's
she is feeling good right now well the
queen trade was just Elation yes
absolutely Queen takes it2 and you could
see the sight of relief and instantly
Rook F6 making the time control and now
really
playing at last like a boss I mean
she's it's still not over by any means
and specifically because of that idea of
truly defending that pawn on D6 with
everything you got because if you lose a
pawn everything drops after that exactly
but how do you defend the pawn once
again that's it Rook B6 Rook D3 and Rook
D7 Rook B6 Rook D3 it's not pretty but
then I go Rook H3
King G7 and Rook F takes
H6 you don't have F5 so I don't actually
defend just a moment just a moment okay
now you move the Rook maybe I give check
on H7 okay so I'm still
tickling okay Rook
h8 now
here do I at last have any coun you hope
you hope
it's a hope maybe you maybe you do maybe
you don't a little glimmer of hope no it
it must be winning of course for white
G8 I think this is G3 check also as a
but uh we have uh in studio one player
who's saying we ended the tournament too
soon I know Christian hatrick for you t
of in the last three rounds you missed
the podium we were discussing about this
by an inch but still an amazing finish
for you assess your tournament assess
your performance and I know you want to
analyze this game because it was so
nice uh yeah I don't know how to assess
my tournament I have to think about it
um the middle of the tournament was very
bad for me I think I became uh
demoralized maybe a little too early um
okay I lost to two people who are
winning the tournament so result wise
it's not too bad but uh I also left a
lot of points on the table um um some
one move blunders like my game against
beame I just blundered a lowed her to
Checkmate me and my game against Talia
which was just such a disgusting blunder
and such a breaking point for me in the
tournament um but also I play I think I
played some good games I think of course
this last part was good for me my game
against Alice was definitely a highlight
for me uh so it was definitely up and
down tournament but rating wise has been
good so at least that's I'm very happy
about absolutely and a three-oh finish
especially this last game against
Grandmaster an eight time National
Champion Arena crush this was an
attacking Masterpiece tell us where were
you sure that things are going your way
in this position because it wasn't clear
right she had her chances on the queen
side as well but you were pushing and
you were creating a lot of threats and a
lot of chances on the king side and in
the center how did you assess this
position where did you feel you're
taking
over well I wasn't expecting she'll
played the time on I was pretty sure
she'll played the con she played it last
two times we played um each other and
she played it with good results so I was
I was happy to see this because I
thought it'll be more combative uh so
when she went F6 like I had a feeling
you don't play F6 in this position
because you know things aren going well
for you so F6 is a sign of desperation
I'm not sure if Bishop H3 is the right
way to go I think it is because I think
there's this pressure on this D7 Pawn
okay I guess it's not I did spend a lot
of time on this move this is something I
feel in this trend every time every time
I spend a lot of time at the critical
moment I make the wrong decision so what
am I supposed to do if not Bishop H3
Rook to G1 same type of idea just create
more tension on the G file and on this
side but rather with Rook G1 than Bishop
H3 at the same time things remain very
complex even at this point Bishop C5
Queen to D3 and now Bishop to B4 I think
this was the mistake Bishop takes C3 she
was supposed to play it's all about
exchanging the Queens right so but I'm
not going to allow her to exchange the
Queens but then I move I go Queen D3 or
something again can I take on G3 maybe
even if I take on G5 you lose that
so yeah but this is good for
black I guess we both didn't really
assess the position correctly and it's
not easy it truly is not easy it's a
very imbalanced type of position but yes
after Bishop to B4 Bishop to F4 you
conducted the attack uh very precisely
with that move Queen to G3 uh Rook HD1
to put pressure on D7 Rook G Queen G3
and then the checkmating uh final attack
final sequence congratulations TV quite
an amazing game this was guys any
questions thank I think just incredible
performance T congratulation on the
really nice finish absolutely thank you
yeah for me uh this game when when um
Arena was denied the opportunity of
playing Bishop C6 like that what what we
just saw there was this uh crucial
Bishop let me see just a second Bishop
H3 Bishop C5 oh uh we have a result in
the game between Andrew and Sam when we
left it Sam S won the game that's a good
finish for Sam
absolutely yeah for for me it was this
moment where we trade we go Queen C5 as
Arena and the whole the whole point is
that we must defend D7 with the bishop
and the moment that she got wrong footed
with the queen right o excuse me when
she got wrong-footed with her Queen
right here she put her Queen on C6 this
move Queen G uh Queen G3 just ended the
game that was just like out I was
surprised to see that Bishop C6 black is
better I thought that white would still
be better in that position
but at least black survived absolutely
but uh yeah Queen C6 terrible uh how are
the ladies doing uh beum and uh Carissa
well we've reached the time control and
now they're thinking Jennifer is taking
her time after this move Rook to E1 uh
trying to deal with this pin on the E5
probably F5 C4 I you want to go C4 the
question is I wanted to go Queen A7
check truth truth be told the problem
with C4 do I have some ideas with D6
right now maybe not D6 you actually take
with a knight I think Queen A7 my idea
was that if you uh take like this I go
Queen to B7 but yes you also have Queen
to A7 that was my trick yes Queen A7
Queen B6 and you're a pawn up for sure
um C4 maybe just Queen to B6 I have to
go F5 now you have to go A5 yeah but I
was trying to get my Pawn as far up the
board as I possibly could before that's
what I'm going to try to do as well face
the music here here yes yeah it's it's
balanced the position is balanced by the
way she play the five after I'm thinking
she play the five I was a little bit
worried that Queen C4 and I would never
get to move the pawn maybe now Queen to
A7 or maybe we're just like blocking
each other it's a mutual doesn't get
that many squares either where you go
yeah yeah it's a mutual blockade of
sorts uh this is no longer an advantage
for begum no three res game absolutely
three res game and to be honest with
this monster Knight on e4 I have to say
and the weaken King I think it's easier
to play for black yeah and Carissa she's
enjoying uh the position obviously an
advantage we don't know whether it's
enough for a decisive advantage or not
because I do have my threats as well and
I do like what ruang is doing she's
keeping active she's not waiting she's
trying to invade via the a file so what
if I play queen king C3 yes King C C3
maybe I
go cuz isn't that winning the pawn after
Rook H3 maybe Rook
A3 now I go King
B2 King B2
maybe Rook A4 or Rook A6 back let's go
Rook
A4 oh now you take on
F7 yeah yeah no this is looking good and
if you go Rook A6 you even have ideas of
C5 Oh I thought Rook H3 but C5 looks
good Rook h three it just seems like at
some point you're going to be able to
coordinate your pieces and you're going
to pick up one of the pawns H6 D6 you
have to many weaknesses as black so
Carissa looking good begim not so much
anymore so right now the way it's
looking Kissa might in fact clinch the
title wonderful and looking at the game
of uh darush and Ray Robin Ray Robson
some tactics were happening in that um
time scramble at the end uh just to pick
up the action right here after the move
Rook takes A5 uh Ray you know couple
pieces
hanging Rook
H6 give me the threat of mate F4 let me
Checkmate you again uh Queen takes H2 on
the agenda H3 Ray drops back with the
Rook you want to trade Queens no
uh
and by the
way his game what a fantastic finish
what a fantastic performance he's tying
for second place what a positional
Masterpiece in this game wow he's only
14 years of age he tied for second place
at the US Championship very very very
impressive he was so happy to qualify by
winning the US junior Championship he
barely qualified because that tournament
was not easy wow yeah and remember he
took some serious risks in the last
exactly exactly and take a look at this
what a masterpiece this last game
strategical Masterpiece it was yeah this
this is difficult to believe that at
such a young age you can have this type
of understanding you can have this chess
culture to defeat Leon aronian I mean
this is unbelievable yeah and this in
particular uh this decision by Mishra
very very impressive decision
kn3 and I remember when deep Juni deep
blue pardon me against Gary Kasparov did
not win a pawn Mishra could win a pawn
with Knight takes B7 and go for the A6
pawn and the computer refused to win the
pawn against Gary and Gary was like
Furious because he said you know outside
interference the the the the computer
always values material over Dynamics and
uh in this particular case it was a an
absolutely I mean Abu just every single
piece yeah and when we left it we left
it here and we thought his pieces were
just
overwhelming um
leavon and uh Lon agreed R B8 coming
Rook B7 if you capture by the way as
black the pawn on A5 right now I win Ace
take the Knight on E7 yes exactly
Rook takes King takes and there goes yes
let's update our standings
uh ladies uh with our two uh uh our two
um contenders for first place still at
at worked so still we have kis Sal Yip
leading the tournament with eight and a
half out of 10 but she looks like she is
going to win the game which would mean
that she clenches the championship title
then we have beging to Jano with eight
and Alice Lee really important win in
her tournament because she is clear
third now absolutely and our
congratulations especially for tata for
fantastic finish three out of three and
in the open in the open section we
already know that Fabiano Carana won the
tournament he made a draw today with
wesle so so Fabiano is first with eight
and wesle so is tied for second with
abanu Mishra who just incredibly uh
played today's game against Leon AR
Ronan very very very impressive I mean I
I really don't I don't see leavon
getting outplayed like uh he did today
even by the top guys that that was that
was very very instructive lanir and Hans
nean that big fight for second place
it's not going anywhere this looks uh
I'm not so sure not so sure I'm not so
sure you think G5 I mean at some point I
will go G5 right then don't I have
enough weaknesses in your position to
play against oh so after I capture on H4
the Knight can go to D4 but also
potentially to F4 F4 yes to attack the
pawn on D3 and the idea of Knight to G6
or Knight G2 if you get too close to the
pawn so let's imagine we go G5 and uh
what do you do now that's that's you
don't actually have a lot of King E3
let's go okay King E3 he he's taking
taking and he's going Knight F4 and
Knight E1 so he's threatening Knight E1
Knight G6 go Knight G2 okay okay so
first I I I have to make a little uh
okay King D2 back King to D2 back so
let's let's fight for the D4 Square now
all right I have to go back with the
Knight Knight C2 and we're back I go
King
E3 no have I Wrong footed you somehow
Maybe not maybe I can't get my my um a
knight E1 feel like my king in keeping
that defense exactly Knight G2 or Knight
C2 yeah don't uh don't prematurely
capture on F5 and invite my king into
the position King D2 yeah I
don't and Knight
G2 I don't see black improving this
position okay let's go there was a
moment of Happiness though there was a
moment of Happiness going let's go back
I I don't want to take on H4 yet okay
okay but G5 what you and I think we just
waited all right so now I'm going to go
King
G6 and I believe we waited some more
again King D2 well it's not that easy to
wait why okay King D2 now
F5 okay now in this case you will be
threatening F4 and that uh
precipitates a
reaction and that's an
interesting if I take we can see how we
can get uh we can get our start to get
some play there on the king side but uh
we have a guest in studio Christian over
to you Sam a great finish for you with
the white pieces against Andrew Tang you
wanted really badly to win this game and
in fact you did so in extraordinary
fashion but it all started in the
opening after D3 He started thinking for
30 minutes and he decided to play that
move D5 let's take a look at that and
tell us your reaction after the move
D5 yeah um he generally doesn't Play The
Marshall but I did see that he tries it
sometimes in critical games so uh I
didn't really expect this line I decided
to play D3 to avoid all the theoretical
lines and you know he went for the pawn
sack anyway with D5 uh initially I
thought okay this is ridiculous I'm just
going to take the pawn but he he had an
idea he wanted to get rid of my Bishop
uh I me if you play uh H3 instead of D3
uh uh Bishop B7 D3 D5 e takes D5 Knight
takes D5 Knight takes E5 Knight D4 this
is like one of the critical positions
and I think he wanted this after H3 so
that was his kind of concept after D3 as
well that makes I mean the main problem
for him is the bishop is kind of stuck
on C and have a lot of tactical
resources as you saw yes yes you did and
this was actually a very nice one after
Knight takes B3 B4 critical moment at
this point yeah I spent a lot of time
here because uh both Knight takes A1 and
Knight D4 are very important if Knight
D4 I have a beautiful move Knight takes
B5 mhh uh once again this tactic Works
he probably has to take on B4 when I'm
I'm a pretty much a healthy Pawn yes and
he took on A1 we initially looked at
this position and we were like okay this
is over right you just pick up the
Knight on A1 at the right moment and
then this is over but it wasn't that
easy to get to that Knight because of
this A5 idea
yet you found
this that's yeah exactly that's why I
spent so much time on this AES before
because I I initially I thought okay he
can't take down A1 then I started
realizing this Pawn on B4 he can just go
A5 and protect his Knight yeah uh so
here I spent some time and I'm I really
like this move Rook E4 because if I can
get my Rook to
C5 uh I have a really good really good
structure um so if I start with Rook E5
very important he plays Rook
E8 and I can't play Rook C5 because of
Knight takes C2 back rank problems mhm
yes so uh the reason I started with Rook
e four was uh one of one of the reasons
is if he plays A5 which is the natural
movement position B takes A5 Rook takes
A5 I have B4 and the bishop goes to B2
and his Knights he has to protect his
Knight with two Rooks and I'm attacking
his king um so I think he had to play
Rook A8 instead of
A5 sorry Rook E8 E8 okay Rook E8 yeah
yeah and now Bishop
E3 he amazingly can still go A5 it's
really
annoying and now if you take he takes
with a queen yeah exactly yeah I was
going to play Rook D4 and keep and H4
and just play this position I still
think White's better but it's very
complicated uh yeah with the knight1 so
when he chose Queen C6 I was very happy
because I managed to get this clamp with
the Rook on
C5 very nice uh and now my Rook protects
C2 which is like one of the good things
about this
position yeah he can never get his out
anymore yeah Rook a was an interesting
practical try because he wants to take
on B2 and if I play Bishop C3 he has a
nice trick with Knight B3
oo very nice yes you can still survive
Bishop takes G7 but obv can still
survive yes and also if inste after
Knight B3 Rook G5 I thought this wins on
the spot initially he has Knight D4 uh
which was kind of
could be a cold shower the Knight came
from A1 to D4 yeah so I went for Bishop
C1 exactly yeah so I went for Bishop C1
B4 Queen H5 and yeah he did this I I had
no time but I managed to calculate until
Knight
E5 uh I think this wins because after
Queen E4 I have Rook takes C7 oh very
nice okay Rook takes C7 Rook f8 Queen G5
and his pie are just out of the game I'm
just mating him
yes there's no way to defend same after
same thing after Queen B3 uh Rook takes
C7 just one detail that's important uh
he doesn't have Rook A7 which is kind of
saving the game because I takeen there's
M on
E8 yeah yeah beautiful so he has to give
he has to give the KN and then White's
just easily winning yeah very nicely
calculated uh definitely a satisfying
way to finish a tournament in such a
complex battle with a good victory
congratulations uh Sam we'll see you in
the next tournament absolutely thank you
Karissa repeating uh the position that's
huge because we kind of thought that
Carissa was enjoying a nice Advantage we
expected her to press for quite some
time but ruang found a way to kind of
complicate
things well Karissa blundered
actually uh I think it was more like
Carissa was kind of helping her find uh
as there's nothing she's
she doesn't want to lose the B3 Pawn she
doesn't want to play passively with her
King King C3 more or less forced right
but then Rook A3 and then that's what
we've been repeating and the problem is
karisa can never go King B2 afterwards
because then Rook takes B3 and that now
suddenly we're in a king and pawn ending
that well that makes no sense for uh
White right I guess perhaps you can try
to go King B1 but that's a dangerous
move to make
uh at what moment right here right here
right now yeah King B1 just try to keep
the game
going Rook takes
G2 I would be maybe we can see the
analysis um I'd be scared to play this
as white that King just one second yes
sir because we're not uh we're not
seeing
yeah okay so Rook takes G no I
you don't play King B1 here though do
you well I guess that's a big question
for Kissa right now she's looking at the
other game at beg's Game how does she
assess that one is the question and if
she's not looking at that game then only
plays her game then that's a big
decision still because King to B1 keeps
the game going but it's such a passive
move such a passive decision you will be
a pawn up but after Rook takes D6 F5
it's it's a pretty res game yeah these
are two I mean there is Rook G3 check I
was about to say no there is no Rook G3
CH King on B1 is terribly excuse me so
yes you can't play Rook B3 Rook G3
pardon me because of Rook you need to
defend B3 so how do you activate your
Rooks yeah no I'm I have no interest
you're starting to get scared yeah of
course with the King on B1 as well but
the King on C3 it's a different story
but no um no here uh no Carissa uh
mistakenly went for the pawn too soon
she played this Rook H3 and just
allowed uh ruy yangyang this opportunity
of uh we were looking at King B2 right
after I think her King was on B2 so we
have this position M Rook F6 Rook
C6
and
uh hold on
yes6 how how did we get this uh that
that was the position yeah Rook Rook C6
to attack the pawn on
C4
C6 how do you defend if you go to C2 I
go to A6 if you go to C3 I first go to
B6 to attack the pawn on B which is what
happened you actually cannot get out of
this whole conand little
uh how come we did not Analyze This this
move order I don't know because this
current position does look like we're
headed for a draw uh which means that it
for bam it's winner bust right I mean we
know she's got sack and regardless of of
whether wins loses or draws but she has
to win but you know karisa she has 16
minutes so King C3 um ruang afterwards
can stop the clock right Rook A3 and
claim the draw so Karissa is going to
take your time not yet yet not yet I
think King C3 would be only one time
repetition the two times excuse me and
then you would have to go through the
same motion think we have King
C3 okay but after Rook A3 you have only
moved King C2 right right and then Rook
a to a third time yes so she's going to
take time here to calculate whether
she's going to risk it no she's about to
make move King B1 she's going B1 B1 wow
she's continuing this whole situation
but wow
Rook takes
G2 Rook takes D6 Rook takes D6 Carissa
still a pawn up but after starting to
become a a double edge sword right now
with such a weak King on B1 no that's
it's a race almost all right so let's go
C5 let's push mention right you
mentioned race let's push him F4 so that
takes yeah let's keep let's go okay
pause what wow Rook F2 oh that looks way
too slow F2 I have to agree with that
okay I we we were just about to mention
the
race what exactly is and black
stopped what if no but C5
now well I got to ask the obvious
question what about C5 right I also
don't like The Rook on F2 because it's
stopping the pawn on F2 go and just run
for the queen it's a very strange
decision and the problem is you cannot
go Rook F6 to exchange that because of
Rook G3 that would be uh marvelous for
uh no this
uh makes no sense in
fact well okay
C5 let's try to imagine what uh ruang
yen is my guessing is that she wants to
go and double up the Rooks on the second
Rook A7 I don't see anything else makes
oh so she was avoiding Rook G3 trading
the Rooks that makes sense so after C5
Rook A7 okay I will go with
[Music]
that okay so if I go B4 I go Rook a A2
go Rook
B3 I go Rook
E2 this one yes and I go Rook D1 so your
pawns are running I have no Perpetual
check no Checkmate
threats wow as we keep a close eye on
this one nishra is in studio after a
fantastic win uh Christian and what a
victory after a difficult loss against
Fabiano Carana in the previous round you
mentioned Legends and Idols that you
have in this game growing up but today
you defeated an actual Legend of Chess
leevon Aron and a living legend such an
incredible player tell us your story how
are you feeling right now this is
definitely the most accomplished uh
let's say player that you've defeated in
your
career yeah it feels amazing to beat
leavon he's he's simply a legend as you
put it I've been following his games
ever since I've grown up other than that
actually I'd like to mention one other
thing there's there's basically two ways
you can go from 2500 to 2700 one is you
play a lot of open tournaments and
another one is that you go you play
these you play these very difficult
events like us championship and so on
I'm the the decision I've been making
for the past like not just now for the
last like 5 years is that I'm playing
the tougher events so that for example
my breaking of 2600 was quite delayed I
should have broken it by like I should
have broken it like 2 three months ago
like this was a bit a bit too much uh
but okay this might sound a bit
overconfident but that's how it is other
than that like this decision I've made
for example when I was trying to become
the youngest International master in the
world I played in all Grandmaster Norm
events and eventually that's what helped
me become grandmas quicker because
otherwise if you get like I got all my
three Norms from Grandmaster events
because if you play if I got them all
from I am Norm events then playing
grandm normal events would be a
different ball game altogether but here
I already had experience on what to do
and what not to do and why are you
saying the same thing is this is the
difficult path compared to playing in
open
tournaments
yeah that's also a quite interesting
like open tourament they're not
necessarily easier that's it's actually
it's a completely different skill set uh
because the thing with open tournaments
is that actually nowadays 21 2200s are
not 21 2200s they play much better than
that because every win you get like two
points and every draw you lose like four
it's a bit
ridiculous absolutely tell us about
today's game we have to talk about it
because it felt like a strategical
masterpiece yeah it felt uh this king's
Indian I I had the feeling that he was
going to play something like this
because okay he won yesterday and now
maybe he's coming he's trying to get
back into the tournament also I'm half a
point above him in the standing so maybe
if he wins this game he could kind of he
could kind of like Leap Frog me in the
standings and try to get second or okay
second or third or just a better ranking
mhm mhm sure let's discuss it night to
so I chose to play I I chose to play D4
in this game this in this tournament
I've mainly played E4 so I thought okay
this might be bit of surprise and of
course thear play Kings Indian is like
it's very very known as such that okay
he loves to play Kings Indian right and
we got to uh this position how did you
assess it how are you seeing your
chances right now were you encouraging a
fight in this game or you happy to see a
fight in this
one yeah definitely I wanted to have a
fight because to be honest in this
tournament he hasn't been playing his
best like the leavon that we all know is
usually having much having much better
score than let's say what was it four or
five out of 10 he's usually on like he
like plus two plus three by this point
like I had a feeling that okay maybe he
can I can try to catch him off off form
absolutely and yeah this was kind of I
think this decision with F4 was quite
good in the opening itself because the
issue is he wants to go E5 E4 and with
the pawn on F4 I kind of take away D5
square and although my Bishop on G2 is
uh
it's quite is a quite bad piece I can
always play Bishop f one and I thought
like okay if the game is kind of closed
I can always I can always played like
Knight D4 Bishop E2 Etc and I should be
better the thing was actually he was
playing quite quickly around here I was
a bit confused because actually once he
played the C5 move I kind of realized
that if black ever gets a Pawn on C5 if
like if I didn't get C5 in the game if
black put the pawn on C5 I have the
issue is like okay why do kind of has no
space and and it becomes quite difficult
to make make moves with white so I
decided that okay I should go C5 and
it's kind of like a double- edged sword
because from one point of view I kind of
ruined his Pawn structure but from the
other point of view I give him to D5
Square where he can activate his knights
from yep and that's exactly what he did
but you got this I like Knight B6 move
was
nice yeah this Knight B6 was quite quite
important because otherwise this Knight
these two knights are quite annoying
attacking E3 now after Knight B6 uh I
kind of force him to trade and now I
think H3 Knight F6 is kind of a big
mistake mhm mhm like after H3 he should
probably go C5 and maybe the position is
around I think white should still be a
bit better but it's not too clear like
let's say h takes G4 C takes D4 Rook
digs
D4 maybe bishop E6 or D5 and I can go G5
and it's maybe his King is still a bit
weak like maybe I go Queen D2 Rook D1
Bishop F1 Rook A4 Etc but it it wasn't
looking too clear like what happened to
the game is I had a knight on D4 like I
okay I put the Knight on A5 but uh this
end game has to be much better for way
like probably close to winning already
yep you because he just simply doesn't
have any play you assessed it correctly
and after that you conducted uh your
offense on the queen side very nicely
with A4 A5 blocking that weakness very
beautiful game to cap off an amazing
performance ABI Mani congratulations
guys any questions no our congratul
ulations too uh Mishra just just great
stuff it was your debut
um I I I just have to say you you must
be feeling great that you just didn't
you know face plant you know it's a big
big challenge playing in these national
championships they're so strong and you
performed well second place I mean come
on I actually do have a question on man
congratulation on this tournament on you
know amazing score also amazing games
and my question is is this your best
tournament performance so far or how
much do you cherish this uh this results
in this
tournament I feel that this result is
quite good as I'm going to play in Grand
Swiss also in another like five six days
and that this will help me gain even
more it'll help me gain even more M
momentum in that in that tournament
because I think as of now I gained like
20 25 points in this tournament it's
like a crazy number I'm like 2616 live
rating and another main thing is that
I'm trying to hit 27 I want to be I'm
the youngest 2700 player in the world
and I have another 13 months and my
rating is currently like 2616 and I have
a feeling I have a very good chance to
break it wow wow congratulations that's
amazing I love your goals uh Misha may
you succeed thank you absolutely and the
Isis of man tournament promises to be a
great great event everybody's going to
aisle of man I
mean how could I miss it absolutely uh
what do we have in the ladies uh in with
the Jennifer first of all this has
changed a lot no what wait what happened
is it winning I'm not sure oh I oh we
why I know right right you're a bit
taken back it going to run well my E3
Pawn is running as well why did we run
with the B Pawn you want to run with the
B Pawn right now no I want to if we move
back okay I don't want to play B4 at all
I just want to go C6 okay C6 I was
worried about the pet A2 I was worried
about the yeah that's what she was
worried about as well wait and if I go
Rook C3 am I going to lose this somehow
might I will take and then take and then
you still have to go
backp yeah repetition repetition yes
talk talk and I the that's a Checkmate
if you go here unfortunately you in fact
lose because I pick up the Rook on C1
exactly so you have to say King C1 King
B1 by the way and that's exactly what
she's trying to do Ru yang right now
with E3 offering this Pawn hey take it
so that I can give you a check push you
to C1 with a king and then take on H2
and create the separation between the
Rooks uh threatening both Rook H1 and
Rook A1 mate this is what I'm talking
about and if we do get to this position
I don't see a way for Kissa to get
out I you can give a check I go back to
f8 you can give another check I go back
you can give yet another check but what
else mhm how do you improve your
situation in fact she did miss an
opportunity at this point what she had
to do is give a check
first the idea being that if you do go
to f8 now I go Rook to
B3 you go E3 you're queening with check
I I'm I'm guessing that's the reason but
let's take a look so C6 you go E3 C7 and
you do queen with check yes yes yes with
the King on F F E2 doesn't come in the
position and this position is winning so
big big moment guys and right now after
Rook G3 check give a check first push
the king to f8 and then go to B3 and do
the same thing okay so what if I go with
the King to H7 that's a good question
very good no Che on the back rank yes
King to H7 now I go to B3 once again you
go E4 and now I have this crazy idea
Rook to F6 create a pair of Rooks wow
yes yes yes by the way did we see a move
or did we see just Kissa getting oh she
went and checked beg him's game on her
clock she went checked be's game she
doesn't really know how to assess it
because that one is complex and right
now she's trying to find a way to win I
don't see it I don't see it guys I think
after E4 things are becoming a little
bit easier because I have a clear plan
as black I go E3 I force his take on E3
and then I give you this check Rook
takes H2 I but this Rook F6 move I mean
is it possible to find it no no no
that's not the point the point is that
you're always looking in these Rook
endings to make your opponent's king
weaker yes you're always looking at
these checks if I can force you onto the
eighth rank with a like for example
you're looking at Rook G3 check because
you would love to Queen with check right
so you would love to force the king to
the eighth rank forcing the king away
from the protection of the f it's not
that you're looking at Rook F6 you just
ask yourself a question is my opponent's
king worse on H7 so you think you would
give the check and maybe find The Rook
six now yeah like like later you but but
first you try to put because once you
see the King on H7 you start to think to
yourself boy wouldn't wouldn't it be
great if I could a check made so yeah
Rook G3 check would definitely have been
on my radar maybe only a you know like I
would have to convince myself The Rook
check isn't uh good but I'm actually
kind of stupified uh frankly that this E
Pawn cuz I kind of thought we were just
going to go here here and here and then
you know you you're not checkmating me
you're not making a perpetual and I
didn't think yeah there you go Rook to
D1 and I didn't understand why cariss
was E3 yes and then Rook C1 Rook to C1
E3 Rook to C1 then I push the Rook on
the D
file okay so I'm ready to go E2 C6
E2 now I'll go C7 all right let's
see she by the way did after E3 play
Rook oh I play Rook a C2 now Rook on a
oh C2 now you cannot capture it because
I promote with a check
nice nice by the way guys after Rook to
E1 this is let me just refresh my my my
my board for just a moment Rook a has a
lot of time but it looks like so she did
by the way after E4 she brought a rook
back after E3 she's played Rook E1 she
says do your worst and there's only one
move to draw A2 she has to find this
move it's not E2 that just hangs The
Rook
right and I am threatening at this exact
moment to take that's right so the idea
after Rook a D2 is you cannot capture
with the E Rook because there's back
rank Checkmate that's that's a mate and
if you capture with the other Rook then
I have Perpetual check on B2 so you have
to go C6 right right so you have to
run uh C C6 let it now E2 and I'm
threatening King
C1 now you go Rook D6 perhaps
and she found it what is that no Rook a
D2 play on the board Rook
D3 I was trying to be
clar I see what you're do yes you tried
yesy trying to be no but I think Rook de
she did find the pretty fast she has 30
minutes on the clock but she just found
the best move and played it immediately
confident absolutely and once again
after C6 what what what were what were
we playing after I think E2 E2 and the
King C1 Rook
D6 Rook D6 I have another Rook to go to
F1 and now Rook F1 be careful if you
just play Rook C3 to defend that pawn
the game over Rook F1
exactly
C7 Rook F1 Rook
F1
C8 equals well let me throw in a check
just to okay King F6 King H7 or even
though King F6 maybe Rook F3 wait wait
wait wait wait no this is is not good
yeah let's go King
H6 okay and I think this is winning for
black winning what what what what no no
no no okay I take on E
E1 Rook
B1 oh you're not going to capture The
Rook
huh okay check on
A1
okay well Rook D2 yes King V3 now I now
I'm winning I go up the board don't
forget about my queen when I said okay
so I don't go R2 remember when I said
the The Rook on G3 check and you have
those so I have to just keep checking A1
B1 exactly wow uh what an end game what
a complex end game seriously there's lot
of twists and turns were going on in
this one I'm just going to uh
well once again we just have
Rook D6 is the only her last five
minutes she's getting low on time she
has last five minutes on the clock wow
while Ru anden has 30 minutes but I have
to say the good news for her is that she
has a draw in her pocket any she can
just capture that pawn and B game's
position is not looking great it's not
no because we know beum has to win she
has to win if Karissa draws yeah we just
saw the move
Queen we see we saw C4 and now Queen D7
yes so there's a tickle a double attack
in fact on D5 and
A4 whoa what am I
saying more Salient the a piece is
hanging what just happened did did beum
blender something is a blunder well it
does look like she's losing a pawn now
the question is no but I don't think you
can really capture that pawn on A4
because there's always Bishop takes G7
Queen B7 right right no I'm capturing or
something I'm capturing your Pawn on
D5
oh so let's see if she has enough
compensation that is the question right
now so you go something like Bishop D4
right okay take on D5 I go A5 who's
who's first well I like it you like the
race okay A6 let's
say Rook C1 now I have to
now it's time to defend okay now I kind
of look around the how do I get to your
king right Queen D1 sha how do I get to
your king So something like this I'm
threatening to take the bishop and I'm
I'm I'm dreaming of Queen D1 check
MH by the way I'm just thinking it's a
very difficult position decision for
Karissa like is she going to go for that
draw or is she going to risk continuing
with only less than four minutes on the
clock she's not going for the draw yet
wow she she played C6 let's go okay and
what is the clock times between beam and
Jennifer's game that is a very good
question so beim has 18 minutes while
Jennifer only 8 minutes 10 minutes
difference okay so somehow Jennifer and
beum have much more time no because it's
Ruan y she has 30 minutes on the ground
ah rang has a lot of time a lot of time
and Karissa just played the moves
C6 um and here it is uh
E2 not the move Rook D6 right wait King
C1 yes we looked at okay we looked at
that Rook D6 this was the the now the
threat of Rook F1 right
mhm
the only move to draw is Rook D6 well
not a not a difficult move to find by
the way your Rook is hanging the pawn is
about to Queen so you got to play Rook
D6 in order to capture it uh Rook to D6
yeah the difficult move was Rook a D2
now just go back attack that pawn okay
now this is the okay I was going to go
Rook G3 check remember and I went C7
thereafter sorry
let's go Rook E3 Rook E3 okay gift me
the pawn you take that and now I go King
B2 let's
say King B2 sure okay good I take an
under Pawn on
A2 H2 H2 pardon
yeah yeah that's just a draw and then a
little I'm a little bit faster in terms
of picking up your Rook but I think
you're in time to pick my as well yeah
yeah yeah okay so the way to blunder
here is to play Rook C3 for white right
to defend that pawn because then Rook F1
and oh yes that's no I'm crying that
would be crying for Kissa for sure
exactly she's not going to do that no no
way she's a way too alert to allow those
type of tactics but Rook to D6 this is
the critical moment she needs to find
Rook to D6 she needs to play it she's
played a lot of very fast moves so it
seems that she has calculated everything
and to be honest Rook to D6 being a move
that creates a threat is the first thing
that you're thinking about
exactly wow she is still calculating
though I believe she's calculating Rook
to
G3 you mean Rook to D6 Rook to G3 that's
right and then looking to shelter King
either on F6 to check on bam game name
once again well again as you've
mentioned ruing has 30 minutes to
carefully consider it's very very
crucial decision and she is taking time
to think she's recognizing this is a
critical situation she shouldn't play
Fast here but maybe she's right you know
I it it's it's a funny moment because I
had this
illusion and for you know I I have seen
you know these marvelous marvelous
patterns of Rook check Rook takes Rook
on F1 in my career I mean uh Christian
just pointed out well I can refute you
with the move Rook to
D3 and probably for that matter with
Rook E1 Rook E1 but
sometimes oh you know too
much a minut Karissa is checking the
position from a different perspective
her opponent's perspective I remember I
had one opponent who was very very
annoying who would do that consistently
he would make a move and then come
around the board and look at the
position over my shoulder now I have to
remember the guilty party's name but I
huh um King C1 Rook D6 Rook G3
check this is King H3 King H6 pardon me
and then we were can you get extremely
greedy no that's how you lose um if you
go B5 for
example uh how to be GRE how to be
greedy and lose yeah like King H6 B B5
boy five yes and Rook D6 here we go she
she Force to keep the position balanced
let's go but now I go Rook F1 and now
this is and now Rook D1 now this is the
way I I lose uh brilliantly position
all four funny position right yeah I
can't take cuz that is a a promotion
that's a girl and I'm telling you I
would be super nervous if I was Karissa
like with this Pawn on
E2 yeah and that's why she's been taking
a good look at that game of begim
because again if begim doesn't win she
can make a draw she can make a draw and
claim the championship right there right
and just remind everybody
uh the what if scenarios it's uh this
simple Christian absolutely if Karissa
draws and it does seem like Karissa will
be drawing this game and begim draws
then Karissa wins the championship
because she's half a point ahead going
into this round but if Karissa draws and
beg him wins then we got our playoff
then we have a playoff absolutely and
maybe we can highlight that scenario as
well is the second one as you can see
and Karissa right now trying to figure
things out well we do think that this is
actually uh a draw and uh but she has
three minutes on the clock yes not a lot
of time left and a lot of nerves I can
tell you that much for sure all right
how do you force a draw well if I was
white I would play Rook G3 check likely
you would play King F6 not sure about
King F6 okay just because there's always
this ideas of you know it's guess work
uh like Rook F1 Rook F3 for example is
what I'm worried about okay that's why I
want to go to H6 all right Rook to G3
check King H6 if I was Carissa I would
be playing C7 Rook C6 King D2 yes let's
make a draw Rook C6 King
D2 and uh I certainly uh have an
advantage I'm not worse as uh as we
would say but I was expecting you to
play Rook F1
I would make a
queen just played B5 what is that excuse
me
what Rook F1 is this Rook F1 game
over B5 Rook F1 resigns no way wow she
loses Rook F1 resigns no
way and uh Rook F1 resigns guys yeah of
course
wow Rook G3 check she's missed what we
were just talking about she's missed
this idea four Rooks of the four Rooks
on the first she's wow she thought she
has Rook G1 she's overlooked Rook
D1 oh my God what an end to this
tournament we have right
here it's crazy because what if they
both fall on the finish what if Jennifer
you
wins that's definitely in the cards that
is definitely in the cards as well but
guys this G up and down one winning we
then the other then again oh but can we
see karissa's face right now because she
she realizes I I can tell you that much
she realizes that no I don't think she
realized it yet yeah yeah I think she
realized it how how did what's the tell
what do you think is the tell I think
she's played Rook G3 and she's planning
Rook G1 really and she's sitting there
saying I'm winning I think she's just
not looking at the opponent she's just
poker facing it now she's trying to
Poker Face it
yes looking at the clock but she sees
that ruang has about 30 minutes a lot of
time to just move the king not on the F6
but any other Square she's blushing a
little bit guys I mean I I I can see it
I can see it by the way I was telling
you this point on each too it was making
me
[Music]
nervous
wow incredible what a finish to this
tournament we
have by the way beum is going to be a
pawn down and with that pawn on
C3 lurking and lurking wh's position
around wh's position that's not looking
good from a practical perspective either
why is ruyang hesitating well she has 30
minutes no
no no no no no seriously uh why didn't
you play King
F6 wait King F6 oh you can play The Rook
F3
now that's a move that's a move as well
yes that wins as
well it wins as well it wins as well the
problem you're allowing Rook to F3 and
then Rook takes
E2 Rook F3 and at least I can play with
two pawns and maybe hope for something
against the Rooks right
okay which is not a tremendous hope
because I can go King well C7 is a
threat right now Rook
F5 and then I play C7 should be waiting
C7
I what is going on over
there no you could play Rook F1
check Force the king either to B2 or C2
and then
play WoW Brook but okay King F6 on the
board and uh Carissa she's thinking well
I think she now she realizes realizes
that Rook D1 is game over she's going to
have to play Rook F3 check Jennifer down
to her and she has played it because
she's realizes there goes the Rook very
quickly ruy Yang grabbed the
Rook guys we did not exp this Rook
C3 very quickly played excuse me but
yeah that's good enough because you have
never Rook C2 the king is too close to
the pawns Rook C2 takes King E7 King E7
and then you go King E7 yeah and King d8
in your in time yeah yeah that seems to
be it Rook B3 I'm winning one of the
pawns or trading Rooks got R she's got
the game in the bag
now very sad finish for cariss there it
is Carissa a resignation what a finish
and look at that smile from ru yangang
she knows she she's just got gifted a
win
wow but things might be smiling in
karissa's favor even with this loss
because be him's position is not easy at
all let's take a look at that
wow uh what a turnaround what a
turnaround we we witnessed there
karissa's some decision just mystifying
Queen B2 on the and what's the clock
times in this one I think time trouble
is a factor as well right b game has 14
15 minutes and it's Jennifer you who is
lower on time she has four minutes lower
on time but a better position right now
but you know begim now can check the
result and she sees that if she makes a
draw she forces playoffs Howes Big Boost
of
confidence okay we know we got the
script but how do we how do we uh
fulfill how do you do it it's not easy
guys no it's not that pawn on C2 looks
so threatening always in these uh
who has the more dangerous passer well
it's clear that Jennifer does okay shall
we ask the salian question Queen takes
D5 you're welcome to take a Pawn King G8
okay now once again as mentioned earlier
on my agenda is Queen D1 but now I go
Bishop H6 okay so I defend C1 and I also
threaten Che importantly yes you do
check on C5 check on C5 I no but you
have check check sorry you have Queen
you want no that's not a check never
mind it's not a check it's a mate that's
not that's a m but hold on
how go because Queen D6 and I'm doing a
double attack that is very nice that
that is excellent so I have to go to H1
yeah but now my horsey can go to F2 a
horsey goes to F2 okay and now I have
Queen D6 again and now and keep in mind
after capturing on H6 no I can Capt in
on I want to capture on H6 because I'm
guarding the promotion Square absolutely
gotcha that does it and uh that wins
for Jennifer because there's no there's
[Music]
no perets funnily enough okay cool okay
so it means after Bishop H6 Queen C5 I'm
lost yeah I think white is lost here
okay so so after Bishop takes
eight Bishop takes G7 King G8 you can't
play the desirable Bishop
H6 so go ahead uh Christian if you don't
mind yes uh Queen takes D5 Bishop G7
King h8 yeah this is not looking good so
after Queen D5 I don't have to take on
G7 maybe I have to start with Rook to C1
again such difficult decisions along the
way in this one because I can take the
pawn on A5 maybe we should we we should
look at your board just because we need
to right keep an eye on the players
Queen que yes wow okay just a second she
did not take the pawn on
D5 Queen C7 mm just trying to threat uh
make a threat with C1
promotion okay so I defend now probably
she wants to go Knight
G3 Knight G3
three but
no that's interesting cuz I don't have
time for A6 or any of that my brain
hurts such a complicated position Queen
B5 and now Queen
F4 Queen B5 no but Queen F4 I thought I
have Bishop takes G oh but you're also
targeting that
Rook thought I have Bishop takes G7 and
queen D7 but let's if I take you take
Queen D7 again at this point you might
just want to force a draw somehow as
beging if you are beging and you've just
spotted Karissa losing her game you're
looking for any ways any sort of way out
to force that tie break right right I
mean sure you keep that potential win in
mind but with the pawn on C2 you're also
looking for ways
out for
sure
wow I just have to refresh the board for
a moment there and again uh sorry the
clock times yeah so begim 12 minutes and
Jennifer you only 2 minutes on the
clock with a victory beam's our new
Champion with a draw we have
playoffs but can't Jennifer winning
those are the script writers right
because this is a three game result
absolutely anything can happen in this
and we do have Rook C1 and you were
mentioning Knight G3 was Jennifer's
intention I don't understand the move
Queen C7 otherwise why did she play
Queen C7 and not Queen takes D5 and by
the way after Knight
G3 can we
play D6 is that a move absolutely why
not but then you take Rook takes
C2 and Rook takes C2 and there's no
Queen
B8 ah
wait how what is this position guys cuz
I
still okay take on
G7 I think this
is to be honest I have I still have no
idea what's happening probably Advantage
black right now yeah for
sure but uh Kate can you explain to me
Jennifer's decision not to take on D5
because I'm totally perplexed I don't
really just worried about giving up that
G7 Pawn okay okay KN G3 on the board by
the way Jennifer is down to 1 minute
M my knight to
G3 because my plan is very clear Knight
E2
right now if you're going to go
something like King I don't know F2 then
I have Queen
F4 and that wins on the spot right so no
King F2 for sure 12 minutes for
Bim one minute for
Jennifer with this wild position but
again it's all about that C2 pawn and
that Knight to E2 big threat right now
in the position forking
everybody you have the Royal Fork the
family fork and uh a winning Fork at the
moment so we were looking at the move
Queen
B5 a moment ago
trying to not allow that Knight E2 and
then we saw as a response Queen F4
threatening both pieces with a check so
can I take on
C2
well first of all I I'm I'm really
trying to
understand Bishop B2 no there yeah
like if
I if I'm trying to draw right I would
like to find a way of making a draw can
I play Bishop B2 find that and try to
make a draw just okay no that makes a
lot of
sense just how okay but I go Queen E3
check King
H2 Queen
F2 uh I just if you go here I was going
to go here and what is your threat I'm
playing Knight
E2 with
still no thread though I don't know what
you just did okay trying to set up
something I'll uh I'll fall for it I
think I've got my draw now at least no
now the queen is really active at least
also D6 I'm not sure about right so if
you go Queen
F4 you attack two
pieces I defend both pieces with Retreat
okay I readjust Knight E4 now Oh no
you're GNA okay so I also have wait a
minute you just went Knight E4 to G3
what yeah but I want to have my queen on
F2 so I had to bring the queen a bit
closer okay but I worried you're going
to grab that pawn on
C2 I'll grab the pawn on G7 if you don't
mind I don't
mind okay no yeah
right uh I I'm lost I I I truly lost I
don't get what just is going on here and
I
queen after Knight G3 beum is having to
analyze these really
obscure tactics here um I'm at a loss
Knight G3 I'm expecting Queen Knight E2
is just killing yes and I don't I can't
defend against the threat by moving my
king I can't defend against the threat
by moving my Rook because you make a
Queen so this is only move like box
right
forced um does black have a choice
beside Queen F4 do you have another move
let me know if you have another move I
mean queen F4 looks Queen C4 can you
play I was looking at Queen C4 but then
you have again Queen
D7 no check so Queen C4 is a is an
alternative to Queen
F4 because again a queen trade no but
now King F2 right King
F2 to again s side step Knight E2 if you
take my Bishop I'll take your knight if
you go Knight I'm in time to defend the
bishop and life is good right beam will
be very very very
pleased so Queen B5 this queen C4 this
queen F4 any other is there R B8 no
because Bishop takes G7 maybe Rook takes
C2
also oh I like that one I finally took
that pawn I mean that pond was like you
know on my throat uh no that was a big
that was a big Munch uh just a moment
ago I don't think you could play Rook
B8 wow what a complicated position for
sure I mean after five hours of play
championship title is on the line you're
you're you're nervous because of the
time okay so let's go Queen B5 Queen F4
right
uh sorry say that again which Queen B5
Queen F4 did we Queen B5 solve that
Queen F4 and I said Bishop just
defending the rook and all right stay at
this point and try to improve Black's
position somehow maybe
H5 okay fair just trying to make some
space for my king no more Rook takes C2
ideas for you uh how about Queen takes
G7 ideas
right but I have
Rook to C7 wow no but you had discovered
attack so Bishop takes G7 I'm not sure
this is really playing with fire Bishop
G7 King H7 oh no King H E5 Bishop E5 and
then Knight
E2 but King G8 is also maybe a little
simpler probably yeah getting out of
that discovered attack
right but
boy
I'm not sure I would want to play this
with no time on my clock either check
with what side with either side yeah
yeah no D6 I guess I just take on
D6 my desirable Bishop E5 is not uh
checks on C5 exactly um guys this is
minutes 4
ridiculously complicated position
complicated but again from Bean's
perspective she must be very happy that
Carissa lost her game so she with a draw
she uh she will get into the playoffs
okay let me just chill play you know
calm Zen like chess uh I defend Zen like
chess in this good luck you know like
I'm I'm I'm a careful Defender I what if
I go rookie eight now I want to make a
draw rookie eight I think is winning now
why is that winning well you cannot take
with a rook on C2 and Knight E2 I'm not
100% sure how you stop this uh massive
threat yes
yes I think your
zen zen idea I was trying to be so
careful and over meditation meditation
ended to brutal wake up yeah right truly
brutal wake up oh my goodness wow by the
way 1 minute for Jenifer but 5 minutes
only right now for Begg him and those
those minutes just they go by fast they
F they sure sure do uh again I you know
I I understand how difficult a position
of this is but sometimes Force moves
like a capture that's the only thing you
do that's the only move you can make you
have to make it is there's no choice
here for bean beside Queen
B5 right
but I think she may be cating a bit
further because she's expecting you know
Queen F4 and she doesn't want to give uh
Jennifer too much time after that Queen
A4 move there are some choices along the
way sorry I think we're we're talking
past one another I'm saying when you
have no
choice right but there are some choices
like Queen like that always shocked me
Queen takes d8 check there is no other
move in the position King takes d8
there's there's no other move people
have have spent 10 minutes before
recapturing the the queen and I asked
myself why well because if I play Queen
B5 here I know Jennifer is going to
respond to Queen F4 and I want to play
after she plays Queen F4 I want to Blitz
out my next move but you D6 that's the
other move in the position go oh my gosh
she's she's play but doesn't that just
blunder the game no it's still it
doesn't blunder the game it's still
equality no way yes in the position so
Queen takes D6 Queen takes D6 Bishop E5
probably I will start with Rook takes
C2 Rook takes C2 MH Rook takes C2 yes
and we were we we G7 we've got B8 and
you can't take on C2 because this is a
check so I go Bishop B7 oh my gosh by
the way Jennifer down to 30 seconds mhm
King G8 and now I take on C2 so you got
got this check in your pocket if I
take oh J how many seconds did you say
15 seconds now and she finally did take
on
D6 oh my God and now begum is forced to
take on
C2 no took G oh that's I think that's
losing King to G8 I think that's over
but what's the difference because after
King G8 I D1 Queen D1 Che but I have
Queen B3 check now but it doesn't matter
I take that no I oh the Knight is
defended on G3 yeah Bishop takes G7 was
a losing
move wow Rook takes C2 was a drw can
this be a more dramatic finish no I
think correct I remember the 2013
candidates where both
Magnus and Vladimir kramnick the two
leaders of the tournament lost the final
game at the Finish are we going to see
the same thing two tournament leaders
losing the final round I think so yeah
that's King G8 on the board that's it
and again what Bishop takes G7 she
should have stopped and and thought
about because Queen D1 is such a
dangerous threat right now and there's
no stopping it I mean you're probably
thinking about Bishop H6 but Bishop H6 I
just simply take that first of all you
can simply take that I just take that oh
and I don't have like King H2 move like
a waiting move oh so I'm not really sure
what she missed after this move King to
G8 I think she maybe missed like me the
Knight is defended on G3 like she was
expecting that she would have Queen B3
check and taking the Knight so Bishop
E5 how what's what's the Finish there
okay Bishop E5 that's
true I have que so Queen D1 that was the
idea Queen D1 I go if you go to F2 then
Knight E4 and that has to be a che I
have to go to H2 then I have Knight F1
all right King H1 or King
G1 wow uh so what is the wi guys are cuz
I still don't actually see okay so I go
to D2
mhm all
right as expect Oh I thought C4 but that
just allows you to grab that pawn on
C2 our producer uh Tom uh is boldly
stating the
obvious this is the hardest fight for
seventh place that Jennifer's ever had
in her
life and it's the truth but for first
place hold on isn't there a simpler way
of winning this game than what we've
just discovered we went Queen dwan right
that looks like looks the obvious strong
Knight F1 is another obvious move it
feels like it right I would be very uh
surprised if there was a different
one um cuz I do want to transfer the
knight at least to E3 or E3 or D okay go
ahead E3 go ahead make E3 King goes
to2 and like Queen E2 or where's the
Finish
I can't guess anything I can't guess
anything what is happening in this game
I the play commentators have lost their
minds the players have lost their minds
I don't I'm hesitant to suggest might
winning winning after King H I don't
think so no no no King H2 just Queen
E6 Knight E2 check King H2 yes Queen E6
again what do you do next
Queen
E6 okay I don't like the queen on H2
actually because what's your next move
is the question so can I go king sorry
Yas sir can I go to H1 after absolutely
well King H1 oh no that's Queen D1 I can
play Queen D1 yes this is and capture
with Knight on C1 not allowing you to
give any checks on the white diagonal
but is that completely finished okay but
guys let's go let's go to F2 right ah
but F you take on
C1 no wait is this complete finish yes
sir that's a good question yeah after
you take on C1
H I don't see this as a complete finish
no how do you stop the checkm I don't
know I think the move Knight E2 is is
the strangest decision I can
imagine down to two minutes I how could
you not play Queen D1 in that moment
that was crazy still a lot of things
King 2 but King to H2 makes things a bit
easier right with this queen to E6
move Queen to
e the problem is whenever you take on
E5 there's going to be a check so so
there's no more Rook Queen E6 stops any
checks on the diagonal that's a good but
is Queen D5 the same move also stopping
the checks Queen D5 Queen E6 Queen with
nine seconds Jennifer played Queen E6
by way the nervous tensions getting to
Jennifer too because she made the move
pressed her clock and then adjusted her
Queen Once More on beam's time not the
proper etiquette anyway uh Rook E1 tell
me
how why did Jennifer take I go C1 oh
this I promote C1 oh no how did I I no
for sure that's
right Bishop Bishop
H okay this looks like a Desperado move
to my eyes well you want to Don't Take
The Rook on C1 because there is
Checkmate on
G7 for sure but that definitely looks
like a Desperado move can I play Queen
G6 protecting but that's oh because I
don't have Queen B3 check and attacking
can I take on C2 now that was the mate
by the way Jennifer down to 10 seconds
this is a with the queen on G3 yes G
exactly and I think that's 4 Seconds
come on Queen
G6 one second on the clock by way one
second on the clock oh my goodness but
wait is this check made on G7 it's no
it's check that's a
check
check what what is this about one second
how does Ray Robson I don't know how
they do it press their clock how they do
it how did Jennifer just press her clock
with one second so okay now she's gained
the minute she gains the 30 seconds
beging need to play King Bishop h8 right
now fast but then comes Queen G6 I don't
think we going to and queen G6 just wins
the game she needs to see that yes it
defends G7 we threaten The Rook you
cannot play Rook takes C2 You Queen
check loses the bishop right if you play
Rook takes C2 you get mated that's
simple that we understand it's about the
only thing about in this ending that
I've
understood what an Absolut Madness
finish to this tournament what a crazy
finish absolutely what's the count she's
she's about to play Queen G6 she still
has time she's about to play cuz she but
you know one second yeah Queen no Queen
E7 Queen what excuse me what is on Queen
E7 but now I can just take on
C2 there was one second away from
begging for being the
champion oh my goodness those
circumstances are you allowed to say now
I can
just because I think we've been saying
that for the last dozen moves half dozen
moves Queen E7 did you expect that move
okay no
no okay but you take on C2 let's go into
that end game right yeah because that's
a lot of pawns for that Bishop so Rook
takes Rook takes only one only one well
I'm going to take it also on F5 I'm not
sure if you want to do that because then
I give you a check on uh the B8 H2
diagonal and Knight G3 is coming picking
up the queen queen so you canot I lose
this game for both colors like three
times right but if you don't take on C2
then what else do you do I guess you can
TR
isang can you go Bishop F6 yeah I was
about to say isn't that a funny thing
but Bishop F6 I go Queen E3 right and
that's problematic I think Bishop F6
Queen E3 yeah that's attacking the rook
and we have that same checkmating and
the problem is if you try to go Bishop
h8 now I give you a check on F4 first
and then I pick up the Rook on C1 with a
check true
exactly no it's all gone now she has to
take on C2 she has to take on
C2 so I mean every time we say something
very
definitive uh we correct ourselves
immediately so Rook C2 Rook C2 Queen C2
King
h8 now again we can't take this Pawn
because Queen E5 Queen D6 check we get
ourselves
ped King has to move to H1 only move and
93 by the way just to mention that lanir
and Hans Drew so it means that
Wesley lanir and Mishra are all tied for
the second position we expected this but
Queen to E3 now finishes the
game
Queen Jennifer with 25 seconds
she's done it she found it Queen E3 and
it does feel suddenly like
Carissa is breathing a side relief
Karissa is buying a dinner to
Jennifer but who deserves it more I
don't know oh my goodness uh Queen E3
again we've got Queen F4 check and queen
takes C1 check
on tap so we don't have time to Bishop
h8 we cannot play Rook takes C2 because
that's the checkmating mechanism that
we've seen the zigzag to G1 oh actually
we can just go Queen G1 immediately we
don't have to do it by way can play uh
Queen A2 check by the way be him is down
to 25 seconds as well you have to check
guess what you don't get another check
but you don't have a followup is the
problem exactly no one second that made
a difference that J did not lose on time
yeah it's
crazy wow I have seen in um the American
Cup one second and we've got Queen A2
check that after King f8 only move
nothing to discuss that's it that was
your last
check yeah this looks uh this looks G oh
my goodness I mean you can try to go
Queen A4 that might be the only way out
A4 I think for both Karissa and beim
this was the first game that was really
up and down so many
times because the whole tournament
they've been pretty convincing with
their games Bishop Bishop G5 Bishop G5
with
the oh sorry Queen A2 Bishop G5 on the
board sorry
but that's just Queen takes G5 is
over Queen takes
G CU then the king just hides actually
after Queen A3 we have Queen
E7 Jennifer is triple checking but then
she captures that
Bishop Queen A3 check maybe we can move
our King around or even Queen
E7
yeah queen7 she grab that Queen because
I'm forcing a trade The Rook on C1 is
hanging that's it this is game over yeah
there's no coming back from this also
you have Queen C7 to defend the Rook on
C7 in case you try to go from h8 with
some checks Queen to A1 you can just
simply start with Queen Seven pick up
the Rook on C1 and that's it exactly
first time Caris can
breathe I feel the same for me I've been
holding my breath this whole time
that was wow what a turn of events I
mean beim was completely winning out of
the opening right and then things went
South I tell you Jennifer we've seen it
time and time again most definitively in
the Armageddon when she was a piece down
against Arena Crush decided not to
resign a losing position and went on to
win by the way um beame played Queen B2
yes this is where we were expecting
thing okay there is a check in the
position we can also play Queen D6 Queen
D1 and just grab the free rook but the
idea of just simply protecting The Rook
with a gain of tempo and then taking the
Rook there's no Perpetual checks of
course I just very nicely happily but I
feel like run still kind of queen D6
Queen D1 but then I I'm not sure about
that cuz you have queen of six ideas
after oh wow I don't know if I want to
allow that you're right just uh I want
to keep the Queen close to to my side
closer okay I agree closer Clos to my
side just a little closer yeah Queen C7
shck I like that that's
a very definitive
decision by the way sorry not for
nothing and I mean again it's the
vulture in me but King G8
okay no no one's gonna play nobody's
gonna play King G8 well it just stops
the
checks it just stops the checks okay
that's true because Rook cannot move
then I always promote yes that was what
I meant no but then you allow Queen B3
check I mean I allow what that's another
check on B3 why would you why would well
if I allow Queen HJ check I'm going to
allow you two or three check but at
least you got the Rook but I have
finally got the extra Knight Pawn on C2
you finally got the
Rook yes Jennifer Fells the same way I
don't know King G8 it feels like that
would be the the most elegant but okay
Queen HH is trying for that Perpetual
check
there it ain't there it just there's no
there
there uh King did come up yep to E7 we
can justen
takes the king is going to come up I
suppose to E6 or D6 D6 D6 was our choice
we go check and we take a a knight
E8 no Queen G6 on the board okay Queen
G6 King D6 Queen
G6 King
E5 that's a nice slalom of the board
the king is just going to hide on
B2 root Queen G3 check You're Expecting
King
D4 makes
sense she's done
it by the way is this the last remaining
game yeah because cly in the Ladi
section saw uh Ray Robson winning
against d
and Anna zatonski the Karen Cup champion
won her game King
C3 to the last full measure I mean
amazing ah what a
game Jennifer will be very happy for
that one second that just changed the
result of this game I'll be very happy
for having survived the commentary of
this game I was just blown away by the
back and forth that was taking place I
as you said was winning than it was even
then at end we just didn't know what was
happening so difficult to understand
what's happened Jennifer ran her clock
down to one second one second made her
move with a second ago and and it was
probably more like a third of a second
at that right we're going to I could she
made it because through the magic of
Television we got to count was that than
a thir of a second that was on clock
because that was wow so
crazy that was so crazy but King
C3 and just the king is going to that D2
square a women the most amazing Women's
Championship that we've ever called will
come to a close after we see the move
Knight D3 and we see both leaders losing
in their last round Yes again the only
tournament that comes to mind where that
has happened is the candidates London
2013 and Knight D3 and queen F6 check on
the board Queen
E5 that's that's a clincher the checks
have finished W yeah the music
ends our congratulations to Carissa Yip
for falling across the Finish Line at
the very end and for beum what a
disappointment it's it's a heartbreak
losing your last two games after having
the tournament of your life it's an
absolute heartbreak I mean oh oh she was
heartbroken yesterday just for the
simple fact that you know it's very
difficult to believe that you're going
to be able to come back you still have
to believe that you're going to be able
to come back with a victory but to have
that position and to see your opponent
your main competitor fall yeah stumble
in the last moment and then still not be
able to take advantage of that where
where that is take a look at the longest
one second in the history of Chess okay
come on let's zoom in on that okay she's
about to grab a piece and it's one
second right now one second then she
just grabs the pie move no way and hits
the clock on time that's crazy that is
actually less than a third of a second I
think that's less than a third of and
look at that Queen is it on D6 you tell
me but you know I'm I'm surprised it's
physically possible to make a move when
you have already one second and in time
wow hit that clock again one second
already this is what decided this
Championship that's what I meant to say
this is for the title bam wins if that
clock says zeros beum wins you I don't
know I it kind of It kind of
slid D6 to C6 if you play Queen C6 if
the Arbiter sh
dobes Queen G7 Ian if you look at the
percentage where the queen is more I
don't even know feel
we
before the Arbiter could say is we count
the percentages I should we stop it do
do we have a replay an appeal I don't
know wow uh by the way if you do make an
appeal what happens at that point if you
actually go back home and make an
appeal the queen is you sign the
scorches though that's the problem I
think once you sign the scores the game
is over that's for sure you don't sign
if you're going to make an appeal you
can't sign the scor I think now when
she's adjusting you simply need to stop
the vog and say where is the queen yes
but it's obviously on D6 obviously yeah
it happened before we've seen this type
of situation before it's obviously on D6
but I was a witness to the game luir
Lovich versus Jonathan Spielman where
laich's Rook was going to the h8 square
so it goes all the way across the eighth
rank to the eight square and uh the
Arbiter adjusts the rook and puts it on
G8 and lbo says no I put it on h8 the
Arbiter puts
and and the Arbiter was insistent luo
loses the game on the spot Jonathan
Spielman really versus draw yeah the
Arbiter wouldn't allow it wouldn't allow
it no wow he interfered with the players
the play both players understood it was
actually Jonathan Spielman who adjusted
The Rook on h8 and uh but what a finish
guys what a finish is still bit racing
right now big
time uh nobody's for sure by the way
this is what we there's no certainty in
this one the final standings wow Karis
say the 2023 US Women's Champion winning
$40,000 beim toir Jano incredible
performance so far but just losing the
last two important games in the
tournament uh being second and honestly
third place and winning
$20,000 and here is the winner of the
2023 US Women's chess champion ion
International Master Kar
congratulations and in the open I mean
again I'm just like
holding holding uh my my I'm stunned I
am just so stunn there was a big tie
there was a big tie for a second uh and
everybody's walking home uh the champion
year already yesterday we crowned
Fabiano Carana as the winner but then we
have a three-way tie Wesley so lenier
Dominguez which was maybe expected but
very young and new player on the field
abim Manu Mishra also tying for that
second place I think Ray Robson will be
very satisfied that he somehow after a
very bad start got a tie for fifth Hans
neeman's going to be disappointed and S
very pleased with his final performance
all earning
$115,000 that's not b and once again
here's our champion in the open the 2023
us chess champion Grand Master of
Fabiano
just incredible performance absolutely
and a backto back uh champion at that
that is uh very impressive and his
performance I mean he was very very
deserving I don't even know what to say
about Karissa and V who was the most
deserving they certainly turned this
event into a two horse race more or less
after they went on that streak right
they they that they drew one another in
round four they just and then they went
everything it was bowling pins right
they were just knocking everybody out of
the way two rounds to go and those last
two rounds right they understood we're
fighting for first and second there's
nobody else catching us so it's all
about in between us who's going to get
first and then you see that lip frogging
happens after begging just if you think
about it she CLA claim the draw right
there against Arena we're at least in a
tie break if everything goes like it did
today right crazy we're in tie breaks
with half a point out of two in the last
couple of rounds but she loses two of
them in a row right
heartbreaking heartbreaking but you can
imagine how happy Karissa is right now I
mean Karissa it's kind of a stunning
thing I don't even know what you do at
that point do you watch the final few
seconds your heart broken that you've
already lost but I remember she's
probably crying somewhere being consoled
by her dad of course and then her dad
picks up his phone he looks at the
result and like by the way wait minut
I mean all friends on our writing CS
just like wait what's happening 60
incoming messages I remember a very very
heartbroken um Magnus Carlson loses the
last round game uh against Peter fidler
and the
candidates and it's told that uh
Vladimir karnick lost and by the way you
have the better tie breaks Magnus you're
the winner and Magnus is like what he
jumped in the pool he jumped in the pool
that was CH that was the chai that was
the but I think he jumped in the pool in
that one as wellbe yes but oh my gosh uh
winning by tie breaks I remember seen it
in the movie Magnus I think they kind of
discussed this scen what Magnus was
feeling and yeah it's just incredible
that you lose and then you qualify
Anyway by way yeah great biography for
those of you have we we have to see that
final moment because this whole
championship about that last second that
Jennifer you had forever taking one on
take a look at this right if you if you
think the SpaceTime Continuum stop
that's one second right there second
like she you just grabbed your
queen and you're slapping the clock I
did very and then Jennifer is checking
like did I make the time control or not
I mean did I and now the queen ends up
closer to the C6 Square which would
allow Queen G7 mate and she adjust sit
back wow this is crazy okay now we're
going to do it in real time not in
slowmo but real time and she adjust
the and it's like she looked at the
clock yeah yeah yeah I made it I made it
yeah yeah of course that is the
championship wow that's how these
tournaments well I have to say I haven't
seen this type of drama in a long time
we see drama in every single event that
we
have but our 20 23 Champion is with us
Christian take it away
please Karissa our hearts are racing
everybody is wondering what in the world
just transpired for the last few moves
in that final second were you watching
that
game um no I actually wasn't I was in
bed being sad about how I threw away
everything in attempt to to win um so
yeah I was really in like the depths of
my Despair and then I got a call from
like a bunch of people and they were
like you have to come back to the club
because you're going to be the new
champion and I was like what this what a
nice story this must be a such an
intriguing way to win a championship
right you went through the spectrum of
all possible emotions out there you were
obviously exhilarated winning so many
games one after the other but then those
last last couple of rounds you are half
a point behind you come back leate prag
your opponent then this final round
first of all how did you strategize in
your mind this final round were you
thinking that this is a must-win
situation for
you um not really I was sort of like you
know a draw would be okay um but then I
got to the board and while I was playing
I was like you know what actually I
would really rather win um I don't know
I just like I really thought begum would
win and I was like I I don't want to
play another day of
Chess um not not cuz you know I hate the
game or anything but it's just like for
the last month or so I've been playing
Non-Stop and I was like another playoff
and I'll have to prep again and I'm
really behind on all my homework so I
was planning on using tonight to catch
up on that um so I was like I'm going to
I'm going to win this game and in the
work end game it really felt like I was
pressing um but then I was just like low
on the clock blundered
everything and I was I was so sad and I
was like you know what like I don't even
deserve to be a champion if you know I'm
making these sorts of blenders in a
position where I just need a draw and
where I like had a draw um so I was
super disappointed in
myself but luckily things worked out
okay yes absolutely and you had the
opportunity by the way to repeat the
position a few times and even in that
last final moves it was that idea of
going Rook to G3 and Rook to G1 started
with a move
C7 when you play the move C7 did you
realize that after Rook to F1 you
lost I think I played B5 but yeah I was
just yeah I had spent so much time
beforehand you know um I kind of saw my
way up to this position and for some
reason I just missed that after Rook F1
Rook G1 King somewhere I mean Rook G3
King somewhere Rook G1 black just has
Rook D1 and I was like spending all my
time calculating Rook df6 um so it's
just like a terrible terrible
miscalculation in it um so you were
looking at df6 here this what you were
cating yeah and then White's just doing
great here but I just missed Rook D1
completely and um I don't know blind
spot I guess
and yeah once it was played on the board
I was like um once I saw this so ricky1
idea I was like oh my God like yeah I
kind of threw away everything and I was
like checking begam game at the same
time and everything and uh for some
reason I still thought that you know I
should try to fight for the win but I I
really shouldn't have um but yeah this
is kind of mistake that I make a lot of
the times but hopefully this will be the
last but Karissa I have to uh we have to
replay this final moment of the final
second that Jennifer had on her clock
did you see this and take us through
your emotion when you're seeing it right
now as a
replay
two
[Music]
one wow one second on
I I think that was less than one second
way less than one
second I mean it's different now that I
know the result of the game but uh you
know if I was watching it live I would
be I would be scared but I think since
the broadcast is on a the broadcast is
on a delay um so I wasn't seeing the
most the first time stuff yeah wow wow
well Karissa I'll give you guys the
floor right now just an incredible I
don't want the floor you just ex I want
the
ceiling congratulations Carissa we're
going to leave it there I we just wow uh
amazing amazing amazing stuff we were
watching Jennifer make her move with one
second on the clock and we were just
like wow how does that one second last
so long but I do have to admire like
your spirit to really push for the dra
draw I mean push for the win at all cost
to be kind of risking that I was so
terrified when the pawn was on E2 and I
was like I would just go for Perpetual
I'm scared something is going to happen
so um you know that's why you're a
better player than me that's why I'm not
a battle player because I'm you know too
kind of maybe worried but you just kind
of were calculating and it didn't work
out this time but maybe it's going to
work another because you had that
fighting
spirit thank you you our congratulations
again as we close the show I'm just
looking for the first time at the uh
women's uh results and I'm seeing every
single game was decisive there was not a
single draw in today's uh Championship
round wow again final standings in the
US Women's championships Karis s winning
it in just incredible fashion $40,000
second beim toova and third Alis
wow Christian we just like shaking your
ass like this is absolutely crazy wow
and that one second I mean look we've
been doing this for a long time but I
don't think I've seen this before that's
a disappointment for myself as well for
my
Pi you we got to give her you know got
to give the flowers to Sabina absolutely
got new we have all the stage there K
say be janova and Alis Le that's that's
not bad that's not bad okay far hadto no
come on we cannot all be of
course I mean if he participation
trophy my absolutely but we do have some
extra special guests as uh we get uh uh
with this uh final final uh day I
seriously I just have to say this has
been an incredible eventful day I had no
idea when I got up this morning that we
were going to be calling this kind of a
championship I remember yesterday saying
that the script needs to be written well
for today I think was written very well
but we have Anna in studio with you
Christian Anna difficult event for you
but everything that finishes well it's
much more pleasant to take home a
victory for you in the last round how
are you feeling right now give us your
assessment of this competition for
you uh competition uh in overall of
course I'm not happy with my result and
I lost four games in a row and very
happy to win in last round even if I I
don't look like happy it's always good
to finish on good absolutely results
yeah and losing like four games was so
frustrating especially like yesterday I
had winning position versus um Karissa
congratulations I'm very happy for her
and but still I tried to win yesterday
and missing like Queen C5 which like my
husband says it was winning for me after
Queen C5 yesterday absolutely yes and
you've had a good year so far in terms
of results Great result at the Ken cup
sure less great result in this one but
what's next for you an
know uh I don't have uh probably I would
like to play like World rid and Blitz
championship and like usually I have
good results in blit and I hope to train
with proper training I I finally can I
don't know get a medal or something well
I don't know even if this event will
take place where like every year I'm
playing and this is probably going to be
next result next next tournament for me
absolutely it's uh that that tournament
we never know exactly where it's going
to be when it's going to be and then
it's announced a couple of weeks before
Anna thank you very much for joining us
we'll see you in the next tournament
here in St Louis yeah thank you and uh
no we've got a lot of Chess still to be
done and these are the next Grand
Chester events gate yeah we have St
Louis rapid and Blades November 12th to
November 19th and then the big event
sinkfield cup November 19th through
December 3rd as we will be crowning a
grand chestor champion I think it's 1.2
million in total prizes for this it's
why they call it the granddaddy of the
mall field Cup coming up November 19th
through December 3rd and we'll all be
looking forward to that one absolutely
one of the best tournaments in the year
it really really is it's
magnificent and for tomorrow we do have
the closing ceremonies coming up I do
believe that we will be um uh live
streaming and and will the coverage will
start at 6 p.m. that's it 6 p.m. uh
central time yes
exactly
good and we have uh the spoiler uh our
defending Champion Jennifer you we're
getting her prepared as a Christian
you've got lots of questions for
Jennifer Jennifer uh just a wild Affair
in today's game and uh after the opening
it felt you were pretty much busted and
it showed on your face as well at some
point you weren't even watching the game
it felt like you're fighting you're
fighting but you don't believe in your
position as much yet you managed to get
back into the game how did you do
that um well I think I just got a pretty
bad position have the opening I don't
really I don't I am prep this I don't
play this so I I just I don't know why I
did this but I guess I just didn't want
to play anything else so I I was like
let's just play the nimzo don't really
know it but um so not the best position
but I was just you know trying to make
it interesting for a little bit and then
I think when she let me um get my
Knights like in the center and they were
able to stay there and you know there
wasn't any breaks and I think I was
doing starting to come back into the
game at that point but for a while there
it did look pretty bad absolutely and it
was after the time control how did you
assess position uh the position after
the time control at this point excuse me
I don't have the right game somewhere
around here after this trade you have
the C Pawn you have the beautiful Knight
in the center but at the same time white
has her trums as well especially this
Pawn on A4 that could potentially round
down the board very quickly how did you
assess
it um honestly I thought I had really
good chances here because it's just very
easy for me to play if I'm able to get
my um Pawn pushed and also you have to
worry about checks along the diagonal
from A7 B1 actually if you go back I
don't know if I was supposed to play um
f F5 here yeah was best this what we're
talking about if I was best okay because
I wasn't sure if we should do queen E5
first because Queen E5 doesn't let um
Bishop C3 like what that happened but
this
was yes yeah so this is like oh I mean
apparently Queen to uh F3 and after that
Rook to D1 to get the Rook behind and
supposedly I'm faster than you are with
the c Pawn
yeah yeah so this is what um I thought
about for a long time but I decided to
go with F5 first absolutely and of
course that opened up the game it wasn't
easy in fact even at this point the
computer is still saying that this is
equal but with some crazy moves in the
position yet I do want to see that final
second of yours one more time maybe you
haven't seen it yet I know you felt it
but tell us your feelings going into
through through this through the motions
at this
[Laughter]
point no I
yeah I mean my question is how did you
stop time like you had one second and
you managed to make a move and hit the
clock that's right because you see there
is one second and you haven't even
picked up your queen
yet right there that's when you pick up
your queen you have one
second boom
that's the longest one second in chest
that's
crazy no when I when I realized that I
was like there's no way I'm about to
flag this game right now cuz I've done
this so many times in the past like it's
embarrassing how many times I flagged a
game of increment just because I like
forget sometimes I'm about to run out of
time and then this happens but I somehow
caught it um in the very end but yeah
that that was really embarrassing for a
second wow guys
questions for Jennifer after that game
after that
finish I'm
still yeah yeah yeah um wow um just so
many questions and uh confusions and
everything else it wasn't your
tournament Jennifer but I have the
feeling that you really like Fighting
Chess you're like today you fought your
way back it's your openings your
openings are really letting you down
you've had bad positions coming out of
the openings you had a bad position
today you fought your way back in is it
just school workor is pre pre preventing
you from really improving your openings
what's what's the problem Jen um yeah
that was the main problem going to this
tournament I just hadn't reviewed
openings in forever and then I probably
should have tried to squeeze in time but
it's it was just difficult and then here
I didn't have the best prep um honestly
sometimes no prep um like yesterday
against Alice was genuinely like going
to that game I just did not feel like I
just didn't want to play that day cuz um
I had to take like a test so I just
stayed up all night so I like all
nighter like zero sleep so didn't really
prep all that much so that was just
horrible feeling just like horrible day
and then um yeah like going to this
round I mean I just like I feel like I
also just kind of been not as motivated
to like do prep here even though I just
because I wasn't you know feeling the
tournament but I really should have cuz
like that I think that was one of my
problems cuz before in the past like
even if I didn't like do so well I'd
always like still try my best towards
the end but I think I was just
struggling a bit um especially when I
was like balancing a lot of different
things so um yeah I think I just like
need to really think about how I want to
manage my time in the future and you
know U set different priorities cuz you
know realistically like looking back at
this tournament um this was like a bit
too challenging for me to play this at
during this time in my school year for
this semester especially so um you know
I did you know I did come play some
interesting games but I I did wish I did
did things
differently uh Jennifer I don't have a
question but I have a compliment first
of all congratulations on winning this
absolutely crazy game but I have to say
that you really keep us entertained the
last Armageddon game with Bishop G4 you
know being pieced down and then just
like fighting it through and winning
that game and now just winning this game
uh just fantastic really
congratulations thank you thank you um
actually like before before this year
like back before like I won my first US
Champs I would play spoiler a lot
because I would always be playing
someone who was like in contention the
last round and I I I just I always love
doing that like I mean not love it but
like it's just kind of fun because
everyone's like watching your game and I
mean the pressure is on them so it's
like an interesting thing absolutely
Jennifer thank you so very much we'll
see you at the closing
ceremonies and here are our Champions
the US Women's chest Champion
International Master Karis say
congratulations there was never any
doubt oh sorry I meant in Fab's sorry
sorry and then the 2023 us chess
champion Grand Master Fabiano Carana
again our congratulations wrap it up for
us Christian what ENT I don't have any
yeah after this one I absolutely have no
words left absolutely amazing couple of
national championships we knew that
they're going to be dramatic but I don't
remember the last time I called such a
final game I mean this one kudos to the
players kudos to us as well because we
survived we Sur I'm
getting just an incredible couple of
national championships once again
congratulations to the winner uh Fabiano
Carana in the open section and of course
kis a in the ladies section just an
incredible battle all throughout these
two national championships incredible
competitors all of them and they've
given us just an incredible show really
really enjoy calling the action with you
Christian and with you great calling
action really big shout out to the World
Chess Hall of Fame for hosting the
tournament and being such a great host
to the St Louis chess club for all the
support the prize fund to Silverback our
production team here in St Louis you
guys do an absolutely absolutely
incredible job thank you thank you thank
you and to you viewers for watching usly
absolutely for sharing your day uh join
us tomorrow as we will bring you live
streaming the uh closing ceremonies and
really 6 p.m. wonderful thank you good
night bye
[Music]
everyone
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited